Testing, testing. Attention, please. Attention, attention. Hear you, hear you.
Skyrim belongs to the North. That's my hear you, hear you. Why are you saying I
hate you? I'm not even fricking spawning yet! Let me spawn in! You know, I learned
something new yesterday thanks to TikTok so I can't wait to talk about it.
Right, testing. This is Ambroker. See this fricking, you fricking freaks? Oh my God! Oh my
God! I'm YouTube, I got accepted from YouTube monetization like right now. No
way! I just got accepted for YouTube monetization right fricking now. No way!
Wait, but I need to do my stream then. Wait! Oh my God! I literally just opened up
YouTube studio. I've been accepted. No way! Wait, do I need to go offline and do my...
No, I'll do it tomorrow. Oh my God! We did it! What the frick? What the frick frack
tiddly-tack-tick-tack-patty-work? Oh my God! Wait, and hopefully this doesn't say anything.
Wow! Wow! I just fricking checked. Right, right. We're still going to do Skyrim
today because you know, Skyrim belongs to the Norths. But tomorrow I'll get to do my
monetization celebration stream! And my toe is like amazing for it so I'm excited.
Oh my God! That's amazing. Right, if you're fricking watching right now, don't
worry about how you call it. The memberships aren't activated because I
need to go in and tell it what to call the tiers and stuff. But I'm 100%
sure tier one is $1.99 USD. This is to prevent anyone gaining access via
gift to membership streams. And then I believe the membership price, like the
actual price, is $4.99 USD. Does that sound right? I need to ask you guys. I need to ask you guys what sounds right.
You guys call the shots. Yeah, if it's $4.99 USD and then Patreon's $5 USD then it's $9.99 total to
support your Oshii at Veiler. You're okay. That seems right. Okay, that sounds
okay. Everyone's going to give me the thumbs up.
Congrats on the monetization. Doesn't mean we won't support you in other ways anymore though.
Oh, thank you so much. I really appreciate it.
Why are you giving me money for getting more money?
What the fuck? It's an infinite money glitch. Oh my God. Also, there was an offline donation
by Shank. Shank says, thank you for the tip, by the way. He says, I'm over here squidding
my dick. I got ink on my dick right now. Which is so good. Thank you, Tim Shuttle. Congrats
on the monetization. Thank you. And Bajinga as well. Thank you again for the tip, for
the 20. That was a big tip. Thank you. Okay, to prevent gifts, you need to set the membership
quote above five bucks. Are you serious? Wait, wait, wait, wait. Wasn't it not membership
can only be gifted? Stop giving me! Why are you giving me money for being able to make
Oh my God. No, I have to end my ASMR series now. I have four ASMR videos. I owe you. Oh,
and I'm doing an endurance stream today. It's over. Reluctantly saying thank you for the
tip. Wait, I could have sworn you can only gift the lowest tier membership on YouTube
or has that been updated since? I won't say who so they can announce it themselves, but
someone else has also gotten monetized. Oh my God, we're all done are monetized. No way.
Like, okay, so the only reason we didn't like monetize faster in quotation marks is because
you stop it. Don't give me money for getting money. Preordering my search. Thank you. Don't
stay down for the tip. That's crazy. That's freaking crazy. Gifts go to the most expensive
tier under five bucks. So I need to set it as 501. That looks terrible though. That looks
so greedy, but I can't have any outsiders in the membership streams because I need to
use a lot of euphemisms. Are you squid me right now? Shank. Oh, it's offline. I'm all
about stron of the bath. Thanks, Shank, for the tip. You guys will get the Blackwater
reference very shortly. Super training up. Virginia. Stop. Actually, one cent greed law.
Actually, it's two cent greed because I wanted it $4.99 as fat. Said it to sit. No, $6 is
too much. This is too much money to ask for, like, for membership stuff. Oh, right, that's
it. When I said we're making an agency together, we flinched. I wasn't kidding. Oh, I see.
And our snowberries are here. They just did an ASMR stream. We all have to keep our voices
down, okay? The snowberries are asleep. Fine, you've got it. Set it to 999. I would start
at $60 just to be sure. Post up. Hi, icy raiders. Hi, snowberries. I just unlocked monetization.
I didn't know until I freaking went on my channel. It just happened right now. I'm not
going to do my monetization celebration today. I'm going to do it tomorrow and then it gives
me less time to do endurance skyrim unless we come back to maybe switch up the thingy.
But that's okay. It's actually a perfect transition from icy stream. Hi, hi, little icicle.
But yes, we are all getting monetized very slowly, which is fantastic. Oh my gosh, you can get
support via email or chat. Don't worry, that chat support thing does absolutely nothing.
I assure you, it doesn't do a single thing, okay? I actually, I tell a lie, they did help me one
time, so I'll give it up. Amy, thank you, Amy, for your clap, clap, clap. Apparently, there's
one other person that has been processed. When we applied, it was like, yeah, it takes a month
for them to review your chat. A month! A month to review James Cameron's avatar, excuse me.
A month to freaking review Assassin's Creed Brotherhood, excuse me. Oh no, no, oh you guys
so much ASMR video. But I do have some good news about VTuber Collabs. I finally, I finally
sent away. So now I'm waiting on the girls. The ball is now in the girls court that I'm collabing
with. Yeah, yesterday, I was listening to a music creator called Yoast. He's a Dutch and he was in
Eurovision and he said, welcome to Europe. Life is till the end, Europe, Europe, Europe. Turns out he has
a song where it goes, suck my, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm. So just imagine me playing the song and
repeat in the dark, taping up four ASMR collabs in one go. A month review time sounds realistic,
given the fact that your streams are all above 10 hours. Like I also thank you for the tip again,
but you're giving a lot of money. You need to be careful. Are you screaming me right now?
Thank you for the tip. Oh my God. Damn, I almost got that song out of my head. Yeah, so basically
just imagine me in a dark room. Just, I had this song on repeat. I'm like, yeah, okay. Right,
Wolf Mums, Pamper You to Sleep, right? Okay, what's next? Okay, Jealous VTubers drag you in an
alleyway for tangos. Okay, but what's next? What's next? Right, next script now. Like I was on it.
I was on it. Anonymous. It's the silent and on his back. He's giving money, but he's not saying
anything. He's not getting Brian to say anything. Thank you for the tip. But yeah, anyway, that's
how I work. I don't know how you work, but I work like a madman. Had to take a shower. So I've got
to listen at 1.5 speed for the next 15 minutes. I was not prepared for the super speed beat up.
So I was as strong as I forgot to live tweet or tweet. If you mean tweet, I have absolutely
horrific news. I am the worst VTuber to ever spawn. I never use my emotes. I spent like so much on
all these emotes. I never use them. I never tweet out when I'm live, because I start at the same
time every single day and I'm like, you want to be here, you're gonna be here. Somebody,
absolutely. Next script. YouTube to monetize you one day after you get approved. I mean,
depending on how the monetization celebration goes tomorrow, that's quite plausible. But hey,
at least a little bit YouTube history. Don't mind if I make the headlines for Veal Ur. So
you guys go and support my gen mates. That's right. There are five other lovely girls in the
description below for you to check out. If you cannot stand, Todd winning yet again with the
Death Grip, the Skyrim has over female VTubers. Okay. So if you've had enough of that,
Denny, you worry. I've got you sorted out. Sheepsters is going live in two minus two hours.
I believe Emma and Azura, my goodness Azura, and is coming for my Endurance Stream title.
For Goodness Gravy, she was up on a farm. No, it's not called Farmville. The farming star,
Jew Valley, for goodness sake. And then she beady popped out of 10 of her Endurance Stream. I'm
like, damn, they're coming from my title. I'm gonna show them how it's done. Okay, I'm gonna show
them how it's done. I woke up feeling sick and I was like, oh, maybe I would do an Endurance Stream.
But the moment I hit go live, it feels like I have been given a second burst of energy,
a second wind, if you will. It's like that cinematic moment in like the video game
thing. We're like, oh, Brian.
Congrats on monetization. Does the meet and greet VIP pass come with the highest membership tier
pre-order? Zarian. Dapper. Why would you give 100? That's so much. You never even said anything,
Dapper bucket. Oh my God. Thank you for the 100. Iron Reaper 100. Why are you? Why are you giving me
money for being able to earn more money? What's going on? What's going on? Have I missed something
in the VTuber etiquette book? Iron Reaper, thank you for the 100. Dapper, thank you for the 100.
Zarian, congrats on monetization. Meet and greet for anyone who goes over $20 on the donut.
That's terrible. You can't say that part out loud. Literally, everyone is giving your,
yeah, please make sure you are fully sorted before you give any money. Please understand,
I adore what I do. I have been welcomed with open arms into the VTuber community as someone who
could definitely have been described as an outsider. And instead of being shunned,
I was welcomed and taught the ropes, which I'm so thankful for. But please understand,
like, I can stream for free. I love what I do, okay? Anonymous with a 20 with no message again.
Brian, you look, you need to put Brian to work, guys, okay? You need to put Brian to work. Oh,
Anonymous gave me 20 because I said the 20 thing. That is terrible. But we've done it. We
officially have finished our first week at Bueller headquarters. Literally, everyone has done
fantastic streaming. I am very happy to see some of the girls taking a break.
Orvon Biscay. Brian. We don't like giving YouTube a cut.
Wait, oh, that's why you just stream elements. Okay, I understand. I read about that. Thank you,
Orvon Biscay. Brian! Don't knows will continue until morale improves. Congratulations. Wait,
why did I know that? Quote. Do you guys hear Brian at all when he talks? Yeah, you do. Surely you do.
Oh my god. Wait, you said I said your name yesterday correctly. Rilke? Rilke? Cadmus?
Thank you for the tip. Why did I know that quote? Yeah, we hear him. Okay, thank god.
God, it feels like so much longer. You've always been here. I think because, like,
my average streamed week is probably what a VTuber achieves in an entire month. So it feels like
I've been here for a very long time. I was like, nope, this is officially my first, like,
strong, you know, first second week of streaming. Ancient joke. The beatings will continue until
the more. Okay, that's okay. Okay, okay, okay. Guys, do you know a perfect way to party the
achievement? A really big storm of bad joke. What did you even say? Was that supposed to be a joke?
I don't get it. I don't get the joke if that was supposed to be a joke. So you're getting crickets.
Who's ready? Who's ready for bi-zura, bi-zura, bi-zura. Now, I know that's not in this game,
but bi-zura. Remember that time I accident... Wait, can you hear the game?
Can you hear any of that? You can't hear any of that.
Oh, oh, oh, wait, get monetization off the screen right now.
Oh, my freaking mouse won't hover over... Right, there we go.
Oh, my voice is cracking already. I've never even started.
Oh, oh, oh.
Don't begin. Don't begin. Don't begin of Skyrim. Don't know the words. One of them was like,
all glass for a meme fucking cover.
Bite pulp, Bryan. This is our attempt at normalizing corporate green-free donations fanning.
wait no are you guys neutral it wait you oh god thank you so much for all the
tips holy sugar thank you Etherna a oh my god my mouse won't hover over OBS so I
can lower the volume of the freaking game oh it's so loud oh that's getting
loud right I've turned it down a wee bit and turned me up there's a Brian echo
now right I guess I'll just play him through desktop only I'll just need
test if this works okay okay it works it works okay okay let's jump into it do
you know the actual lyrics it's like Dovahkin Dovahkin Dovahkin of Skyrim level
one oh it's been so freaking long since I've played this game oh my god it's
Emmys debut me me me me me me no mods of course right no vanilla I'm
appreciating the game and its release quality and I do understand those who
prefer a modded experience I like to appreciate a game the way it's been
released I understand there's always time constraints there's always stuff that
has been taken out for example ruining the thieves guild
but I just I want to appreciate it how it is wait I didn't hear any of that if
that played Daria from souls time to high rocks Skyrim is for the North's
first world ah oh I'm on controller by the way because I'm used to playing X
box no mods as good as God intended as Brian talking at all I don't hear Brian
all no can you guys hear Brian I can't hear him he said the loon
ah oh I need to put subtitles on as well ah freaking pause the game hold on oh
my god oh my god I can't see my mouse it's not giving me my freaking cursor
please please stop this madness please right you're just gonna have to deal
with double Brian oh my god that's like proper pause holy shit reluctantly
saying thank you for the 20 I think you drop it
relatively need to get that memebership after all also hey you're finally wait
you're trying to cross that border it's our the leader of the storm cloaks
Yarl thank you reluctantly saying for the tip gaming kits funny congrats
Johnny also I found this don't I think you dropped it giving me money giving me
money because I made money should be of home I'm from Rorick's dad
ah look it's cinematic it is let's get that so far we look like
and you hand touches the be no hear me and obey I found out I think into my
dreams a darkness that will allure you thank you
meredaya meredaya meredaya there is the tip all right you guys are giving too
much money I was more of a fallout guy cause I'm the wanderer the Wanderer
roam around around around I'm a wanderer I'm what stop pay are you finally
awake I'm here to create order my name no that's so much money it rocks are we
supposed to say your names it rocks away it rocks away thank you for the tip I
appreciate it I'm Reaper again thank you for the tip identifying yourself as a
fallout wanderer apparently we can do fallout 76 multiplayer I don't know how
it's gonna work too much monetization get absolutely loved on there how dare
you meredaya is the God who owns the beacon ah right we're ERPing now as a
Skyrim and day deities yes yes Johnny please make the stop that's funny as
anything okay every right we're gonna be role-playing out the wazoo
100% Nord what is the bill today
eh grembo thank you for the congrats and the tip we are Nord build okay we are
Nord we are Stormcloak we are enjoying the game as the resistance or the
opposition to what the Legion is trying to put on the upon Skyrim as a whole
okay so Skyrim is the current region that we're in there's different regions
such as Hammerfell for example oh Brian you'd rather go to the woods with a
high elf or a grizzly bear um I don't know could that take on a high elf I
feel like I'm really weak apparently polar bears are actually the most
aggressive breed of bear if you didn't know that grizzly bears actually avoid
human intervention apparently right so we are Nordic a citizens of Skyrim they
are tall and fair-haired people strong and hardy Nord are famous for the
resistance to cold and their talent as warriors they can use a battle cry to
make opponents flee fantastic and are we gonna be a man or a woman oh um okay
okay just a few technicals be a technical difficulties
you get to the cloud district very often oh what am I saying of course you
don't thank you Nazim are you roleplayed as NPCs of Skyrim Nazim I'm not
really I don't know if you can hear that but that's me click and select on Nord
oh it's trigger is this where the membership pre-orders happen stop
a Rico thank you for the tip why are you I don't understand another week of my
new daily routine work from five to one and then
strong a time from two to two followed by sleep from two fifteen no that's so
unhealthy bear oh that's so unhealthy oh my god and take my money guys what the
hey Terminator 101 thank you Phoenix thank you no breaks on this
saliring train oh my god you guys are in it you're in it to win it now do I get
to play a whammin I get to be a whammin or do you guys not like when whammin I
don't know I feel like if we're serious that someone's booty all day I'd rather
pick a whammin you know but thank you so much for all these tips Phoenix bear on
a zeme yeah yeah Nazim a Rico Tario the freaking there's so many tip become
whammin okay I'm only to be one in here yeah wait run guard what's the matter
someone steal your sweet role oh my someone's do your sweet role I was to be
able to do the accent in Skyrim but then I'm completely bloody forgotten how to do
it I'll need to listen to it more and right we're gonna be young and pretty
and so we'll use that face we're gonna be white as possible because you'll never
guess what color I am and the reason why you don't do skinny is because a skinny
is possible is because the clothes texture on the shoulders can you see
that you actually are better if you want less clothes a mashing to put the
weight up just a wee tiny wee bit and for the complexion again we're wanting
young and it are do we want freckles I don't know freckles mainstream forget
we'll get no dirt do you want to kill scar and the name of the nodes I pray to
the Lord's you all get a taste of my blade and my sword and I'm taking on
hordes of enemies I'm going on hordes of weaponry's I think I think cheeky
little scars on the face there just the kind of show that we mean business okay
where is here I don't really I'm not really fussed for all this stuff neck color I didn't
even know that was a sentence with me right now I'm pretty good Tony and say a quick
congrats on oh thank you soon you deserve it after all your hard work thank you so much for
the tip for good Tony honestly I would have like if YouTube updated its things like we all made
watch time on day one after debut which is in shame which is insane what color are eyes
no way I've lost my right give us give us the sexy eyes okay do we want like piercing eyes
like I'm looking into your that's I'm looking into your soul eyes I used to be an adventure
no then I took an arrow to the knee thank you for the love how this entire phrase is a euphemism
for marriage tying you down from your aw oh wait oh not the old ball and chain ruining my skyrim
adventures uh Tharya thank you for the tip literally the old ball and chain I want to like
I want piercing eyes to be like yeah I'm a Nord by the way that's realistically piercing yeah I'll
do it I'll do it we just need to change the hair because then I like the hair oh let's see what we'll
go look to look to the second one this is girl simulator right no we're gonna have
hair on you there's no point in having me here is there bunches like me I don't think there's
any bunches I feel like an adventure doesn't have time to like perfectly pleat her hair oh look at
that nose bridge she got a nose job it's so pretty uh I don't oh I'm not we're not doing the mohawk
I can tell you that much right now there's really no bunches I know this game came out in 2011 but
bunches nay bunches girl nose damn bills wrap yes vanilla skyrim
stop stream no bunches need to get some mods going honestly uh right oh that's redonkulous
oh that looks kind of cool that was badass but what claw are we gonna be blonde Nordic or we're
going to be black here Nordic uh the black the black is me but I don't know if we're going like
blonde like perfect waifu type thing I mean she's got the smoky eyes going a little smoky eyelash
and liner I can see it I got a little scar going you know show how go red why would I red that's
the red no there's no red black is better okay I think black really accentuates like
okay done how'd I do done what's her name I can buy youtube premium with paypal but not membership
youtube is a bitch my membership isn't even up yeah iron reaper you're like 10 steps ahead of me
what do we call ourselves uh we're the drag some things I don't know sometimes that react on me right
born stop right there criminal scum just giving congrats on money oh thank you so much scrumptious
nightmare I appreciate it so much why the frick frag diddley duck are you all giving me money though
like don't and don't deny explaining why you're giving me money like why you're giving me money
forgetting money via monetization just put it in the chat okay just put it in the chat I don't
understand why you're giving me money for the ability to make money Nazim's wife right um I quite
like doing vanilla like call yourself dragonborn or unless she's gonna call me dragonborn twice
Jamal seaborn okay dude uh but that's genius because you're in to support the next gen oh
okay okay oh I like that all right I'll I'll accept the money if you want to the next generation of
daughters uh but just remember the only reason that we have five daughters in the first place is
because of what happened in the ASMR booth all lights were turned off so we'll need to just uh
if you want that again right we're gonna just call ourselves dragonborn I like role playing
directly um as the character's name uh I don't know why I just like it I like being lower friendly
call her she goes to the block I see one more time did you guys what at least you'll die here
here's some oh okay riko but yeah mystery money my booty crack I cast mended butt crack
thank you so much for all the tips my god you guys are facing the day though you should
hold back how about you hold back okay just hold stop dragon dies nuts across your
okay now I left my sprinkler on you
brian oh my god strong strong yeah tell me how to spend my money all right okay shipy scottles
thank you for the tip dragon dies nuts if you can blame any more that we gave you money I'll put
two more oh behind that's me shut up for the rest of the stream about the dough knows I can assure
you that much a big out thank you so much shipy scottles um or von biscuit again for the tip and
iron rip or again for the tip I will no longer complain uh let me be clear oh we're literally
watching someone get beheaded by the way my ancestors oh wait hold on we need to put uh
um we need to put subtitles on because I am dead no display love you
I love you too a little replay anonymous I love you too anonymous thank you for the tip I appreciate
you what he's you're pretty squid me right now totally not budget okay you're done thank you for
the tip where's my subtitles did I not just put them on am I going crazy and maybe crazy
no one saw that by the way no one saw wait I did oh general no one saw that by the way
and it changes later on when we need to do a little to me a legendary dragon
but no one saw that okay what did I just do anonymous tipped and said money right
thank you anonymous I appreciate you squid me right okay I got it from a company called
villa model icy snow pause yellow sprinklers is different but welcome did you right thank you
for the tip that did you guys see emmy's not safe for work I almost like through the screen I was
having a sample you know how I'm sampling american uh like uh fizzy juice uh oh oh we're loading in
we're loading into the gameplay section oh my god the controls are all wrong I give the best
head it's just not mine executioner oh my god the controls are all crouched is freaking analog
stick when it should be run I will change this once we get out unbound uh real and true
she wanted the emanate the emanate oh my god that's genius sorry right this is going to break so
don't if this is games too loud just tell me I can turn it down I'll do it no he's burning everything
so uh when I first played this game uh my dad was watching me both of us couldn't figure out I was
supposed to do this we kept going back and forth at the same area but like I handed it to him on
like dad going you do this bit and he's like I don't know what you're doing either okay you need to
hide behind here to not be hit by the dragon's glass um 60 millilitres of our nectar the emanate
I have her notice on I see everything my little sister post ha I was so glad you guys are like
enjoying her and her character like obviously getting me concepted was like are we doing this and
it was like oh my god like real or is doing this holy crap oh neat crouched neat crouched
she doesn't see us even though that wearing his sign is up why don't you all do it yeah I hope she
will bottle and ship it actually I forgot to get back to her about permission for something which
you guys will really enjoy I don't know um I don't know if she's still lurking uh right heart
wait hold on boo boo hey too we hate you uh to the to a bit spit on his face we don't we're not going
with you yeah yeah oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god it's drama it's drama we're going with the
storm folk which is blue because the red are the baddies
uh actually can't we strongly really said chat's this real when making any
um right can you unbound me yet so I can start fixing my controls oh my god he's not got a pulse
yeah he's what is known as a ragdoll looks like we're the only ones who made it
that thing was a dragon yeah we don't like people who aren't no if you actually know the lore of
Skyrim it's actually pretty outrageous I don't know why the storm cloaks are the baddies I'm
not going mental but from what I know the Thalmor not the Thalmor the age the Thalmor oh no the Thalmor
Embassy is it the Thalmor they came into Skyrim and we're like right right sorry sorry I'm trying
to explain the lore of Skyrim like really quick right hold on let's fix my frick right that should
be run uh sentence gameplay run run just what gameplay looks sensitivity vibrate
where do I hello oh it's controls not sounds my apologies right um run toggle pov no absolutely
not sprint sprint should be this one crouch should be uh what one should crouch be I can only know I
only know which one crouch should be okay crouch should be the other analog stick I need to go back
out in order to do it properly please let's go it's happening wait what's that what I four six was
six days ago wait what what did it four monetized talents did I miss it I mean four of us monetized
oh my god you need to oh all the girls I don't know if there's any girls lurking right now you need
to think of your monetization stream um she be already put what hers is I think I said what mine
was in chat if you don't know what to do don't worry I'll help you after my stream uh what was I
doing snake sneak is uh crouches other this button character menu I don't think so I don't think
character menu is freaking b what the frick what the frick that's quite I mean oh I can't remember
my sentence from childhood god damn it's been so long toggle pov left bumper no let uh character menu
is probably left bumper then first row da is uh right bumper yes okay this looks correct
why oh no jump right one last one I'm so sorry please please I'm so sorry uh jump is alpha
activate is why yeah this looks correct sorry I'm an Xbox kid I'm not going to beat that
a la gunkies wait is b crouch instead I think b is crouch you know that hold on hold on pause
pause the tunes I need time I should release is uh crouch crouch crouch crouch sneak and then
toggle tv yeah yeah that's fine please monetize the last two so everyone is happy together
go ahead take it all right one more to get right everything all right all right all right let's
get that off right let's check out the drip oh look at the storm cold drip I'm going to see if I can
do your one should be a motion the rest can have being practiced can you check your difficulty
I think it's so bug no no nothing wrong with the difficulty of the game where what do we need to
oh wait there's about to be an enemy that comes through I think or something we're about to jump
on hope bye tomorrow is six out of six I would love that for all the girls they're so excited
come on they can't see us they don't know he can't see me at all is he like directly at me by the way
oh my god I forgot how clunky the frickin if you're late oh my god this is so clunky
yes yes a key a key um take all I'm definitely gonna equip these because they're a lot better than
right I know I'm dressing up as the enemy okay but that's heavy armor uh we're gonna wait where the
frick is the key or he gets the key okay storm coke and drip in the same sentences oxymoronic
how do they're both bad but storm cooks are just worse the high king was leader of the good factions
the sky room and he surrendered to the empire because they were the less bad option I didn't
know that I thought it was like the thalmor embassy came in and they were like you can he
worship talus anymore and I was like eh you can't he come into my company and tell me what I can do
and can he do so eh I'll pick this guy storm cooks like you can't he just go and be doing that like
that's a region right where's the enemies oh oh yeah that's right look at that come oh my god it's
so bad on pc like when we analogue stick oh wow kill cam stealth goes from input I don't know
I'm normally like a two-handed player I always try to be an archer and I always end up two-handed
because there's a really good freaking um there's a really good um
enchantment which you can get from uh the yeah sorry torturer yeah yeah you're trying to tell me
that uh oh oh she getting it she annihilated him no I haven't seen him uh you can lock pick these for
like ah I guess we'll try it so there's eh you can literally smurf this if you leave and then
shuggle it hear that hear that if you do super gently see so we now know it's left side
oh I'm not getting pranked there you can literally smurf like all this stuff if you want it to be
made you can pick up this stuff but we are actually going to sell it because it's good
money I don't think I think there's a shield behind here if you wanted to do yeah if you want a shield
then uh there is one here but I don't really bother with shield that I do two-handed so we're
going to get a warhammer very shortly eh there should be coins down here and one of these if I'm
not mistaken I guess 300 no 300 coins seems a bit extreme maybe 30 coins in there and we are just
going to blast through it um try two-handing mage mage is my fave no two-handed warrior two-handed
lightweight warrior and you can muck around with a bow and an arrow like if you do the nightingale
quest you get light armor that's pretty sneaky but the thief-skilled armor especially for this
stamina and like item increase is so good um as for how we're going to tackle what we do first
um I'm going to purposefully do the companion's quest line and then load a previous save because
I don't like oh sorry sorry hold on I was out of stamina I was trying to reach up um that
I see it just posted a very watery tweet no way the the piss corp uh accusations
we ain't beating them today and we ain't beating them tomorrow and the nightingales yeah pure mage
is hard mode I there should be something up here if I remember correctly on the right side of these
rocks what was it oh it's just a weak coin purse I got 14 gold honestly per scaley boy he's he's
gone you he couldn't get out but the bars are broken now I love the jewel wheels nightingale
peeler no not peeler that's awful but that's hilarious at the same time um right there are
spiders so if any of you are arachnophobic wow um don't worry they are getting absolutely yeah I've
been poisoned I think they give stamina of frostbite but yeah please look away if you're arachnophobic
we are just gonna blast through this area uh did I come from here uh um I think there's something
to look up there maybe I don't know I can't there is a bear ahead I say look away but you're too busy
doing something on your alternative twitter so it's okay
she doesn't have to know and we are going to take this for some really quick money I believe
there is an achievement for holding 100 000 gold at one stage the best way to make gold I have found
is by enchanting and selling that jewelry um there is a bit of a mild strat that I devised
myself I don't know if it's the strat uh survival mode survival adds the need absolutely not what
is this survival adds the need to eat sleep and stay warm it also adds challenges such as no no
and no I'm a vanilla skyrim oh my god is that is that pc option
um there he goes I just realized am I not am I not getting achievements on xbox for this
I don't think I am I'm not aww I named the stream zero to one thousand oops well that's a very accurate
run are you playing anniversary um it's an additional challenge oh well we should have
gotten an achievement there but we're not playing xbox some dumb imagine having to eat
eat 10 cheese wheels um so there is a really easy mine you can clear I think it will give us two
handed um that's just dead ahead it's like right in your oh wait actually sorry the standing stones
first uh standing stones I believe there are 12 standing stones which give you a certain boost
such as a faster leveling exp uh under certain things so there's a mage stone there's a thief
stone and there is a warrior stone but there's different ones as well one uh I believe is
like a mule stone where you just straight up can carry more items uh on your persons uh yeah literally
activate thief activate mage activate warrior uh we are gonna do thief um are we gonna do thief
what's warrior I've forgotten right we'll do warrior normally I do thief but we will we're
gonna clear out this mine very quickly we're just gonna pick up uh ingredients as we go along
the way of the stones the way war yeah this should be an achievement to find them all yes um
um well so they're just not have achievements at all because I'm not I'm playing on xbox game
pass but it's not like instance to uh xbox uh don't be too afraid of the wolves on the
they are too hip they can give you rock join oh I've gone past the mine already they can give you
is it no is it rock join or is it lockjaw I think it's rock join oh my memory of me
I've gone so past this mineshaft yeah here we go right there should be a baddie out here hello
yeah yeah yeah you're playing a novice no I'm not these accusations are unfound
it is rock join I thought that but strony where is the blarney and yes I know the blarney stone
what are you trying to make a balamori joke there's a tripwire here in this mine but don't
worry about it as I said you can please carry them up whatever level you want I like blasting through
and just absolutely annihilate and take this like it's so good there are some later stages
were even being on easy mode isn't that bad although I have to admit I guess this is registering as
PC Skyrim and it's quite different oh this is so sad they made this person mine themselves to death
they've had me working down here for days now it's not the time that's getting to me though it's
these tunnels I've told this countless times now to add extra support to the weak sections of the
tunnel if only we had more of these wooden beams that were we reinforced with bronze
honestly if I hear the earth shift one more time above my head I'm so stressed I may stop
drinking for good I mean what's a Nord without his mead and he died because of a collapsing
so my granddad was a miner and he used to tell me really rough stories about
um the he is like being in the mineshaft and all of that uh and they had a mine collapse and
within two minutes they had already killed the guy out and he was gone like he just perished it was
a main a minor yes um they did I think bandits normally have like a lock pick and coin but
that's not really the best um you can't just like straight up grab this shit but there is a big
chest in here so we're just gonna clear out the wait unless we oh I was gonna say unless we sneak
but the guys right there um yeah but like my granddad used to talk so openly about the um we just
got it to stick oh call is oh no hold on everyone knows I'm bad at log picking now um okay we've got
our first what are you 20 damage right 20 damage um he like spoke so openly about it and I'm like
granddad granddad that's just straight up like stuff that's like man-made like horrors beyond
comprehension type stuff uh this chest
okay we're definitely on pc because amber does not look like that what the heck
what the heck I've never seen that in Skyrim before am I going crazy or I don't know
I'm losing it right don't get ready to swing
that's so good oh um if the book is valued at 50 coins or more you will level up reading that book
if you are ever in a section and you're like what the heck are all these books if that book is valued
at 50 uh septum or more then it is actually a skill book oh oh my god that's so satisfying
that's so freaking satisfying hold on a minute yeah that's a yeah bone archer
um I think there's a tiny little chest on the edge here I think there's a little bug with a
difficulty no not at all I'm playing on oh wait it's just in a vein if you didn't know um these
are called veins when you can see the ore sticking out from the wall it's quite interesting honestly
maybe I should talk about mining because my granddad spoke to me in big detail about it all um
and like how they used to come out and like their eyes really bloodshot red and everything
have I missed that chest back there I think I have but it's not a big deal
yeah I thought that and I just like I was like I've missed that chest haven't I but it's fine
if you run with your weapon out your stamina will decrease but that's okay you don't really need it
especially when you're just so good at the game like playing legendary mode like as I'm playing
right now if you didn't know I'm playing legendary mode like just because I'm such a pro everything
becomes really easy and you just have to like understand the strats as long as you like swing
first basically you win every fight and the reason why they hardly do any damage to me is because I
have such high defense of course and not any other reason if you're looking for work go see
um Rayloff said you could help me Rayloff of course you're he's a friend he promised you could
help we escaped from the amperials together she lied as easily as she breathes what are you talking
about this is legendary mode literally like I know it's hard to believe that a vtuber is just so
good at skyrim that they can play legendary mode as casually as I can but it's just it's just the way
it is okay so the area is now just discovering that dragons are coming back I don't know why
but I actually believe you you've got the look of someone who's just seen the dragon legendary easy
but never heard of it legendary is easy mode because I'm just so skilled at this game open
options and show that it's legendary fine I will I will show that it's legendary oh look what's over
there hold on what's over there look a little to the left look a little to the left see I told
see I told you it was legendary I don't know see I don't know why you doubted me for a millisecond
why this isn't legendary like I'm just back oh oh my god like did you guys see what I see just
posted on our alternative Twitter oh my god yeah go look yeah no it's crazy oh my god I don't know
she did that it's good to see you oh
yeah
good okay we are gonna go ahead and just deliver the news to the yorl of
dragons reach that's not the name of the town of white run we are gonna oh something's at me
oh it's a crab get off please uh there should be wolves up ahead but don't worry
did strony just look wow actually the legendary wait momay fey and uh what
stroneying the truth did you just hit no not at all I don't know what you're talking about
well can't fake proof like that you're clearly a true gamer thank you I appreciate it I don't
sometimes look it's a hard pill to swallow to admit that sometimes you know a girl may be better
than you at a game but that's okay that's okay you know I'll stroke your ego you stroke mine
you admit that I'm a legendary Skyrim player and admit that uh I'll I'll stroke your ego and some
other things too at the same time you know we are gonna try and hit some of these markers
the reason for this is because there's a thieves guild quest at this particular location so we will
unlock it um speech 100 honestly yeah I'm sorry to doubt you look it's okay stuff happens like
things in life you know sometimes it's just once you once you swallow the the truth that um
you know someone may be better at your favorite video game then it becomes easy you know life
looks so good uh driving my driving my fork listening and watching stroney okay I need to
describe in detail what we're doing what is that those are like clouds that are being developed by
horses footprints that looks like a texture gone wrong we're currently traveling to white run we're
just uh unlocking white run stables speech 100 as expected of a crater of peeler
yeah those look like uh the dust generated things and that's currently appearing in the sky
spirit of the sky is where I'm gonna go when I die when I die put me a rest
put me up in the spirit of the sky I will believe you no matter what see that that's what I like to
see you know trust trust is an important foundation to build off of that's why I'm a legend
halt official business only now this is where our tongue can come into aid
persuasion I've news from helgen about the dragon attack
you've got a thousand errors in this game so you must be good right
spin years there's nazim thanks for the tip again nazim you want to see it see the lane
see the lane you get to the cloud district very often oh what am I saying of course you don't
it's at the line oh hello come to chat with an old woman do your good deal for the day no
do your good deed for the day
they're saying it's because of this great man he's at the line what a guy
hail tallos let's hear it let's hear it come on let's hear it I want to hear what you have to say
come on
okay wrap it up wrap it up jeez right we will take talus's blessing though all diseases cured
other blessings removed and the blessing of talus added wait it's joining big children what big
question what children do you adopt uh unveil our girls are you making game I even know how to
marry I like uh me all is it uh what's her name lioness and scarum what's her in scarum and uh
goodness me the thieves guild area rifting my god my knowledge is out the window it's been
here since I've built up this game me all the lioness exactly uh so this don't even don't even
engage in conversation don't waste my time I'm delivering news about a freaking dragon everyone
shut up in this room right now I'm talking about a dragon a dragon destroyed helgen okay
okay and girders afraid riverwood is next kill the yarl kill jester me all that essentially
uh yeah me all the lioness I used to marry her all the time because I find her really cool
uh but you can't unlock her quest until like level seven nine eight
okay hydration check yes I had a great view while the imperials were trying to cut my head off
really are you squinting me right now mr l general to leases approximately two percent more
caked up on legendary making the civil war significantly more difficult thank you mr l
for the tip yes no don't worry I'm fully aware of how caked up the enemies are on legendary mode
don't worry I'll handle it I will explain to you all the strats to get you through the section
of the game please don't worry I will teach you the tips and tricks the dragon destroyed helgen
and last I saw it was heading this way by you smear I will not let you go let her go
continue to trust in the strength of our walls against the dragon the greater as this yarl bar
ball gruff the lesser the yarl is lurking in the mountains as a provocation he'll assume we're
preparing to join all we're a part of the council we should maybe we can exchange to oh yeah yarl ball
in you ever played kill zone I'm not y'all both grew up the mediocre yes my yarl
bro the glitter meal nurse elf friend follows her because you into art that's funny
I never even thought about that I didn't think she liked them that way
white brother service I have okay give me take this as a small studied imperial armor
started our first quest come let's go find foreign god my court wizard he's been looking
into a matter related to the dragons and rumors of dragons as Lydia gonna be your companion
you guys can pick the companion studied armor I already had studied on what's my carry weight
I'm not really that heavy at the moment and we've just unlocked two there um
black foals barrel dog companion Cicero Cicero is not a companion come to dragon Cicero a companion
ongoing hostilities you have to great warriors I don't want to spoil it for anyone who might
know I've done the assassins uh the dark brotherhood line I can hear a child in the game please stop
please cease your your dialogue the yarl said you had a project you needed help with
project you think you could help me wait you need to spare his life he always attacks me
the yarl can be found wait oh my god oh for goodness sake I had to wait for this
born dialogue you need to end all the assassins quest and spare him I could just warn he attacks
me every time I spare him are you squinting me right now I'm such a fake gamer oh yes my favorite
skyrim gaggle ball mouse thank you for the tip floria he's not look he's not the worst yarl
but he's a bit funny in the head okay he could have he could have acted a bit more
all right where am I going to fetch no need for tedious housing wise leave the details to your
learned of a certain stone tablets go to bleak falls bearer we are going to bleak falls bar right
so this is how you make a sugar ton of money the arcane and channel we're just and you literally
get to level up just by destroying by destroying stuff it's pretty cool anyway we'll let them keep
yapping away because we're about to unlock our dragon born powers is that john skyrim from the hit
legendary show skyrim yeah but at the end of the fight you can decide to kill him or go away
I could have sworn he attacks me on xbox I'm wondering if it's possible
um there might be a few courted differences battleborn give me your money I don't have any money
why didn't they hire me to be the NPCs like seriously could you imagine me
like hanging a boot I'd actually I'd actually be so wait why does that say wait wait
has a fricked up map there we go where am I going leak falls bar oh and you go uh we're just
going to go on riverwood real quick but not a big yapper as I'm actually I'm having a mental
debate right now um so because we're not currently getting achievements like on steam or here
I'm wondering if I should do a short two hour stream then come back and do the monetization
stream possibly I'm having to master jabay about that um oh my god there's a firefly
it's hard to stay awake when I'd rather be asleep
everything is never as easy as I fall asleep there are wolves currently
biting my ankles but it's fine oh oh no it's not I'm gonna get lock joints perish
be gone you can meet sister outside white run before doing the burp
dark brother yes you can meet him in his travels it's possible but you just have to beat him up
first in the it's from UG can't wait for carry okay sneak peek at the next concert
oh the next be allure cover the fact you know the lyrics to that song off my heart is alarming
it was like a really big song I was like can I believe your eyes like 10 million fireflies
lit up the world of life at least these are bandits I can't remember what the loot is up here
oh we got to hit uh I think there's a bad guy up here so we're actually gonna sneak for one
oh something can see us oh we're hitting again I think there is a bad guy in the chair up here
we just need a little oh yeah oh yeah I heard that knife don't think I didn't hear it we're
no okay well he can see me so does the cat
the kill counts in this game are so ridiculous literally bludgeoned on to death
I'll still leave the the light armor on I know why are you doing two-handed with light armor
look I just like light armor okay heavy armor you'll never guess what heavy armor takes up a lot of
room and it's heavy very popularly 10 years ago remembers on every rip that rip that guy
oh rip that guy I thought you meant the singer uh leather hat worn from iron hat I don't know
that's canonically how strong he uh expires people headbutt let's do the hell with it
we are in legendary you we can't let them hit us yeah we're one shot right now so we need to
make sure we don't get hurt oh I remember going up these stairs for the first time
and I was absolutely terrified of everything in this game
oh and I was I was probably oh it's probably just the baby playing on medium difficulty the default
uh oh don't worry we didn't actually get hit it oh we didn't get hit that was called a whiff that's
that's what's known as a whiff in video games don't worry don't worry we're still fine
no the guy oh someone's shooting at me I heard that bone I don't
can I compare something if I ever play skyrim nowadays I cheat with 300 speed
and speed malt command what's that I don't even know what that is uh there should be a little
dialogue do I have a bow and arrow I don't actually think I have a arrow I had the chance to pick up
a bow and I didn't that's what I get for no don't worry oh we're doing the golden claw oh my god
right I'm actually gonna pick up our bow for moments like that where we could
legit just grab that stuff there should be a little chest here oh okay
yeah my wee glazegut kiss ah well
oh such a good lock pick oh 47 gold look we're not exactly breaking the bank here right I think
we'll do tomorrow uh I'm just thinking why am I why I'm I'm so dumb and set this up but not to be
on xbox game pass um because I'm not getting any achievements I think we'll do I'll play for two
hours and we'll redirect into sheepsters when she comes up and then I will replay everything that I
achieved basically oh this is supposed to be a tutorial if you don't I've just upset him he pulls
it to show you that it's wrong and I think he perishes here but he's yeah yeah it's like no
hell so it's uh snake snake dolphin you could just run the do the campaign and do monetization yeah
or yeah actually maybe um maybe we just do the main campaigns I wouldn't actually I would be quite
happy and satisfied with Skyrim again if the book is worth more than 50 gold if we do the main quest
lines instead then I would actually be happy with what we've achieved with Skyrim and we can
oh my god I forgot there's rats here hold on oh I'm getting bit to death oh my gosh oh my god the
swing is so bad this swing is terrible I know I should level up I'm saving it if you didn't know
leveling up actually fully heals you so if you ever get in a in a bit of a pickle why didn't you
warn him yes actually I wouldn't mind that today we'll do an endurance stream if that's okay
it's freaking terrifying oh he's actually quite a bc boy like honestly
oh my god he's just stabbed me wait something else is red I don't know hi
oh my ankle do you know see that big massive spider and you pick on me you pick on me
right hello did it you killed it now cut me down before anything else shows up okay again the rest
the rest are winning please please you have this whole chamber and you pick on me
right like is this cold he's actually one of the stronger enemies in the dungeon
be as a script to death and instadize where's the golden claw
same like a bandit attacking after takedown our dragon literally hand over the claw first
okay no you're kind of real for that I'm sorry I wasn't thinking
hello I'm sure you wouldn't betray me would you
why should I share the treasure with anyone why are you are you just leading me there
you feel I'm not sharing it with anyone is he about to get rolled by a drogger
I see
he is wait sorry there's one behind me
he actually does I didn't know he was scripted to do that I always kill him instantly
saw mudcrabs the other day horrible creatures wait yeah so it's on his person should we read his
journal left trigger read my fingers are trembling the golden claws finally in my hands and with it
the power of the ancient nordic heroes that fool lucian valerius has no idea that his favorite
store decoration was actually the key to bleak falls thorough now I just need to get to the
hall of stories and unlock the door the legends say there is a test that the nord's put in place
to keep the unworthy way but that when you have the golden claw the solution is in the palm of your
hand oh shit okay I saw that coming I'm so sorry I saw that coming I stood right on that trap
oh shit why when I use a stamina move stop holding the freaking stamina bar holy crap when I do a
stamina move it like makes me go to the side literally the only thing that's going to hurt me
in this game is um is uh traps nothing else
spider girl for jen too
so there's one I don't want to talk about it too much just for my baby girls like
bro we are only a weekend wait is there a drogger here I'm gonna crazy no and obviously I don't
want to disrespect the baby girls um I was talking to them about like how development works behind
the scenes um and unfortunately I used my words pretty poorly and it made some of them a bit
uncomfortable so I don't really like talking about it too much um but it's due to my poor
communication it's not due to the the girls in any way um but I what I can see is that
development takes a year at least for a generation like an entire generation if you will um and like
I don't want to say too much to make the girls feel like oh I'm just like casting them aside
because like oh shiny gen two like you know that's absolutely not the case like I have said this from
the start um if there is going to be a gen two it will be at least a year away like I am I am not
rushing gens out just for the sake of doing it that's that's so unbelievably disrespectful
to the girls who have placed faith in me um and like I still have a load of plans like now that
the girls are in the stage of being monetized um there's a lot of plans we can now execute um like
shorts as well there's a lot of shorts that need to be made um we have a fantastic uh
shorts editor who did a hail mary to the website and applied themselves um and he's he's been a
fantastic shorts editor he's pretty much done the majority of the work we have a a second one
who's quite busy at the moment but we are gonna you know test if it's all good and if it's all good
then you know we've got a lot of shorts play coming up um confirmed not a black company I I hope
not I I said to the girls wholeheartedly and hopefully they will voucher they remember I said
something along the lines I oh I wasn't paying attention sorry um I said if I ever do anything to
you that is like absolutely hurting you that hurts you in any way that is a completely negative
experience with me in any way take me out back and shoot me um like it was it's why I was very
serious in the interview uh they they are welcome to talk about the interview if they like um am I
gonna am I going back the way I came no I'm not um I said to them do not ever refer to me as your
boss do not ever think of me as like a superior or something like that um that's definitely not
ever how I want you to think like I am literally like in this with you we're we're memeing about
we're figuring out what we want to do like um definitely take me out back and shoot me I'm
so serious do not ever ever let me like oh that's it does more damage um like do not ever take me
like you know what's that saying you live long enough to become the villain don't ever let me live
become don't ever let me live long enough to become the villain take me out back and shoot me
like oh it's why from the get go like if the girls sign on their contract for another year
we the company um we offer an alternative outfit on the house for them as well as their pay increase
goes sorry I'm fucking trying to like remember the the attack pattern and where the droggers
spawn in this uh we'll talk about this but um like uh we definitely wanted to raise their
income and the split goes uh 85 15 again kind of showing that we're not really here for grade
we're kind of here for alternative reasons um so is there an actual say oh I don't own the company
like I genuinely wholeheartedly my my name I'm basically my role is what is a creative director
I already if you look on the thingy it'll tell you what the code is but you just need to move
these twice and then you've got the correct code uh unless it's different on pc uh but basically I'm
I was the creative director because I did used to have the scripts like I used to be the script
maker I no longer have that there's no a manager all I do right now is stream as strone as me um
and I send away shorts like I literally went into the girls DMs uh last night like after stream
and I was like hey um can I get an audio of you saying this and they're like yeah I'll do it in
the morning like that's that's all I do uh you're a cco I don't know what a cco is you're already
like the opposite of a black company I mean you're ready to be dragonborn word of power
learned force unrelenting force force um there's always an overlord or um some sort of um
protector of the words of power which you know makes sense all things considered
uh oh we're gonna break that down break it down now
uh chief creative officer um no I've uh we're just gonna break everything down and
I think there's a hidden chest by this waterfall although I could be completely wrong oh well no
damn my memory coming through it's been how many years since I played this game and I'm like
yeah there's a we hidden chest here then there's a there and then you can pick this up and then
do that oh my god so mlg pro honestly um wow you executed that based on honestly foos sounds like
the german word foo which means foot oh did you like my foos last night huh did did you like them
streams tell me I don't have I feel so feminine right now I'm like the most feminine I might get
more pedicures gonna say that that was so fun I enjoyed it the women was so like both the women
were so lovely I felt so flustered in that stream though I hope it didn't come across too badly but
I was like so out of my element like when I saw the time was an hour until uh sheepsters was up I
was like oh my god what have I done like how did I speedrun it it's like so quickly
have you got back the tool um it's still unfortunately very uh cut up so I've still
got a wee band-aid on it I washed it uh in the bath uh she got me good all I'm gonna say is she
got me good like it was deep you know like the side the smaller side part of your tool cut straight
into that she was really sorry though but it's fine like stuff happens honestly and I believe she
was new I believe she was new to the establishment so it's better to it's better for her to make a
mistake on me because like hopefully I'm nice and understand and they're like I didn't say anything
mean I was like oh you're fine like don't worry about it um and like the other women was like
translating for her because she didn't speak English and I was like it's fine so I'm kind of
glad she made that mistake on me rather than someone else who would have been like a Karen
basically like I'm not gonna say anything about Australia but um I have I have heard some unique
conversations occur I'm not even paying attention to the plot because I'm too busy rambling about
my my life um look forward to the seat stream anyway who slashed your toe the lady that was
doing my pedicure oh god I'm not like paying attention to the plot all right we've just
handed over the dragon stone he's gonna translate it or something and then they're gonna know that
the things are back this is a map of Skyrim it's very big we're in white run right now
um we're actually gonna take a horse and carriage and go to rifting because I want to
do the thieves guild quest yippee it's my favorite quest um so that's the Skyrim town that's the
eh sorry that's an uh stormcork town stormcork is winterhold stormcork solitude is the legion
at legion it's not legion hey ho strony here with my weekday donation telling you I'm off to work
I'll catch you at the other end once I'm off okay enjoy your legendary mode conquest thank you so
much yes monetization excited to see some of it yeah thank you so much for the tip please
enjoy work tiny spiny or tiny spinning one or the other okay we're listening to plot okay um but
yes legendary mode conquest thank you thank you uh yeah I think maybe we'll do just one big endurance
Skyrim stream and then tomorrow we'll do monetization uh because since we're not really getting
achievements is not really too much need your help again what do you need my help with oh yes
sorry I completely forgot we're about to go get our dragon power in order to be the dragon born
and utilize our powers we have to perish dragons yes so we're about to get our first uh shout
power winterhold is the stormcork capital yeah the best quest link yeah we're gonna do
the thieves guild we're also gonna bring the thieves guild back to its glory but i'm gonna
need your guys's help for the tally um you can just run ahead of arolyth um it's not necessary
to hang about strony has the wrong kind of tism to pay attention to multiple things that was yeah
I can't do that I can like hyper I say they call it hyper focused I don't think it's even hyper
focused it I'm not focused at all I'm just having a really good time um but yeah I'm very lucky that
I don't experience like burnout or anything I'm like yeah I can't really oh sorry oh I'm so sorry
to hear that you're having such a tough time oh yeah um right hold on I'm gonna unlock this
little windmill as a landmarker when you pepega farm that's terrible when you discover a landmark
you can fast travel to it which gets you around a lot faster um
did you know that with frostbills you can make dragons land I did not know that I always use that
shout um to get them to land oh it's so pretty look at the butterfly oh my god catch the butterfly
rip its wings off for alchemy yes oh purple butterfly he didn't serve it okay now we need
to wait for the game to hurry up with the npc so we're just gonna wait an hour oh there we go boom
just like that no burnout lucky you I just don't experience it I like I've never experienced
issues with that I don't feel it like I can feel tired like I can be like oh I need to go get some
like tea and some food and then we'll play like for a couple of more hours I can do that no problem
like at all I think the only time I feel I just feel frustrated that I don't have more time like
when I was doing all the ASMR collabs like writing all the scripts back to back and actually I knew
girl uh I'm used to tell a new girl and I was like hey you want to do some more and she was like
fuck you want to do some more and she's like I know a lot about you and I was like oh that's
embarrassing um but if you know a lot about me then you know how easy this collab is gonna be
because I'll do all the work um but like I don't mind doing all the work if anyone's lurking
I don't mind doing the work I actually prefer it um because it makes things a lot easier
and make every arrow count I used to not experience burnout playing games but now I do which is a
shame no so if you can't play video games that's like life burnout like if you would rather watch
someone else play video games then like play it yourself livestreaming doesn't count because you're
you're being tortured to watch me play Skyrim via uh my controller where the heck is this dragon
is he on the floor oh it is okay oh let's spank his butt uh whoa it's actually kind of hurt me a
little bit no you're stinking you're so stinking um see I've been on top here stamina bar is
greed out only HP oh it's landed again oh you're hurting me stop it you're hurting me
oh look at that two-handed 32 I should probably level that up we are gonna pick up the dragon
bones these are like why on earth oh he must eat a weight ring guard um dovahki no
uh so now this is where the NPCs get really weird around you I don't know what he's fighting
right now he's locked on something a mud crab maybe nearby there's mud crabs over that way
today I learned from a Scottish cuttlefish I may have burned out yes so if you'd rather um if you
would rather um
he's supposed to come up to me is it you
normally an NPC walks up to you and goes oh my god you are the dragon born in a really
poor like Swedish accent
what type of two-handed we specialize in in hammer, axe, sword those there's
aren't those one-handed yeah I'm just gonna pick up with the apocrity apocrity something like that
did he die I guess they may have perished yeah I've been uninspired by the games to play recent
so I'd prefer watching others like yes I think that is a symptom of burnout because of
the
I think the gray beards have summoned us
oh it's Khajiit who's a good boy hey push push push
do you seek to make a purchase uh uh what have you got for sale I'm gonna just sell some of my stuff
that I don't want uh I'm gonna break that break it down now
I'm gonna break all this stuff down it's just so we're not too heavy and I can break those down
take red did that red did that we're gonna break it down I've got a brook bass and a Nord meat
resurrect and restore my energy would I do amber I'll just sell it I don't I don't really know
oh I definitely want to sell this I like how my speech gets better just selling stuff in general
like you always want to hold on to soul gems they're very important may the road lead to oh
that's why I always say safe travels land strider because of this game I think is really cute just
safe travels land strider khajiit roleplay stream uh I actually don't know how to pur you know how
some v-tubers compare like I can't do I can only roll my r by the pope even the gray beards
screaming your name strongy you absolute sexy player thank you for the tip sorry or sorry
y'all I think they're y'all ebw a bit a bit a bit a bit a bit a bit a bit a bit a bit a bit a bit a bit
khajiit has squares if you have coins I told you y'all not alone we're not causing trouble
so they're looking for uh someone but we're not doing that quest right now because we're
trying to zoom past this so we can go and do the main quest of the dragonborn I'm wearing a hat with
badass horns I'm the dover king known globally you're nobody at home he was so English in those
songs for no reason I'm just kidding it is his accent he's allowed to have an accent
if it's gosh I'm dover king known globally you're nobody at all like it yeah I think the English
rapping accent is a bit better than the scots was the dragon there uh the watch tower was
destroyed but we killed the dragon let's just skip a few dialogue and see it turns out I might be
dragonborn dragonborn what do you know about the dragonborn when the dragon died I absorbed some
kind of power so it's true the gray beards really were summoning you the vampire DLC I don't even
think I saw that one the gray beards okay okay okay we get blah blah blah blah wait
why does it say I need to keep oh I need to keep talking to him you've done a great service
yes yes yes thank you thank you thank you yes please gift me uh axe of white run
oh I'm staying of the sick oh I am so sorry for creating a mess that was a misfire it was a
mis-input mis-input please don't fight me I didn't mean to do that I was uh the wrong
wrong button there uh axe of white run target dies within three second fills a soul gem
that's perfect because it's exactly the enchantment we want we're gonna break break it down now
just breaking down everything um and we're gonna see if we can enchant our Nordic battle axe
although I even have soul gem I have the world's weakest soul gem
I'm gonna have to refill it so much if I end up using it
uh this is the best I can do
uh we're just gonna oh we're completely out of soul gems anyway
I'm sorry it was a mis-input it was a mis-input I'm so sorry look I'm the I'm the thing anyway
I'm the I'm a thing oh Lydia do you want to come with us so you can be filled with dragon bones
follow me I need you oh my god wait if I got Lydia's face am I going crazy or do I have Lydia's face
wait a minute did I accidentally recreate Lydia
wait take take that helmet off right now I think I may have accidentally recreated Lydia
no I'm I'm such a Lydia fanboy I recreated her as myself oh my god we even have the same
nose and lips and everything that is hilarious I'm so sorry Lydia I'm just such a I must have like
subconsciously made her this that shirt is making people nervous on it I'm still winning
Lydia cuttles for real for real right we now need to go all the way up this mount well we need to
go to Rorik's stead I versus it oh my god I'm such a fake gamer honestly I don't even know why you
guys listen to me half the time uh 20's copied my whole flow word for word bar for bar it's a
highland coup excuse me little gate let me just close that let me just close that oh it's the wee
highland coup look at this no uh whoa whoa whoa look at yidwi horns fun uh I mentioned this other
day actually uh I had a relative that owned one and uh the they they're actually super gentle
uh but it made my relative blind in one eye lamal uh because the horn poked his eyeball um that was
funny uh but he wasn't even mad at her it was a female highland coup I can't even remember what
he named there but honestly it sounds like the most Scottish you know I don't care about your
question the fuck up um literally I honestly must sound so Scottish a stream like oh my grandad
used to work in the mines uh had a family that family member that literally owned a highland coup
like oh my god that's where like no wonder I was raised in a bar and literally don't have manners
like I just I never had it from the start a wee coup a wee highland coup my favorite part of a
strong stream is our unofficial catchphrase did you know oh did you know did you know uh right I
think we're gonna manually walk there there are gonna be wolves ahead but because we're playing
legendary differently and I'm such an MLG pro at this game um it's honestly not problem and
we might even see Cicero on the way it's unlikely we'll meet Cicero on the way there just because
he spawns I find the Cicero spawns more northern west of the map and we are her and like going
southern east which is the opposite um Lydia no hello this was as stupid as a feud with clan
need something no oh oh she's got a bit of them oh what was that shadow freaking the honeybearing
meadery ah yes a bit of a bit of meadery oh wait will we open a veal or a meadery why not
that seems to be the way of like um content creators when they get in their end game they
like come out with a product I'm like I think my end game would be video games like uh like paying
to get them made like what what my my rubbish ideas are um I think that's probably my end game whoa
okay that was that was a lot going on the screen for one for one soul that was quite a lot there is
a waste on up ahead I don't think it's a good one Haggis and nips and ties
do you also live in a lone terror up on some hill are you
wait oh no is this an enemy dog no it's a nice dog hello I've been hunting and fishing in these parts
for years I've been hunting and fishing in these parts for years are you telling me my lore story
is shrek right now you can buy dragon scale you've not got the money for it all right
veal or drinks it may or may not contain something unique to the girls I see that
skiver on the road don't think I can't see you oh so captured that that is the noise I like to
hear honestly I believe there's a few skeletons up on this hill but again nothing we can't handle
nothing you can't handle at all um as I said we're gonna do the main quest we're gonna do
the thieves um and then hello are you you are definitely an enemy oh I do beg your pardon but
it's all the way absolutely nothing around these parts and another soul capture do you have soul
gem spark white cat um we'll destroy those oh oh oh how dare you do you oh wait I think that
ancient that ancient bow is stronger than what we have for our bow um right we're skeleton scare
ooh scary are you squid me right by the pope I don't like my family history every time I read my
family history I always have to ask myself are we the bad guys thank you for the tip
I think my family history is like really boring it's just like yeah Scottish and Irish
I know that you can do like 23 and me tests to like really see where you come from but I actually
don't uh I don't believe it's safe at all to like willingly hand over your DNA like that look
I know I'm starting to send like needy streamer overload where we're doing like that god speed
run where she you know she got into like all the conspiracy theories and stuff but it's not really
a conspiracy theory right I like maybe I should do a stream like that unironically I'll like yeah
um wait what are you attacking you're not attacking me no you're not okay that's strange
uh the scaly sounded like an oblivion scaly at least you got a cool accent out of the deal yeah
and we are just running our way over to mvark said I believe is the town name of where
you kind of forgot the pronunciation um nah I don't think it's safe either type your DNA
on fail the company yeah like um I took like ethics class um and we were discussing like
how good like emerging technology is like if you haven't heard about crisper is DNA fixing
technology essentially DNA fixing um it's going through a lot of lab studies and trials and all
that but it's found very effective against like um you know things that were previously incurable
essentially or diseases that are uh untreatable that kind of thing um and the technology that
can be raised from it um to help people is outstanding however do we do we trust such
do we trust your DNA sequence to be handled with care or would in theory insurance help
I'm sorry I'm literally hell yeah I'm up for scotland conspiracy theory stream thank you so much
totally not Virginia um like I could definitely get into it but we were like talking about like
uh didn't see one of the industry companies get caught selling all the data they said they
wouldn't is that yes uh not to mention um there's like a whole rabbit hole about what data leaks are
um because um I don't know I don't know if you guys care but um there's actually a whole other
conspiracy um that data leaks aren't actually like that it's kind of more like government demands
to have access but they already kind of have access so a lot of things especially with the
technology in the state age but uh maybe I shouldn't go too far down the rabbit hole don't want to
deter anyone where the heck am I supposed to go I think there's a path ahead I'll just follow this
path um I thought we were going down the designer baby route oh well that already happened one of
the biggest examples of the designer baby route was victoria beckham's children you're telling me
that brown eyed lady has a 25 percent of uh blue eyed offspring and she just happened to pop out
to blue eyed children uh no she did what is called ivf and then the dna tested and checked if the
children and in the egg in the egg yes in the egg uh were able to uh had the recessive blue eyes
it has already been done in this day and age and that was back in 2005 or something crazy it's one
of the biggest public uh things that are right in the faces of people that you wouldn't know about
it's already occurring today this also occurs with the fox p12 gene I believe I'm so sorry if no one
cares about this but I'll try and get through it really quickly there's also a gene that's been identified
called the fox p12 I believe um and if you have it it means you're actually a lot smarter and able
to pick up things a lot easier than someone who is without this gene and it's been called into question
that IVF babies may also be getting tested for this so you have a child or offspring that may be a
bit smarter than the average girl but that's just on me okay uh I'll just leave it I'll leave it there
but there there's a lot there's a lot okay um it's really interesting to continue the
happen yes so a lot of people think it hasn't already occurred or the first human hasn't been
cloned and dolly the first sheep was cloned in 1964 I believe uh the no no no no no that's when
we first were publicly allowed to be learned and to be taught about the cloning um it's already
happened long ago you just don't get to know about it because ethnically it's messed ethnically
ethically it's messed up and the public shouldn't really be allowed to access this knowledge because
well it brings up a lot of questions such as if you clone a person do they have one soul do they
share soul and then it brings religion into question if you didn't know religion also helps bring in
a lot of order into people's and communities lives and the rabbit hole goes incredibly deep but we
can't touch on that subject too much because I'm just a vtuber playing skyrim right now and we're
just trying to get to everything so we can talk to the greybeards to learn about our true powers
the dragonborn as we play this game so yes please don't mind me uh oh there's a saber cat after me
my goodness um but yes uh please uh please let us enjoy skyrim for what it is but anyway that's
why I don't really start talking about these subjects uh because uh yeah it's uh it's a bit
scary it's a bit scary when you look into it yeah right uh yeah gamers for genetically engineered
cat girls represent absolutely I'm 100% there with you the fact that nickel girls aren't real
I used to right this sounds really bad I used to actually fantasize about owning a nickel girl
I don't know why I just I used to fantasize about like treating her really well and like
she would have had a previous owner before me or something but I'll be like I'll treat you right
baby I don't know why I give me like some sort of like superior like saving complex or something
I don't know why but like I just oh I used to fantasize about all of that like especially
after watching monster monster um I used to like really uh there should be a quest
where you deliver something for someone is it you here for work get an axe and bring me all the
wood you can chop oh okay right sorry jeez um if this dream doesn't demonstrate that the
Tism is strong and veiler literally tiffin box there's someone that gives you a quest
oh the graybeards 10 not well it's trouble is my legs aren't okay we're gonna yet if you talk to
this guy you can do a quest for him um there's also a hidden thing if you read all of these on the
way up something happens but I've completely forgotten what happens because I've never done it
before because I saw it in a video and I've forgotten what happened in the video uh right let's see
emblem one before the birth of men the dragons ruled all of montus their words their word was the
voice and they spoke only for true needs for the voice could blot out the sky and flood the land
well four years means more years to peace honestly what neko para does to mf for me honestly
damn strony the last 10 minutes rumbles deaf and i'm so sorry thank you hypno mama thank you for
apologize just saying cloning has never been perfect and there has been a growth in mental
health issues as time has gone on we are all clones of our grandfathers grandmothers but imperfect
oh thank you tharia for the tip i could talk about um so you know how like the older generations
thing is like oh the lead paint stair because they'd been exposed to lead so much um my freaking biggest
thing is that they've known about micro plastics forever and uh i actually got proven right it has
been supra wait did i miss an emblem no i didn't hello how are you keep an eye out for wolves you
need something i did he's so cold yeah maybe because your arms are out and you have your stomach
is out and i can see your nip noop like of course you're cold right let's read emblem two oh emblem
men were born and spread over the face did i thank those tips thank you frosty you know thank you
tharia uh yeah micro plastics are today's lead plane apparently they're in the skin of men uh
or i read something about it being in the skin of men i don't know if it's true or not or if i got
trolled i believe anything i read men are born and spread over the face of mondes the dragons
president over the crawling masses men were weak then and had no voice
there is something about men's skin having micro plastics in it or something to do with their
dingle whoppers uh you got you got plastic in your dingle whopper right now please be honest
is it have you have you heard about this is this true can you confirm you sent me a picture
usually like marshmallow thank you average strawny stream yep yep yep oh look shiny thing yep yep
honestly some someone sent me a marshmallow and they were like i know your streams you get really
excited but if i put you on a low enough volume your rambling puts me to sleep because it just
goes everywhere my brain can't keep up i was like oh i'm so glad you like it and there's like as long
as i like the note of like as long as i put you down low enough because i get really excited at
random stages um actually i'm just gonna leave my weapon out you know but look at badass we look
oh actually we're gonna get nicer armor soon because this armor is is leilig young uh like
your mother your mother leilig yeah i'll should leave okay please be emblem three so i haven't
missed anything uh i don't know how to give nothing emblem three the fledging spirit of men
were strong in old times unafraid to war with unafraid to war with dragons and their voice
but the dragons only shouted them down and broke their hearts random Netherlands uh yeah thank you
well thank you well for uh listening to my random Dutch if i recall correctly all the
men they tested had microplastic in their yeah so my my biggest thing i'm on right now is that they
knew about microplastics years ago uh and all in the name of capitalistic profits uh they let us all
get poisoned but that's just me anyway if anyone's wondering why i really like need to shoot my
overload and that one particular uh achievement uh that one particular route you could take hmm i
wonder why uh but yeah uh i uh came across a documentary where the woman actually submitted
because she did find it and she got laughed at the company and yeah that was like 20 years ago
but it's been known for it's been known from the start so it's very very
she cares about our boss yes please if you are a man listen to me right now i cut oh wait hold on
i command you to eat tomatoes i'm not being funny tomatoes are the best thing you can do
for your boss thank you for listening to my rant uh i'm so serious oh someone's mad what are you
doing walking the steps meditating on the emblems i make this trip every few have i turned off the
thing wait why apparently tomatoes are the best thing to help your ball health i don't know why
just tomatoes are really good for you you can have it on a pizza i do not care you can have tomato
sauce on whatever food group you're eating uh you can have um ravioli tomato sauce like tomato
made up sauce that kind of thing but tomatoes are yucky oh i'm trying to give options um
you can have a chicken parma that has tomato sauce on it you can have um sun roasted tomatoes
maybe if you like to do thing in the oven uh so tomatoes to help the health pineapples to
help the taste thank you i'll be here all week ladies and gentlemen okay then to the one lady
watching right now um sorry kane called on parthax who pitted pitied man together they taught men to
use the voice then dragon war rage dragon against tongue very good thanks bldak i love all veggies
but man i hate sprouts very bitter i got to eat bok choy for the first time it's so tasteless i don't
understand how it can be someone's favorite veggie there's no flavor it's bitter it's a bitter uh
there is a yeti up ahead so just be advised if you're you jump scare easily you'll actually see
him look there he is should we snipe him oh well he's found me now hasn't he i messed that one up
didn't i all right jump down jump down jump into my weapon drain okay i was a bit early on the swing
i was a bit early it's okay a bit where are you oh oh yeah oh yeah piss oh yeah piss oh yeah piss
right we're just gonna run away oh yeah uh we are playing legendary mode which is the reason
why we need to get moved on but we need to read the emblem first uh man prevailed shouting alduin
out of the world providing for all that their voice too was strong although their sacrifice
were many fold oh yes oh i do love the lord oh he's swinging for me he's swinging oh he's so strong
and of course he has long arms just to really emphasize how much i despise the design of long
armed enemies they knew can i push him back go away oh it's out of range right where's the emblem
emblem emblem emblem this looks like an emblem emblem emblem emblem what's this emblem six the roaring
tongues the sky children conquer founding the first empire with sword and voice whilst the
dragons withdrew from this world am i still getting can i hide from him can he still see me no is he
coded to come all the way this way i forget that skyrim's like pretty sandboxed so i think he can
come all this way can he come is he still coming i'm like i'm like hiding behind this pillar is he
there oh he's still coming it's okay it's okay level up it gives full health oh i forgot about that
you guys should be playing i should be watching you guys play should i do a stream like that where
i commentate over your guys's gameplay on stuff like you just submit like a five minute clip
and i'll be like oh yeah get it i just like try and commentate and i'll be like oh you you've
messed oh you fucked up you're dead you're dead you need to restart you can go again
can he what he definitely still coming that would actually be really fun so it's like a fun idea
yeah here is lush rain hello hello talos medicana emblem nine have i missed one
for years all silent the gray bird spoke one name i said that's so weird
tiber septum strip stripling them was summoned to horathgard they blessed and named him
dovican i think i forgot the freaking thing i'm not gonna lie very proud to be the one lady in
strony hey let's go i have to go to work now hopefully you'll still be streaming yes endurance
today we're just mucking about on skyrim and playing the main quest thank you miss morrigan
shout out to the one the one lurker the one fem female actually i should say i was gonna show
my youtube stats so you guys can see everything because i think it's really interesting like looking
at stats and stuff i don't know i just oh wait i'm to put i'm to put something in here what am i to
put in here i forgot is it fish i think i'm gonna put fish in here uh did i not take that miscellaneous
quest yeah what are the supplies is it like a miscellaneous
oh hey we're so good the soul female and she has now gone back to work
miss female viewers 0 to 10 or 10 30 percent oh less than 10 percent i will never like kind of
some streamers get a bit hung up on like oh look at my female viewer ratio type thing and
i'm like if you're a chick that can hang out then you're a chick that can hang out you know
but i do understand and i will never not ever unacknowledge this like i create my content for
guys uh at the helm um you know i say he when i'm making a little script and all that thing and
i don't see any issue with it some i've definitely seen some streamers like very boastful like
oh check me out i've got i've got this percentage and gender and it was like whoever's hanging out
is hanging out but i will acknowledge yes i alienate uh chicks because i often do you know he
him and we've all got tentacles um you know i don't really address the clam that much but you
know you're welcome to uh that's terrible that's absolutely awful that's why there's only one
girl that watches me um what am i supposed to do oh i'm supposed to shout the old man i remember
well i'm glad you like it literally it does not bother me one bit i have definitely seen a bit
of an emergence um not so often but a few twitter posts here and there being like check out my
my viewer percentage and i'm like whoever wants to hang out more than welcome to hang out and i'll
admit off the bat yes i i can't alienate chicks because we see tentacle in this house and that's
fine like it's not it's not a problem we will do our best to teach you how to use your gift
we're all reeflings no matter what yes please hydrate my goodness how oh my god it's already
been two hours we've not even done anything we can show you the way but not your watch
show me the way i'm ready to learn you have an unborn gift but
clamsicles don't have the same ring to if your demographic is 90 percent men you're gonna address
the he yeah that elusive female cover she's way to work now last she's way to work we'll celebrate
her return after work play your work show so far how's it going how was the show
stony do you like knives uh like see his gold care pack so
me who's not paying attention to the poor i'm about to learn the second
word row so first row and then we'll go grab that in a minute okay
master iron art will now is we must find our queen
the shifling that's a fellow gunner combine it with foos foos row you have the gift of inbred
time flies when playing what are your favorite games yeah wait what give me give me the word
i should be spawning on the floor give me the word
this okay this happened on xbox as well where he takes like a full business day to give you the
damn word she be is live okay if you would like to watch she be cotton bomb play i actually don't
know i did talk to him he's currently giving me the power of the word but the word ain't spawning
above voice within
very few but in your case dragon ball
learn the power oh for goodness sake are we bugged out already
Todd congrats for your names Todd by the way but Todd my goodness Todd
do uh finally got it it just works yeah yeah but it does Todd Todd it's Todd short for something
toddler no that's not the full name what's Todd short for Teddy Theodore
Todd the toddler okay Howard no that's probably to Dorothy what Todd Howard Theodore Theodore
i don't know i'm just like what's short what's shorthand for Todd Todd Toddary toddler Howard Theodore
okay Toddles row row give me row row row your boat gently turn the stream
medley medley medley medley hope it's like a dream
Todd is short for Todd Ali foolish shite what where did that come from right demonstrate your
unrelenting shout is it this way open skyrim Toddster the Todd myster Todd room wait i've
gone the wrong way i wish you wouldn't do that oh right i'm supposed to do on this okay let's not
hit the game i thought it was a little easier on pc but i guess the pc and the xbox bugs are the
exact freaking same it just works in fact it does not actually work at all oh the poor baskets
going everywhere those poor old men are gonna have to pick them up because i'm being naughty and
shouting all over the place it's short for Todd's vision it just works
it's weird not hearing the fistful da part the da
it's just sounds like a dog barking
okay one i one i one i did go see part that yeah let me see part that let me see part that
master body hurry loin oh my god i can't believe it never been this far away from home
oh my god i can't believe it never been this far away from home hey you do have to wait for the
npcs to go through the door because if you go through the door first for some reason they don't
show up on the other side unless you want to wait but we need to assist the man through the door
they're there there you go into the yep end of the court you're up right despawned right i'm happy
with that i definitely confirmed a despawn i like to shout it shout it i like to shout it shout it
i like to shout it now everyone Todd is meant to be the name for the president of the cheese
club who is so full of himself he thinks starfield is a good game worth a what is going on with star
field i saw a clip of someone taking someone's ship and someone was like they just stole his
in real life money or something because he took a ship that was in game i don't know what's going
on with starcraft citizens but i hope you guys are doing okay out there because i don't i don't
nothing right okay we're all win oh sorry sorry i was a bit i was a bit excited to do that one
i apologize i was a wee bit excited right oh you can't change shout we'll shout it okay oh i don't
have a soul yet wrong game oh wait oh star citizen and starfield are different eeps the one where
it's been in production for like 12 billion years not to be dramatic but 12 billion years is how long
are you ready you want to see how fast i am i am speed come on come on baby come on baby
one world one spring oh sorry wrong one wait oh wait i wasn't supposed to do that with them
uh wait hold on i need to recharge my shower lydia please a little to the right lydia lydia
i'm looking to the right doll face like i know you're a bit daft in the head that's why you're
uh cell sword i just i just headbomb talk about an upgrade to the glas go kiss oh my goodness
don't
not my premature first don't make fun of me please one minute 56 beat that i bet you can
i thought it was easy for everyone oh my gosh you see that's why it's just someone legendary
right now what now what what the heck is it the horn one i think it may be the horn one you know
hold on let me check it is retrieves a horn now we can ignore that and go and do the thief's
guild which is much more exciting in my humble opinion so let's go all the way doing this hell
and we'll finish this little miscellaneous and then we'll go to the thief's guild
no no no no no no no no no no no no i get so annoyed with these guys because they always end up
killing npcs you need to drag the cultists out of any environment because they always kill npcs
and you can't resurrect the freaking thing so you need to wait until they come and attack you
get ready prepare yourself
they're so annoying you there you're the one they call dragonborn
yeah the graybeards yes i am
you are but he's shadow lord miran
right right lidia lidia please do not kill any of the guards i'm gonna be so annoyed
yeah yeah yeah yeah perish
super okay lidia got smacked up but she's okay that's good we'll take that oh
oh what do you can i destroy oh i can destroy these for uh a level up i'll i'll take that i'll
take that oh look at that i'll take that but mind if i do
yes i am dragonborn actually funny you mentioned that and passing i'm actually the dragonborn
you're the hey yeah we got the DLCs too whoa i don't want to what time is it oh wake up
wake up that actually really hurt my hands i don't know if you heard me
smack my bone on the table to try and make that noise
is this a fresh run it is we're just gonna be doing the best quests which is the main quest
and thieves guild and then because i completely messed up like a dum dum dummy dum dum dum
i delivered the supplies wasn't it it was anyway much appreciated here take this for your troubles
thank you uh oh i got 500 coin honestly that's decent we're gonna pick up ninroot because i'm
pretty sure there's a ninroot quest that'll air date right we're gonna check the map
and we're gonna go directly east because that is where DLC to
oh my god cute fragile girl bro i could hardly open those freaking cans of fizzies yesterday i
was actually getting embarrassed and then i couldn't even open up the kisses either i was like
freaking straining for my life thankfully my my sweaty hands came in clutch when i came to the
crisps uh oh excuse me just going for a swim casually a 500 quid is like literally so good
honestly that's like such a big booster start in the game uh right redmond's hall i don't like the
sound of that and we are just gonna try and discover the landmarks on the way oh wait we can
can we just use our yeah okay we can just use our ultimate to get a bit faster
the cultists are from myriac still see uh i don't like that one we can maybe do vampire
questline as well vampire thieves guild and main quests where the storm cloaks win in the end
yes please i think i will be very satisfied with their skyrim adventures doing that
clear cut and we're not kind of stuck with the hill come on there we go uh that definitely because
they're freaking actually that's another thing uh toad why make a serena in the first place if
i can't marry her like i'm not being funny but probably one of the best characters please leave
me alone i don't want any trouble okay i'm just passing through um but that's done their amazing
side quest honestly you should always pick ninroo it's the only plant that is limited in the game
oh are you gonna do the assassin guys quest the dark brotherhood actually i really enjoy the
dark brotherhood we may end up doing that as well as a sweet mother sweet mother send your
child unto me for the sins of the unworthy must be baptized in blood and fear i remember watching
that for the first time and just being blown away like i loved everything about her i'm
such an edgy little child such an edgy little beast um so i didn't want players to have too
much fun and they couldn't keep buying the new versions of skyrim honestly uh there is a forest
ahead i think after the forest is uh oh look at the rabbit goodbye oh i made a noise i actually
feel bad now i'm not doing that again if it didn't make a noise i'd be all right but because it
made a noise i actually genuinely feel really bad feels bad but you know that vampire woman sara
i think that's her name she can become human serena why am i so high up where am i
oh i'm on the freaking outskirts of the map rifton's here right that'll be why i can't go
any higher but i can go higher why can't i go higher
right what wait there's a pair oh that's lydia i was like why is there NPCs like all the way up here
where is it what why is this wait there's like a genuinely a path here though i'm looking crazy
have i even been here before
whoa okay we've got hunters that's fine oh there's a dragon thing off my head
there's like way more south side it looks like the end good hunt
you
i'm gonna transfer right now i'm so sorry
oh
where am i genuinely what i've i don't do that oh there's rifton okay i was getting so confused
i've literally just came the most difficult way possible i was getting so confused i'm like i
could have sworn rifton was east south east i literally isn't i can't believe i just did that
i must just flew myself off that oh this is the scuma then oh i love this quest so much
i got nothing on me you're looking for scuma head on downstairs okay um again book is worth 50 so
we gotta level up uh she be cotton bum is live right now if uh you're sick of todd howard winning
again uh yeah okay dummy that is an elk no it's a wool
go on the most difficult way yet literally the horse is currently um
vertical on the mountainside type of pathing because that i couldn't have made it any worse if i tried
trying to do some scuma oh my god would you do scuma with me at the next convention
have the next vtuber convention let's just scuma i don't even know what it's supposed to do
or mimic i think it's supposed to maybe mimic um barrel bine um
yeah because everyone seems zonked out barrel bine makes you very um
sedated in nature we're right rifton there's a wolf below me again
i'm just decimating the wolf population honestly skyrim's just scotland before they eradicated
the world she can't convince me otherwise like right i'm pretty sure if we discover yeah this
is the first um thieves thing farted and almost dies from fall damage 10 out of 10 far actually
i haven't been in chibi stream i'ma go over there for the first time yeah give it give
my genmeys a shout a shout give them a shot um they're absolutely fantastic in their own special
way um if you like burps chibi's your gal um i feel like bright little sisters emi's your gal
if you like adorable brats that'll call you an old man and tease you and you can tease her back
ac's your gal if you want to be babyed as soon as you're gal uh and if you want to be uh i don't
know what would mercy's if you want to be uh if you want a jealous experience watch mercy
and then i think someone described me as like the neighbor from next door that doesn't mean you
placing your hand on a round object and i was like honestly yeah that's pretty good pretty good
uh description yes there's chibi live if you'd like to have a have a chicken i don't know what
game she's playing senpai to yander yeah azure called her bingbong oh like sph bros again looked after
something chibi is talking yes you get before i let you into rift and yeah yeah visitors text
how about we do a little persuasion for the privilege of entering the city this is obviously
a shakedown keep your voice down my speech is 22 i don't know about you my speech is 22
there she is this is the person i normally wife but then again i become the head of the
thieves guild and she absolutely despises it you're not from rift my travels have taken me from
moral wind at all points in between why are you here then many years ago i lost my you and i see
grimm's week so with um oh this guy shakes his down as well um i'm i'm just passing i'm not scared
of you that's the wrong answer last thing the black briars need around here is some troublemaker
trying to steal a piece of the action who are the black briars have ripped it in their pocket
and the thieves guild watching their back so keep your nose out of their business why are you tell
me all this for free i'm maul i watch the streets for them if you need dirt on anything i'm your guy
but it'll cost you you're just begging for a pagan aren't you i'm sorry i don't know why i said that
my persuasion check failed eat eat i'm really getting tired of your excuses yeah like everyone
uh it's like okay this is the start of honest day's working in life for all that but everyone
wants to talk to you at once when you enter rift and i have to admit it's a bit of a sensory
bit of a cheeky sensory overload entering in your city and skyrim everyone wants to talk to you
right uh how could you possibly know that i'm a thief right i'm gonna tell you something you
should absolutely not do maybe you'd like a taste the game is going to ask you to plan a ring on
this person and it locks him up in jail and removes um a seller from rifting don't do it
don't do it okay if you do it it removes him as a seller and it's like another 800 coins you
can't get from selling stuff these symbols you see around the city um these are thieves guild
symbols you'll see them everywhere it means this place has been marked or there's something of value
inside like you'll see the symbols everywhere and you always want to fail this quest it doesn't matter
if you feel that you still get to become a part of the thieves guild um
oh he's not started his dialogue clearly because uh that should have done it
why am i being told to join the rebellion i didn't do anything oh come on hurry up
oh freaking the sick after that dialogue actually run out um
hello you're having some problems with uh that thief skilled person what do you want
what kind of trouble are you in i owe a great deal of money to someone and i think tell me the
details the stables and white run to sell me some of their tack and harnesses i borrowed some gold
from i hate that you can't just skip the initial quest honestly no no i'm a murderer who will not
be big difference man and if i don't pay her shiny as the whole pack is replaying what
i'll help you pay off your debt speak to sapphire about shaders debt
a voice in your head told you that there's so many sellers in rifting there are but
if you want quick access oh for goodness sake bring y'all wrap it up buddy
like this is getting really just me
i look kind of badass i am lydia the right hand of the thing of white run
oh come on me just fail it so we can start the thieves quest he's a jeweler too yeah definitely
especially when you're level up your um speech you can sell to like anyone which is so good
rest well see you in the morning when you wake up
we're not even started the thieves quest come on i'll discover this building because i've not
discovered it oh come on fail it okay that looks like i failed it surely
not the coughing it is anyone even doing anything bring y'all
no one is talking or interacting when i'm done here i'd be more than happy to sell you an elixir
you must be all right if you've got time to come i haven't rub on xbox it's not this broken
just what you see here what's he got for sale he's got 700 coins so we can
actually empty our inventory with him a little bit uh don't want to get too heavy
uh we don't really need any of that
just uh get rid of it all why not oh who's burping who goes there identify yourself
okay i don't think i can destroy a staff but oh my god this come on good old scum
right if he's not gonna let me fail that i'll move on to um austin grav a bit of austin gravie
hey in the micro wavy did he purchase dragon skills from you yeah he did you can pretty
much convince him to do whatever especially um one of the speech perks is actually having
being able to sell at any point shawnee you have her bore swords and her shields and you have my clock
whoa oh ninroo i hear it tada
there's a quest inside uh black reach which is um i just realized this giant can fly me halfway
across the map so i should probably be a bit more careful um hey how's shawnee going chilling in my
family's living room watching lol it's going good um we're just trying to fail the thieves guild quest
so we are purposely is there a moth in my room hold on i'm about to scream
is there a moth am i being pranked i think my eyeballs are pranking me okay i think i'm okay
okay i'm okay i'm safe um what was i saying um we're just going to continue the dragon born
quest line at the moment because we're trying to freaking get the uh why are you attacking me
i didn't do anything well you started it's i'm i'm i'mma end it i love how fast like they fall back
so no no don't don't try and escape you started it you uh right i'm not actually
didn't fight here we'll just go skip ahead it said it's already failed wait because i moved away
oh you stinking game you honestly right we'll do the thieves guild thing
uh wait does it even you can't fast travel while there's oh you know what this game such a troll
sometimes
can i like hate from them can they even see me come on i'm gonna end up activating a
mud crab and then i won't be able to like fly away
oh look this shouldn't burn arrows at me from here it's quite the distance honestly
this one is like bobby bee
caving in our man's breastplate with a single swing of the hammer
uh heck yeah who's bobby be bobby be
bobby be um to save time you're best going to the mestaville creep just to save a few
perishes where the heck why right take everything else off we're doing this quest only bring you
off i literally had to teleport away and didn't be annoyed just how long did you expect me to
keep those people distracted why are you going in here you don't sorry i'm he doesn't live in here
you caught me at a bad time lost someone yeah my organization's been having a run of bad luck
but i suppose that's just how it goes but never mind that even though you fouled up the job i still
maybe we get some food and a cup of tea shortly if you're up to the challenge no water i've not
even finished my first thing all right then hydration check let's put that to the test the
group i represent has its home in the ratway beneath riftway the tavern called the ragged
flag get there in one piece and we'll see if you've really got we've finally started the question
it will go down to the flag and then we'll take a quick pause so i can
peep and make some food guess what i've got lasagna that's right i can cook when i when i have like
really short streams i get so much done there are enemies but they're really not that bad
it's a shame you even have i see you stop using a sword that's a shield that's cheating
you such cheater make cheater things
uh i think no wait leave it out there's skevers
you can cook honestly i know it probably sounds like i can't i normally just
trap this to do this oh i let myself on fire like a devil
whoa that was supposed to deal with a rat but i guess not
there is a guy with fisticuffs in here
peeler how dare you all right i'll destroy those so we can get um that's an alchemy table
oh i keep doing that i've got them on the wrong way that i used to have them
i'm just gonna eat a lot of stuff don't mind me okay there we go
oh i want to see a test and see what it does um
just a random sword there's nothing special about the sword i'm not really sure what's that
oh uh
right
i remember those guys being so tough and legendary i don't know how you beat them so well
look it's okay to admit it's okay just i'm just so mlg pro
just eat 50 elbisa food to regain your hp literally right where the ragged bull and again
he had ragged on his fun again that's the best i go
look at the fit
whenever you guys call me last this is who i hear in my head when you're like yes last
getting here was easy reliable and headstrong you're turning out to be quite the prize so
refilling your prize how about handling a few deadbeats for me deadbeats our organization
some syrian i want you to explain sounds good do this right so we're basically going on a beat
them up quest i don't good uh we're literally gonna go beat them up for thingy um we can get back
faster at least but we don't have access to the the secret ending yet so we're the prize no you
if we're the prize how come we're the ones who won you you won me like that state wait
am i going crazy have i ever been here before
hold on oh my god you're cheese in it yes i'm cheese in it
need to be sensitive
what is this
what am i going wait oh it's the drop down goodness goodness sake i've never actually opened that
door in my life the drop down why was that why would there even be a god oh you can speed run this
area by unlocking that gate and going that way oh my god i'm learning what do you mean playing
the same game over and over again yields you different results my fine water skills like an
elephant would be nice to my nun right we're gonna go beat up some random citizens it's not very nice
but it is one of these come on baby right we're gonna beat up the the owner of this
hold on how'd you beat him up at level one it's a legendary uh approach
i've already told that before that i'm not paying you people look around you i'm barely keeping this
rattle together the worst thing to that i don't say i didn't warn you brah i like how she's so
game like she's actually so game to beat each other up take this and this and this
we just beat up a woman in her own established friend
yeah so you did have the payment don't make don't make me come back for that payment you hear me
yeah you understand you dumb dumb wait this business here she hates you after this damn right
she does i'm part of the thieves guild hey you have a message from briny off
oh it's one of you what do you mean you people doesn't even bother to show up itself anymore
what's the message simple you didn't pay me and bad things happen
are you squid me right now but the pope and everyone good girl brian why would you say that
iron beeper thanks for the tip why good god i didn't do anything we can protect ourselves
trust me
you people no that's it going to make you sorry for this oh yeah come on oh yeah hello a good friend
i knew you
forget how did you heal that's she in only i'm allowed to heal if you punch them again when
they're down they do uh get aggressive please no more yeah that's right that's right don't
don't ever don't ever not pay the thieves guild again open your mouth right now
you will pay the thieves guild what they're owed oh look oh my gosh we can buy this house and
there's flowers outside the house reeflings this is our house it's no we don't own it yet but this
is our house reeflings there's gonna be a big flower patch over here in a big garden and then
look how big and lovely our houses we get to buy it soon i think it's called the bezers home or
something like that but we'll buy it very shortly okay we just need the yorls it's you
please please don't hurt me i have a message for brian off himself i know who you are you've been
terrorizing the entire city yeah please there's no need for that here message understood here i even
have the payment good girl that's right good girl you just hand that money over nice and tidy
no one else needs to get hurt but strongy we're already home oh the mansion by the lake is better
the one that you built yourself ma'am are you leaving us in a town full of beggars and thieves
but we're a part of the thieves guild they're all on our side listen lass if you want to be a part of
the thief skills you need to learn how to chase it thank you razz nuts razz nuts look i'm not here
to judge anyone's gamer tag because you know i'm sitting here with strongy cuttles razz nuts
razz nuts we're like wrist these nuts in your mouth thank you i'll be here all week there's
your new gamer tag if you need new ones thank you for the tip
there's uh my tummy's rumbling oh no hopefully you can't hear over the ambience of the game
so job's done and you even brought the gold i did you did it clean i like that i did it clean
you can kill people for this yeah i don't i don't think i don't think we should kill be killing
people that's not really protection if they're damned here you go i think you'll find these quite
useful strongy the sound effects wait what about the sound effects
what sound effects turn it up turn what up
judging from how well you've handled those shots wait what what oh oh i'm
razz nuts more like wrist these nuts in your mouth
oh okay sorry we've run into tell you what sorry it took me so long to get i was like
what did i just say show you what we're all about oh we're getting introduced
oh my tummy's rumbling oh but we're getting introduced to the thieves guild part
start it loud and clear oh yeah listen to mercery bring your first
you should be your first we can talk a bit later okay maybe we'll do thieves guild and then we'll
do dark brotherhood because actually really don't start brotherhood and then we'll do vampire
quest lane
and then maybe
we have to do this all between 11 hours though
hmm and we're already down 9 to 9 hours hmm
Beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep beep
beep beep motto
no debates
no discussions
tell me repeated
What we say when we say
Did you really make myself clear?
Backwards
expertise
and your not talking about golden glow
this recruit possesses an aptitude for our line of work
So let her prove it. Let her prove it. Let her prove it.
However, the owner has suddenly decided to take matters into his own hands and shut us out.
He needs to be taught a lesson.
A lesson?
Mercer, aren't you forgetting something?
My outfit!
Oh, I get my outfit. Okay, look at the drip.
Zero minus aura, zero risk, no gift.
I'm expecting you to make us a lot of coin.
Wait, don't I get my outfit yet?
Simple. Do as you're told and keep your blade.
Outfit? Outfit check?
Outfit check? Outfit check?
Minus 100 drip, honestly.
Tonelia, Tonelia, Tonelia.
Alright, tell me about the job.
Makes sense.
Right, we're just beginning our first Thieves Guild assignment.
Basically, we're destroying beehives.
We literally said, yeah, we see the problems with environment, not our problem.
We are going to go talk to...
I've already forgotten her name, but she's in here and she's going to give us...
Has my OBS just died?
Am I still streaming?
Has my connection just died? Please don't.
Please don't do this right now, to me, connection.
Hold on.
I think my...
Oh, dear.
It's not looking bloody good for us, is it?
I just got an error message saying I'm not on VTIP Studio for some reason.
But you guys were saying you see me.
Oh, dear.
Right.
I'm still here.
I'm still here for some reason.
It thinks I'm offline.
That's mildly concerning.
Right.
It's mildly concerning.
But it's fine.
It's fine.
Right.
We're Tonya.
Up in the donya.
Tonya.
I remember her saying that.
Two lovers.
Forbidden from one another.
One who stormfuls the other legions.
Bye.
Yes.
Right.
Zero negative versus negative drip.
You know how it is.
Right.
And do this one, they're items.
And then April.
Look.
Oh, we, too.
Oh, wait.
Where did my weapon tree go?
Hold on.
Pop that back.
Back.
Home again.
Oh, actually.
I can put a soul.
I don't care Vex my goodness she's the worst worst character I see you
recognize that mug anywhere mmm they call her the fence because you get stuck
in her I mean what hey yeah oh man I can't get used to the normal oh you know
you're used to it right look at how cool that is there's a little secret little
secret thing you can do and then there's a de bella oh no tell us again the
bella that was here oh what am I supposed to do I'm supposed to go burn some
beehives are you ready I believe there's a sewer that you can get access to on
the outskirts or you can just walk up to it let me in question mark hello hi
there hi can I burn down your I don't remember where the sewer is I thought
they were gonna talk to me for some reason I don't know why but we have
agreed that backstabs with the axe would be devastating bro you wouldn't even be
able oh like you wouldn't even be able so I just call that I just literally call
that dragonfly with my teeth is this the sewer here it may be no that's just a
piece oh there's like a shoreline that has the sewer in it so you can get into
the estate we're just gonna crouch around like a little goblino what what what
oh my voice just cracked there let's spit right I think we might just go in
guns ablaze and honest oh Lydia's getting oh someone's looking at me I
don't know who but someone can see me right now right if we're doing fire we
need fire destruction flame and then one two three if you destroy all the beehives
then you're naughty we just want to and make them are you an enemy oh oh sorry I
did the I did the melee swing I apologize I did the swing and I always does
that no soul gym largely yes oh he just perished no my bees death by bees show me
what you're working with oh I've done that the killcams are sick when you've
got like good armor on it looks so good no submit only death yeah sorry although
the em how is it called the dark brotherhood have good armor and so do the
nating gales which we're gonna get very shortly thank you are you sure though thank
you very much for saying that is very kind of me I appreciate it thanks for the tip
I just I just feel like my accent accent McGee over here but thank you that's very
kind of you to say it's him it's been like you know I guess I can't say that but
yeah it's nice to be me I enjoy it very much I enjoy oh he's in here wait hold on
we need to destroy this other guy first and then we'll go in okay another kill that man
is right back yeah your accent is cute and hot don't forget the bee statue now hold on
I've only got seven lockpicks honestly I might need to start buying lockpick and if I'm serious
about this hello I'm gonna say worthless mercenaries I didn't think Maven or Mercer would allow me
to get away with this but I had little choice I can't if I do I may as well cut my own throat
mmm no I'm not about to let you ruin everything I've worked so hard I think he
fates you oh I'm sorry bro yeah you didn't stand a chance you were in your
hoity-toity clothes like it was over before it even began jeez I wonder if you can do it
without hurting him and what happens did you know this was a part of a freaking abandoned
quest thing that they never did I can't remember there's like symbols on the roof of the thing
you see that symbol and I can't remember what it was abandoned anyway they didn't finish it
I'll break the lockpicking yeah goes yeah lockpicking increased I broke I broke it hello
I broke it I failed I need to start looting like oh no one's dropping lockpicks oh you got lockpicks
no but thank you again and on this for that tip I appreciate you you went my way
you did well you did ask yes you can you can do the entire mission without being seen or hurt
in anyone oh well I'm definitely not that MLG stage thing every failure is a learning lesson
no no one's here oh Lidia Lidia Lidia are you for real
me when I get oh my sneak is increasing because Lidia Lidia he Lidia that was a whole ass man
Lidia that was very unexpected behavior from you that position as well she left them and she's
like yeah no more problem sorry I've gone the wrong way wow
I can't be bothered spell casting fire that sounds terrible
hey same I'm a ass man to POV the the position wait wait hold on hold on hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold that thought hold pause pause the position she believes you and after
she's done with you for the night okay you can breathe again you don't you don't need to pause
anymore you can breathe again the music in this game is goldly it's ethereal honestly
all right there's no other enemies I will happily take this money though you don't have to ask me
toys wow
all right bill of sale
all done nice return to bring you off yep all done
the fact you went back to crack the joke I don't know
wait am I going hey are there enemies I think there's enemies
open sky room
oh okay it was just like a a little deter if you will it will fast travel no we can't because
there's enemies nearby womp womp let's just uh there'll be like a fish in the war that will
also prevent me from going have an uh have an uh have an uh no no there we go
why no booms wait what did I make why would I be doomed a dead corpse
that's like being a dead corpse like a horse get it
okay well you put me on the spot okay you put me on the spot I couldn't do it that fast
let me take a look at what you felt our engulf sold golden glow he has no idea the extent
if only the parchment had the buyers last but for now you're off to speak them even black
prior she asked for you by name it's just business that's but right we're just basically going to
speak to the person who is hand in hand with the thieves girl and she oh also if you ever need
arrows for free literally it genuinely spawns and like I'm very good golf clap tomato tomato tomato
boo stop doing that uh we will take a pee break very shortly because our purple ladders will be
bursting for those of you who actually do hydrate and for those of us who forget to hydrate
you're just feeling a little bit tired because we need some food in the system
good for the boys bad for the julia whereas she's upstairs what's your problem yeah what's your
hello maven bright bar
confidence i hear or is that arrogant strange i'm often like confused yeah yeah yeah yeah right
she's gonna tell us to go do a quest where we manipulate um a competitor to her brewery
look for malice mark yes um which is quite a unique one because of what goes on inside the quest
quick question is our way to get into the these girl treasury not that i know of
um other than doing the quest line where it opens up and then it reveals uh and then it
the big root wait what oh it's been reflux need more honestly should i call a break
should we do it wait hold on let me let me finish my water
oh uh that was tap water yeah i'm not really fat atop war yeah when i have it in tea i guess it
covers up all the flavor i work with my mother to sell first time vegetable that anyone are you okay
i know it's scary i know it's scary to go into a new place for the first time but you'll be all
right and then you buddy just stop the fire take a seat and get the cold out oh my gosh i love it
i love this game so much i'm gonna hello hello hello can't a man drink in peace
jeez you look his eyes i've got like eye shadow on i'm gonna keep this
so we're to basically poison the bat from a meadery in order to get this guy arrested
it's pretty pretty yeah it's pretty deep plot i have to admit the plot is so deep like it's
probably i'd say an average of five inches deep of this plot um shut up just shut up um i will make
a tea and get some food in me because i think i'm starting to go slightly delirious because i've not
had anything i'm supposed to be holding a tasting of the new hunting so if he sees the meadery in this
state there's currently skeevers and at his meadery and we're gonna offer some well that's not how i
operate so you better or i'll yell skeever okay okay no need to make rash decision here's half my only
how do i permanent so he is literally handing us the poison that we're gonna poison the bat of
mead with it's it's it's so evil i love it please eat get that nutrition you i just get so distracted
when i stream like i don't oh fucking hell um i just uh oh sorry sorry i'm
it's all a bit pear shaped hasn't it uh yeah i just like kind of forget to eat and stuff
when i stream i just get so distracted because it's like such a good time i've always been like
oh my gosh oh all right i'm on the red oh you can't even see my health bar
oh wow my health bar is really bad right now uh i'll show you how bad it is i can i can heal
right now that's how bad it oh maybe i need to adjust my chat so it doesn't go over the screen
especially for video games like this i might get that change
uh spaking the honeybrew mead with emmy needs honestly emmy needs delightfully
did emmy would cry for it it's not bad you're no hit legendary i am
okay hold on lidia you lidia
lidia you literally went around the room what do you mean by over the screen so you see how like
next to me is that little cuttlefish to my to your left i guess from your pop see how the chat is
like going up on screen from that chat box i might change it so it doesn't so the video game isn't
um like encroached in any way because i just noticed now that you can't see my health bar
um you can see my stamina constantly but my big hairs oh oh sorry there's traps sorry sorry
oh sorry sorry oh oh lidia lidia there's traps like did you not just hear me jump over them lidia
oh right this fight always scares me because this guy is actually super OP for no reason
there's a man in here oh we need to we need to get him first because i have like no magic
oh bruv bruv hold on all right i'll get the rats first he is like so strong for no reason
and he freaking does that where he fucking backs off i hate when you back off when you're
fighting them like i know that's normal to back off when someone's like coming at you
but it's so annoying just stand still and let me parachute it's like not that big a deal
yeah so that man was currently living with the the skevers um you know as long as he's happy
and thriving that's the main thing but uh no a little to the right no no a little to the left
a bit more no a little bit more to the left
oh he's a mage yeah we hate mages honestly there's so annoying
male version of ime oh i mean ow i keep getting wrecked by these traps like i've like forgotten
them all right we'll finish this quest and then i will get some food in me because i'm probably
moments from perishing uh you can just grab this key but here by the way super easy um
um i totally didn't know that on my first playthrough and walked all the way back uh
like a dumb dumb no i don't want to steal from it it's honestly kind of picking up stolen items
is really annoying if the guards end up picking you up right we've done it we've done the quest
once we finish we'll take a look if you need to sample some of the finest mead in skyline
that your shift hasn't even started yet when i'm hello well it's about time
you'll just have to wait until after the camp right we're gonna watch it all we're gonna
watch it all in furl lydia go take a seat there lydia go sit lydia sit
what do you need go sit okay got it well
now that you've taken care of your i said go sit you're ruining the view lydia even though you
look just like me it's my finest room yet i call it the hate game from 2011 are you planning on
playing the elton ring dlc yeah we're you when it comes out we're replaying the full game again
and the dlc on pop i have no idea how big the dlc is it's probably gonna be a week of elden
ring so i do apologize to anyone who hates elton ring i will probably have like a shorter stream
and maybe do like a membership stream as well and switch it up maybe she doesn't like to be told
sit she's not a good girl bad girl
i don't understand silence idiot i should have known that actually well i'm here can we maybe
just turn the music down a tiny bit yeah it's a bit overwhelming you're like in fights and stuff
this is not what it seems but bouncing are we actually doing but bouncing i don't know
have you done it i feel like i want to like race to get us to do the dlc i don't i assume you get
the dlc once you've finished the game slamming our way through the lines in between with me to
dragons reach we'll see how quickly your memory clears in the city's prisons now move look i assure
you this is all just a huge misunderstanding i said move he's got the big guns
oh oh dear what is it now we have a tasting to attend to nothing you're supposed to go with him
bad girls are incredibly good girls are the future i don't think that could have gone
any better he always reminded me of lowkey uh i need to get a look at sab jones book so maven
wants you're welcome to take him here this should help thank you remember to put in a good word for
maven for me any good boys from even and then you then you all go boo and then i say any good boys
for stroney and you'll go yay and rejoice right we you won't get away with that
is he gonna attack me
you won't get away with that i'm sorry i can't believe that worked
what am i not being as high that was so scary i accidentally picked up the ball
i'm a good boy for stroney you are his bestest refling
all right we're going we're going back to hand in the quest and then we're gonna take a pause
break i'm gonna make a tea and get lots of food um and then we'll rant and rave about any and all
topics actually i should check out marshmallows i've been getting sent some uh uh live review
looks and i'm just i'm that doesn't mean that doesn't mean i trust you have good jobs finished
here's info the only thing that could identify well you should bring this in there's also the
matter of your payment yeah yeah yeah what does she give me oh she gave me an iron sword of embers
i can destroy that i'll be a good boy for sure if he picks a ball stop right there criminal scum
honestly this game is so sensitive like honestly i feel like right hand in this freaking quest and
then i will go eat i am starving my body is literally doing the rumble jumble and i'm feeling
i'm feeling weaker oh help me refling help me i'm so weak oh you're just gonna have to
spin feed me uh you just need to look after me i'm a delicate little flutter okay
okay hello hello word on the street is that poor sabbjorn is found as you wish
i won't peak i won't ruin it what you're giving me to eat okay
exactly maven sent word that you discovered then this has been someone's trying to take us down
oh someone's trying to take the thieves killed down and it's not us i've never seen him this
before complete dump why did the color palette just shift there i could do
i blink and you'll miss it honestly here comes airplane i found the same marking at the honey
broom eatery you admire them just don't mistake how can we make them pay
name is gullama gullama i'm betty get out there shake him down shake him down shake him down
uh i need to talk to brinjalph again hi brinjalph i can't believe gullama is mixed up in all this
gullama not to be confused with golem a don't get me wrong you could scam a beggar
how about i recite the work even more and oh i reduced the work even more and chew it for me
do you know that's how um used to food babies back in the day um it's actually really common for the
mums to chew the food and then give it to the um sorry um yeah so like before baby formula was a
thing and like solid food training or whatever like before the again a capitalism market kind of
exploded went to hear about what nesli did um yeah it was like really common your mom
chose the food for you and then gives it to you in your mouth it's like a little baby bird moment
and everyone's like that's so gross and i was like bro that's the way it is it's just like how how
it be you know it's very interesting i actually could probably write an entire video i say about it
and then present that video i say live on stream and just to show everyone how natural things are
but everything's been so like oh they're so weird but it's only weird because we've not been exposed
and we no longer even talk about it because it's like literally unironically being bred out of us
over a few generations because capitalism is away um what one fun world stroney did you consider
getting mana as backup food yeah mummy bird and literally i didn't know that was a thing it is so
um uh babies newborns should start on breast milk because it's full of colostrum um and it's
also because a baby doesn't actually have an immune system until six months old um so it's
very important to have breast milk however um it was very common to have what's called a wet nurse
which is when um a woman who had recently had a child uh would share um because it's very common
for some women to experience a surplus and it's very common for some women to experience uh
problems producing milk it's just kind of random doesn't really there's a lot of factors that come
into play um obviously stress is a major one stress on any human body for a long period do you
mind i'm telling a story about tiddy milk leave me alone um but yes uh i'm sure as a lot of you
can imagine being stressed for a very long time is very bad for your health um guys uh guys uh
stress manifests in a lot of mental health issues and a lot of loneliness um
um oh are we gonna make it you know what we're gonna send it send it right hold on hold on
let them fake them out a little fake them out fake them out fake them out it's fine
wow wait wrong one oh shit i'm out of stamina and he's like right next to me this is rather
embarrassing i have to admit uh i didn't really think this far through yeah stress got me pretty good
yeah i like it here because i learned so much information okay there we go we can get away
worse i hear it i don't see it i think that's good that i don't see it though because it means it's
not near me don't call me out like that yeah it's very um interest in the way it physically
manifests in the way like obviously i think the majority of us have been like raised in a western
society which obviously comes with a lot of socialization and socialization plays so much
into the how you can deal with stress factors and like it's just kind of a sad fact that like
homeboys uh kind of get told to suck it up um like i can literally go greeting to the girls
right now and it's like nothing nothing's wrong with it or anything um but it's very interesting
how you tackle it i don't even know how you tackle it i wouldn't even have a clue where you start
like the only thing i guess you could hope for is pockets of communities and over time ideas get
popular like um when the general consensus of society changes that's when the real change comes
through but the problem is you have to basically go out with the old and how do you go out with the
old well the the old passes away the old doesn't bring down it bring down the old doesn't pass on
its teachings like for example um i like my grandparents talked about how they got hit by
their parents um it was a very common place to be hit if you didn't know it's actually illegal
to punish your child via a corporal punishment yes your own child in scotland is legal and you
will be prosecuted for hitting them no it is not punishment no it is not spanking no it is
literally against the law you're welcome to go up and it's very bad for the child
there's a lot of things done around it um but it's very fascinating um how quickly things can
change within a generation so my grandparents told me stories about them getting hit by their parents
they did not hit my parents like they didn't hit mom and dad and then you know opposites i didn't
hit mom and dad and mom or dad so my mom spanked me so my dad never hit me he doesn't like it he
doesn't believe in it and he absolutely despises it my mom so there was this orange slipper
and she used to hit me with it all the time because it was such a low child um
but it's very interesting because um within a couple of generations in scotland it's a big
no no to discipline your children via punishment like that physical punishment um and it's just
like interesting to see as the generations come and go like some people might not like the emphasis
like oh if you're in this age range you're gen x if you're in this you're a zoomer you're this you're
that but the reason it is so purposeful and so important to have these names for generations
is because there's also a lot of societal behaviors that emerge i hear nin root i hear it yes um and
uh so like you who are listening to me right now odds are we were not raised in the exact same
society with the expectations and whatever's however we are crazy enough to have the ability
to set up a community like main where we may agree on how things like should go and how things
shouldn't go and we have created a pocket a pocket of a collective that can provide secondary
socialization which is crazy because primary socialization is your parents but secondary is
like outside outside influence and i could influence you to see the world differently
through my words which is like insane um even we might not even be in the same generation and it's
just as freaking socialization is fantastic stuff i will also probably write a massive stream essay
i would love to talk about all this stuff in higher detail but right now we're about to do the thieves
quest and i've forgotten again to get food but that's okay we're just gonna sneak on in
that's right you're being educated and you're well uh against you well get educated get educated
get educated strongy feeding us knowledge we'll forget to feed herself honestly are you
sweating me right now by the pope strongy sorry for interrupting but would you kindly get food
and tea okay yes i will thank you um penitent i get penitent i've said penitent with no teas
do you become pen in it pen penny ten penny ten penny and penny in thanks for the time sorry i'm
having a stroke because you've got teas in your name i will quickly go grab some food and go for
a pee i highly recommend everyone who's listening to please go get some water go get some tea this
is an endurance stream so we're gonna be here for a little while we're gonna finish the
thieves quest and then we're gonna do dark brotherhood and then we're gonna do vampire quest line
because i enjoy it very much stop your knowledge it's too big oh yeah you can't handle my knowledge
take more take more take more um but yes please get up and stretch your legs please get some
more hydration i'm gonna get a cup of tea some water i might even get a cola i'm feeling so
naughty to get cola so please do get your legs a stretch and yes and analyze the color of your
yes manifest too dark then you need to hydrate more okay get in food get in food get in food
honestly you can't force the knowledge on me is it really forcing if you want it though hmm
did i did i tell you that whenever i make a i guess like forbidden knowledge whenever i make an
audio where i'm very our word um people really enjoy that so i just let you should know it seems
to be a thing though that like anyway uh i'm literally standing up swiveling on my chair i will
be back uh give me like four minutes to pee and a cup of tea and heat up my Liz Hagney like two minutes
in the microwave sounds about right i think but yeah i'll be back in a minute okay
so
What shenanigans did you get up to whilst I took a big fat Joby?
Okay, I've got food, lads she's been gone for 84 years, I've not, I've not, I've been
good.
Like, none of it's true.
I got cola, I got a tea and I got food, I'm so happy.
A what now?
Like, all I'm saying is the kettle was boiled and the microwave had microwaved, okay.
We talked about the happening.
She's back, I am back.
And I have food, a nice tab out and look at marshmallows or is this gonna break the
game?
Wouldn't that be hilarious if it broke the game and I had to redo it all over it then?
Oh my god that would be so funny, please don't do that.
Where's my mouse?
Got this?
Okay, we're back.
How do I open up marshmallow?
We're just gonna be stuffing our faces for a couple of minutes so I'll read marshmallow.
The toes, the toes from the stream the other day hit all the right spots, thank you so
much for caring to your people's desires.
I had quite a bit of spicy time, can't wait to see more of those toesies, oh you'll be
excited for tomorrow's stream, oh my god, oh that's funny as anything.
I want to him in your curls, my curls, my curled toes?
Wow, when you tape you keep your hand on the WASD keys, you're a true gamer, typical
people keep it ASDF, do they have that WASD?
Oh my god, I can't believe it, I'm a nerd, you've caught me.
You have the most beautiful tiny hands in the world, yeah some people said my hands
were small, I'm not, I don't actually, I think my hands are the average size for a
Whammon, I thought, I don't even think funny, I actually thought I was like bang on average
for everything, but I guess I'm not and I'm actually on the smaller side, they are tiny,
oh okay, like when I got the ruler out, oh sorry I just punched the microphone, when
I got the ruler out I thought that was really fun because everyone can kinda, WASD is natural
hand position, yeah I definitely agree with that, mm-hmm, God you have no idea how badly
I want to hold my hand, I should come to a convention then, I'll have, I'll get a body
guard just to make sure everything's all above ground, but yeah I can bring all damn things,
I don't know, I feel like if someone comes to a convention to come see you, I like the
idol meetings, like the Japanese idol meetings where they hold your hand and you can talk
and look at each other over the table type thing, I think that's really sweet and cute,
but I don't know, I don't know, it just seems like something, I dunno, it's just me, mm-hmm,
the ASMR booth if only, I wish a convention would entertain me to do that, that's honestly
ridiculous, make sure everything's above the table honestly, who would get in trouble first,
me or you, me or everyone, let me analyze this one,
hey Strony, is there any chance for a hypnosis with helping the listener with addiction
or focusing desires upon yourself from distractions, um,
oh I'm not sure I can do stuff like that, mine is always of an alternative nature
for grat of the defying nature, I absolutely am not qualified or capable or doing anything that
kind of has like a, I don't know what the word is, but like I, therapeutic, yeah I would say
any therapeutic hypnosis I can't participate in because I don't actually have the knowledge
on who goes there, how to do it safely, so safety first I will admit this is out of my
league, I am definitely not there and I don't think I ever will be there, um 10 out of 10,
9 out of 10, holy moly, oh yeah, oh did you forget when I eat I burp even more, that's right,
the air gets trapped in these lungs, eh lungs in this stomach, I gave you my tribute cherry
and no one else, you're the only woman to ever, ah
these are supposed to be special, I have a mindset in the first place, oh I don't
ever feel like forced to or anything, but I do like that, I took your cherry,
hi Strony, just finished watching your sweet stream and I have to say those sweets are not
as sweet as you, those sweets aren't as sweet as you, hey, oh okay we'll give you that one,
that was cute, okay that was cute, every journal joke I know though, also did you know that the
bumps on the F and J keys on your keyboard are there so you can correctly place your hands
fingers on them without looking or touching, I thought the WASD was funny, I didn't know that,
you have taught me knowledge, everyone please finger the F key and notice the bump on the F
that is for positioning reasons, and in light of recent events the girls have made it clear
they don't want our unfaithful scene, even with your permission if they are reciprocal
and dedication, I am happy for them and happy to oblige their wishes, however this means your
king will be ignored, my sharing, I'm trying to navigate this in a particular way, I think we
all know, I'm trying to get around it, I will just have to, I will have to, I can't say anything,
my tentacle is no once again for your exquisite news, oh I love that and only,
I can't read anything else over that, there we go finger in the F, yes
mmm yes, my sea queen, my sea queen yes, they can entertain my sea queen due to the girls
preference, yes
oh my god my pc, I don't know if it's because it's on standby but it's making the room
unbelievably hot, hi cuddles, during this stream this morning you ask what a fumu was
in response to my comment about some plushies, they're basically smug plushies of popular
characters from the two whole series, however they have developed a bit of a cult following
due to memes and such and ended up with people making their own similar plushies like the
Neurosam and Evil Neurosam, oh okay okay from Makership, ah yeah yeah yes I see, I see thank you,
am I too big for you, oh that's that's a link, that's a link, we'll investigate that later on,
hi Strony, thanks for the fun stream today, a lot of the American sweets did not look safe to eat
well but I'm glad you found a new thing you'd like, yeah Makin' Eggs, orange flavor, I'm all about that,
I'm all about the Makin' Eggs, I've always had a keen interest in hypno content, I'm very very curious
to experience what you have to offer and even more intrigued by the idea of permanent info and
I do have a reverse audio that will be publicly accessible, please don't worry, I've always thought
that hypnosis would never work on me and I'd like to give it a try, literally you, if it's not for you
that's more than okay, I do offer like alternative like audios and stuff that aren't that theme but
if it's not for you please don't ever feel forced to like go along with it if that makes sense,
like either it's for you, you can give it a try, if you're open minded you'll see,
will you give us your best sometime, also you're quite, oh my god I'm choking on my lasagna,
you can hear it slide down my throat, also you're quite literally the cutest cop fish I've ever
seen, thank you, you make me feel a certain kind of way with that voice of yours, oh yeah yeah,
like this, top, why do I say top of the morning, is this one not scott's, good morning, good evening,
good afternoon, right today we're playing Skyrim, that's right, Skyrim belongs to the north,
oh someone says it, someone says I never thought I'd be too big for my beloved,
I don't know how to handle this information, pick the other hole, it's really not that,
it's not that hard, actually I encourage you very much, please don't worry,
I will, I will teach you the ways in the membership stream,
I love your content, hope to see more, I'm in the process of making a short story for you,
but now that I'm halfway done with it, I'm on the verge of scrapping it, no, pure shame, no,
if you ever, if ever saw the late day, I would need a new identity, it's not even explicit,
I use very loose words, but yeah maybe I shouldn't have brought it up, oh don't be scared to put your
creations into the, are you joking me, you know all the scripts that you've heard from the girls
so far, I wrote that, do you think I was proud of the first thing I ever wrote, no, don't scrap it,
let me read it, I want to read, I'm eating cauliflower that's coated in flavour,
hmm, um, I'm so sorry, hi scrawny ass in the stream, but looks like it's in past chat,
what's the model of your keyboard, uh, uh, Corsair, something, I think it's the,
it's the Australian version because the number two is the at key, which is actually the wrong key
in the UK,
this is delicious, this is exactly what I need to stream for 12 hours,
hey scrawny, just want to say I'm glad that Vealer is up and running,
um, I've been following since another life and really enjoyed her refresh and your content is,
that's because I'm unprofessional, so happy to see your dreams come into life and bring in the
V-trip and, flash-trip and re-re-e together, I feel like what you're doing is really breaking
out in your character, oh shucks, you stop that, you're, you're, you're blowing,
smoke up my arse, I am getting my ego stroke so hard, what's going on here,
um, new character, I'd love to see it, can't wait to watch you all in the rest of the
years to come, you stop that, I hope they all continue to achieve their dreams, I do too,
my next goal, once everyone, who goes there, once everyone is monetized, um, we will get,
um, my next goal is to get them all to 5k subscribers because we have a celebratory artwork
for that when everyone achieves it, so I'm very excited, oh, it has to be there forever,
me who has to think of the second, uh, video game for Gen2,
MonkaS, I don't even know if anyone's going to like my idea, but here we go,
hi strongy,
that's just someone's measurements, 13 centimeters, okay,
17, all right, that's the reflens, what's going on, you all filed for those ads that were like,
take this pill,
so wonderful to see you and the other girls flourishing post debut, here's the great and
healthy future, hopefully it's the shiny and pearlescent, as your outfit is strongy, big love,
thank you so much, big love, everything, that's a link, so, uh, can't, can't, uh, look at that, um,
hey, hey, and under this color, I know you like whimpering, there you are, who told you that,
but what should you take on talking during gifts, example calling you a good,
be sucky, the best little, if you want to do that, go for it, yeah,
oh my, yeah, if you want to say that stuff, go for it, I ain't gonna say no,
hey, strongy, I'm a skit, so refling, oh, bless your heart, are you okay, son,
is there any way to retract my mod application, oh, if you get picked for a mod, don't worry,
you can just reject it at any point, if you get that offer, oh, bless, yeah, I hope you're okay,
but I don't trust myself with that kind of power, that's really good on you to, uh, be able to see
that maybe it's not the best idea for you, good on you, skit, so refling, god, the way, it's just,
it's how direct you identified yourself that was kind of humorous, sorry, I do apologize,
I'm not laughing at you, I actually just found it, just like, hey, I'm skit, so refling, like, you just,
you just, like, slammed your boars on the desk because of the, just like, yeah, let's get straight
to the point, um, so sorry, that was rather humorous the way you wrote that, yes, please just reject
the offer, if you do get messaged about it, I actually have no idea, uh, mommy, please, I wanna,
hmm, while listening to you, hmm, hi, Strani, I just wanna say thank you, thank you so much,
Reeler, I'm really, really happy you're back, but I'm also happy for the other girls too, I am too,
they're also sweet and talented, oh, I know they are, absolutely adore them,
I can't read that one out loud because that's very, that's very, uh, maybe in a membership
room, I tried suggesting another man to make you his new Oshi because he was an old-school
runescape addict, when he's out of the picture, I'll swoop in on his wife, not that I'm trying,
well, what, what are you saying, you're trying to get, what, you're trying to get me an old-school
runescape sugar daddy, I've, none of you have seen the runescape series so far, there's just one
installment, oh, shit, management just showed up, everyone front and center, I, I, I'm serious,
you can also contact the website and mention the email you used in the mod application to get it
removed, okay, yeah, that seems fair, um, uh, what was I saying, oh yeah, I literally have like 22
million gp and all I did was show up in freaking fish,
hi cuddles, I'm currently watching the mod of today's ace marstream since I missed it while
sleeping, I'm someone who has never been able to go under despite having a, having a flavor for it,
so, one issue I have that I become,
hysterical, I can't read that, um, uh,
uh-huh, okay,
okay, we have quite an effect on this replay, that's adorable, I like that,
I'm managing with quick hands above desk honestly,
hi, I love you mom, I love you to everything, the stream was incredible, I'm really glad that
I interest you and I can't wait to see what you do next, also I'm still here and she'd be streamed
for you, I'm devoted to you, I really want to send you something, but I haven't had the inspiration
been really in my, my emotions lately and it's really slammed my libido, do I know a sad fact,
my alternative picture is the last time, rip in the chat, I've been so freaking stressed like
all the time and I can't like unstress myself, I think it'll calm down like once the thing
but like I'm so freaking stressed and it's such a shame,
but I'm sure I will get inspiration soon, I think maybe, I'll tell you what, I think maybe once
the monetization for everyone has been achieved, I'll start to feel relaxed because like then truly
is up to the girls, whatever they want to do and I can just get fun shorts ordered of them,
but like right now I'm like, oh my god there's four out of six, why is the other two not come
through because we applied for them all at the same time, like oh no weapons of one of the girls
don't get YouTube monetization, oh no that's like a whole month and uh just like oh I don't,
oh I would be sick if I think about it, we pretend we do not see,
but yeah, the, what did I just say, there's a line of volunteers is extremely long, thank,
yeah you guys want to make gentry right now?
I've almost finished eating and then I will slurp my honey tea and then we'll get back into
the thieves guild, Skyrim's going good, we're at um Gollum from the thieves guild quest,
we're about to be meeting the big naughty on who's trying to take down the thieves guild
soon to him and then once we do the thieves guild we are going to do the dark brotherhood
because I actually really enjoy it, it's quite, I think the dark brotherhood is actually relatively
quick um and then we're going to do the vampires and then if we still have time we're going to do
um the actual dragonborn quest line which I hate doing because it breaks the game
and if you ever like seriously want to do like a hundred percent speed run,
eh speed run, not speed run, just a hundred percent achievements, always leave it last
because it breaks the game so much when you have to like say like oh we'll give white run up or we'll
give this uh rifting up or we'll do this or we'll do that, every detail of how much it breaks the
game, but I finished my my bowl of lasagna, um now I've got my cup of tea and my cola, I do, I do,
I've got my cola, no need to read this during a stream, oh yeah what happens if I do it right now
the ASMR stream was amazing strongy, I was putting your hands during it, ah that's so cute
hmm
I'm giving you, oh whoa someone is giving me a step by step
gate on how to do haptic feedback
inalize, inalizing, okay that's the law links, um how down bad do you think is too down bad for
you, for me, oh no I like, I like main corruption
so there's not really a down too bad, I think corruption's really um up there um oh my first
membership stream can be about that, no about ranking everything
inalize, yes, oh strongy, I just want to thank you for giving all the girls a home and a family,
Vila are such a positive part of the environment already and I'm happy to watch along with all
the other reflins, oh reflin, I said also the latest patreon post is incredible,
did you like it, I thought it was good, would you let me pick on your party
yes if you are a patreon member um another audio has gone up so there's a total of three audios
up, um it is spaced out for the other girls so because all the audios were uploaded on the first
that did mean there's a bit of a break between the next one that comes up but as it stands
everyone has a day, if I can remember correctly Azura, Monday, Mercy, Tuesday, um Emmy, Weddin's Day,
Shebe, Thursday, AC, Friday, strongy, Saturday, I'm not quite sure but just so you understand
they are purposefully spaced out who goes there and um they will be like every Tuesday
all of X's will go out on every Tuesday all of like for me every Saturday an audio will come out
like that kind of thing um we I'm going to get the girls to post on what's inside like with the
tags and everything I just need catch up time um she says as she's sitting on Skyrim for an
endurance stream I've got nothing but the cheek I really do I've got nothing but the cheek but
I do need catch up time to get into the floor things then next month um 100% will be like you
will see what's inside if you want to subscribe for that month or not and if not then you know you
can take a look at whoever else is posting maybe they've got something a bit more up to your style
again I would like to repeat when it comes to the audios I have not shoehorned anyone into the
same type of plot if you will because that will not financially enable them to be the
content creator they'd like to be um a lot of the girls are looking at moving out possibly if
they're able to receive enough support so that's why I do say if you only have enough money to
support one girl please do pick a daughter of mine because um they are gunning to move out um
and it means they would provide more content and yeah it's just a very positive cycle occurs um
yes uh yeah I'm both meanies like not bad just to kill it by emoji if you subscribe to everyone
you get an audio every day I mean technically you're very close you get a rest day no one uploads
on a sunday also they deserve it yes the girls work incredibly hard um AC was like am I allowed
someone asked a question to AC on marshmallow like uh how do your recordings work and she was like
am I allowed to talk about this and I'm like yeah you can as long as you don't see anything that's
like NDA obvious then yeah you can talk about how I I burst into your DMs and hand you a script and
all the spelling is wrong and the grammar's whack yeah you can talk about that all you like I say
actual day of rest honestly um but yes thank you for thanking me for giving the girls a home
but please understand the girls did it themselves they reached out to vealer they applied um they
went to an interview and they were happy with everything some of them did the very thorough
research uh Emmy actually was the most inquisitive and had the most questions Azura I think she was
just like is any of this real I think she thought she was dreaming because she never asked a single
question after the interview um yeah Azura was absolutely adorable Emmy asked a ton of questions
which made me think she wasn't actually gonna accept the character because I told her what the
character's theme was and I saw people were being weird but yeah Azura was like fuck it we ball
NDA and the dogs did not withstand and they have carte blanche what carte blanche
but what uh in English what in English English that's so Azura honestly yeah this one's like
big mommy we ball honestly a free pass or it means like free reign oh carte blanche a blank menu
is what the translation is that makes sense a free pass a blank menu oh my god I can't believe it
sorry I translated it literally versus uh metaphor good uh
hi sending messages scares me but I want I watched your ASMR stream and it was amazing
I can't wait to see more of your stuff both ASMR and other videos they're so fantastic I'm watching you
do what you love and making ASMR making via lure has me thinking I should start and follow my
you should follow your own dreams you've only got one shot I keep snail blinking please Paul
please don't notice me snail blinking you do you've only got one shot if you've got a dream
or something you want to achieve where can go for it like if I win the lottery already know what I'm
doing all I'm saying is if I win the lottery the girls are getting stacked out so I'm saying um
you know the split going even higher you know oh it's always fun to try and reach for a new goal
like for example hypnosis is my new goal I've always enjoyed it and always liked it but I've
never made it myself because like I'm just like not skilled and I need to make sure it's safe
and all that sorry I'm trying to wait there's a fucking cat hair on my face and it's one of
those cat hairs where you wipe it away and then it does a 360 look back on wherever it's freaking
a caption I'm so sorry that'll be gimley honestly um but you honestly you placed everyone in their
spots so well I wouldn't picture anyone else yes there is right no I'm not gonna say it because
I might start up some shitters um and we ain't stirring the pot from these parts we tap the
sign from these parts um let's see hi strongy could you give us a hearing test like hearing
test ASMR of course I can do something like that for ya you do a 360 and walk away wait a minute
a 180 oops wait no 360 is the circle 180 is the opposite right okay um I could absolutely
do a hearing test I did a ear cleaning where I'm like muffled until as the audio progresses I'm less
muffled I thought it was pretty cool I need to edit it actually it might be one of my one and four
because I owe you four this whole Skyrim stream actually kind of went perfect because tomorrow
I will do my monetization celebration stream where everyone can absolutely laugh in I'm pretty
sure someone's probably already guessed what I've got planned for it there's no way after yesterday's
stream someone hasn't put two and two together and knows why I got a pedicure in particular
I refuse I refuse she fell for the oldest these eggs box joke honestly do a 540 believe it
um my body prevented me from my dreams so I come about have you ever had an actual medical
ear cleaning I've not had a medical ear cleaning but I did get my hearing checked as a child um
because I was ignoring my mum where I was undiagnosed it was my idea actually um
I'm going to sip my tea before it gets too cold okay
eh yeah my mum got me uh sent her a hearing test because she was sitting on my dash she was like
scrawny doesn't he listen to me like scrawny scrawny never hears me and I used to do this thing
where I sat right in front of the tv so the tv was on a stand but I would sit directly under it so
my neck was looking directly upward sorry I just hit the mic there by yeah I know you can't see my
hands but my mic was at my mic my neck was directly upwards looking at the tv like pure pure in a
trance like straight up like Tism a doctor walked in and Tism was the diagnosis type thing and obviously
my mum didn't know what it was all about at the time so I got sent for a hearing test and she was
like the wife that did the hearing test on me she was like oh no pet you're here in Spain I don't know
what's going on with you um and yeah basically that was that's when the signs start to show
and then now here I am someone who has to read and write for a living and goodness gravy is it
freaking hard I'm slurping is she okay nah she's just fucking hell autistic
a kid with autism how close were you to the tv oh I'm not being funny when I'm like I was
directly below the tv I like I was sitting crisscross looking directly up at the tv and my
neck was up in the air like and I and my mum ascertained that it was hearing issues rather than
something else what might be going on she had a case of strong autism honestly the strong
too strong
and that's not good for your eyes oh well I do actually need to be wearing my glicks but
I'm making it work okay I was right in the vtuber collab scripts and I was like this is too small
this takes so I zoomed in and I'm like oh my god I'm gonna be a blind as a fish like really soon
wait that's literally me as a kid literally
do you reckon cuttlefish have actual autism um as an uncertified marine biologist anything
is possible if you didn't know down syndrome is possible in animals as well um I believe
down syndrome is the deletion of chrome zone oh god was it in humans uh not 32 that's not right
I can't remember which deletion it is but it can happen in gorillas seriously I'm not even
kidding look up down soon down syndrome gorilla and like it's fucking creepy oh it's an extra
addition of 21 sorry yeah I'm thinking of the deletion one what is the deletion one called
that I always watch documentaries about it happens when life deletes 32 yes um actually
spindle fiber failure um uh which is I um I find it really interesting oh god yeah I feel like
every time I'm like I find this so interesting and fascinating it leads to me rambling about
something that you guys couldn't give less of a shit about I feel really bad but at the same
time I really like blabbing away so I'm like that just do it that just tell you about um
fertilization so the reason why the rate of down syndrome goes up dramatically the older
the woman is beyond the age of 25 yes the age of 25 um you're you're already hitting the wall at 25 rip
um the reason it goes up exponentially is because the failure of the spindle fibers that's what pulls
apart um that's what pulls it apart and then results in a the an additional chromosome wiggling
about which is the rise of down syndrome which is why women who um are having children later in life
are often advised to do what is referred to as a DNA test which I've completely forgotten the name of
but basically they pierce the amniotic sac and take a tiny cell sample of the baby and then check
its DNA sequence under um you know get it because to see if the child has done syndrome or not and
then either they're advised would you like to terminate or not or bring to term whatever
type thing goes on but um it definitely is a risk and uh like also being obese with the child as well
results in gestational diabetes which is very dangerous for the child very dangerous for the mom
um there's also um if depending on the blood type of the mother and the blood type of the child
the mother during the entire pregnancy her body can be attacking the baby until it has a natural
abortion if you didn't know abortion is the natural term but you can also get a medical abortion
but abortion is the natural term for it just happening
there are many reasons why it can never come to term how do you know all this stuff is fascinating
no I don't go to school I like watching youtube videos about um biology related things I have a
fascination in uh diagnoses in particular like why the reason it occurs for example um like uh
there's this syndrome uh of course it evades my mind I think it's called like William Hunter's
syndrome where the child or the well the child that can become an adult um because you you do not pass
away uh unless you have complications with other diseases for example um you will never experience
the sensation of being full uh you will constantly eat um there's like hereditary syndromes as well
like hunter syndrome which is pretty uh devastating and um there's interesting one such as dwarfism
dwarfism can actually be passed on by two individuals who visually do not have any um display of any
dwarf uh ism genetics um but it is a recessive gene and if the two people come together um yep
we can have it how do you know all this riefling that obviously has not got the
angel man syndrome is that angel man syndrome is that the one where the child is locked in the
child like stay I believe so mentally they can't develop any further um uh yes uh Harley Quinn
syndrome um doesn't sound like what it is it's where your skin constantly your skin regenerates
so fast that you flake and you break and it's just absolute it is a living heck for those poor
like children that are born but you can make it to adulthood um there's a lot of sad um
diagnoses that you can get like you can get childhood dementia those are quite crushing ones um
stroneys institute for the gift to take that angel man is the eaten one is it Harley Quinn
it she was this year is dwarf ism classified only as being short there are a redonkulous
amount of dwarfism classifications um some can be like no stunted growth on the abdomen uh other
versions are no stunted growth on the arms and the legs but the um organ holder area if you will
for lack of better words abdomen all the interest in that like there's so many different classifications
is quite um it's quite fascinating stuff when she uh get into torso yeah torso will do just
nicely uh I remember when the photos of those babies were used as shock for yeah unfortunately um
kind of if you use older like if you look up like Freud's stuff for example you get quite a few
older photos that are like Freud Freud you didn't have to photograph that mate like you know do you
know about prisons yeah like the stanley prison experiment and how people play roles that they
perceive to be superior uh absolutely fascinating stuff I do enjoy the psychology I has to offer um
I think humans and our everyday socialization were always kind of it's always insinuated that
there's someone to look up to but I am a big believer in the three um three perspective
talk and it's like parent to parent child to child adult to parent or something like that
and it's like the three ways you can communicate with someone he said prions oh not prisons my
apology I was talking about the the stanley prison experiment prions uh no a little bit
about prions not not not too much sorry I just read what I wanted to read prudder's william's
syndrome oh prudder willie syndrome that sounds like um I was mixing them up yes prions diseases
are horrifying um did you know about the family of blue people from generations of I know there's
a family that's like on youtube because someone goes and films them and they um communicate via
barks because they have so many issues it's such a shame
I want this woman to yank me for the rest of my life honestly
uh well that speaking of prions um what is it rabid racoon bites you what's that called
as soon as you develop um water phobia water phobia hydrophobia water phobia once you develop
hydrophobia rabies that's it once you develop hydrophobia you have a hundred percent um
loss rate uh you can't win it is it is some scary stuff and and to think that we are very
lucky to avoid this by getting a simple tetanus shot um it turns out in test was not wincent
are you squidding me right now I'm not I'm sorry for the interruption no no barnside note
strani teacher outfit when I mean I'm down like I'm I'm down to clone you want strani teach
you may be your teacher I'll be your I can teach you a few things
I would do them for that maybe I should make an audio about that
hmm I've uh a bit of a I have some leaks so close your ears if you don't want to hear about
the audio leaks uh uh referring to my gen mates um so the new audio uh I don't know master manager
wherever the frick you want to call them um is now in place uh there is like a I told you that
she be has a four part series it's absolutely magnificent I've read it and I love it as there
is four part series is now coming together oh my gosh golly if you like the being pampered
being called a good boy or feeling little oh my you are eating good I don't even have
a wee willy winky sausage I'm appreciating that that's all I'm saying I'm appreciating
what is being put down uh Emmys uh is coming through um I actually need to send off a note
because I accidentally wrote Emmys part one uh to our four part series which is a big mistake
because having too many cooks spoils the broth especially when it comes to bloody scripts I
gonna uh show you that much uh um what uh mercedes is overall like uh you finally accept
being with the yandere and some people don't like that there's resistance I comprehend
but in this one I want there to be resistance and then she breaks you okay that's what I want okay
and what I want go I can't remember what aces is good mirror of aces though
damn strongly are you the tower of babel because you are stacked in defiance of god and I cannot
speak coherently when you go down oh thank you for the tip anonymous oh my god
I tell a babel babel babel why Brian I can't believe you even said that loud honestly um
are they gonna be on patreon they are gonna be on patreon please do uh don't however wait until
the don't if you're like I do not have the money to support these girls do not worry you can do it
for free by liking their streams and hanging out even if you're lurking it's perfectly fine
um and then you might be saying to yourself but if I don't give money I don't get access to certain
content while this is true wait until the don't know thorns I have purposely made the effort
for goals to be public access um now please don't get me wrong there still be rewards for those who
can but I have purposely pushed for public access rewards once goals have been met please let me
try and cook it's very hard to find a good balance who goes there I don't find yourself um
but yes I am I am trying my best to find the perfect thing we've already undercut at the
market severely price point wise on patreon um and we hope that through showing the lack of greed
the lack of greed uh that you know don't worry like even if you can't pay we're we've got you
okay we've got you uh we'll hook you up
okay let me just
let's play some Skyrim
anyone anyone want some room on their sky right here we go I'm in
oh that's bloody loud I don't ever have my head set on right where are we
where where are we the Tower of Babel is the old story about man about a man's hubris and
defiance of god and the reason they allegedly that man speak isn't that Tower of Babel on
or am I getting my bees mixed up my babel in the Tower of Babel Babylon
accessibility no greed and moe miscompany I gotta go on a jogs and enjoy your jog I'd say
listen to the stream but you might be bricked up by the time you're uh it's the Tower of Babel
okay wait is Babylon just a location then
Azura what are you doing in my game Azura what's going on Azura are you going to the high ground
what are you doing what are you going to do once you're up here huh what are you going to do once
you're up here nothing oh you're still going oh my god she's still going Azura where where are you
supposed to go Azura is absolutely lagging I'm not I'm no lying she's absolutely lagging it
oh I heard that that plot
Babylon is the whole horror Babylon thing uh I've been playing too much I
oh my gosh right that's it oh I like that
okay she can beat him up it's fine I like that he's just dodging and then I just do one big
oh that's a steal oh no wait a minute that's against the law I'm a good fantasy role player
I broke her stance you know what else I'll break her hi man okay you're done where is it
where's the enemy oh he's uh oh I never even saw that man I really do need my glasses on that's
terrible legit I thought you were talking about Skyrim's Azura Azura isn't even in the other Skyrim
didn't have Azura maybe Azura's star
the kind of thing which is
wait is this not it
hey wait what how come crazy is this not it
oh my god I've gone way too far ahead of the plot I've gone way too far ahead of the plot
I've not even spoken to the guy to get him to move I was so confused why the trap door wasn't open up
oh Azura gets you to clean out her star right you're done I'm not not you're done
didn't even get to the the first message I read in chat after like a couple of minutes of combat
that's terrible yeah Azura's star is I thought it was on I'm literally speed run the plot I've
gone like 10 leagues ahead I do apologize Babel is where humanity teamed up to build a tower
to heaven and knocked it down and honestly it's quite interesting how
no I can't say that unfortunately um base I'm speed running the plot
uh yeah I've been playing too much Binding of Isaac oh my god wait have I said I'm I'm like
nine-name percent sure I've actually already said this but some of the girls are into tarot cards
they're called um and it's the funniest thing ever and the reason why it's funny is my only
exposure to tarot cards is the Binding of Isaac okay which means whenever they're talking about
pooling cards or whatever they're like the tower card and I'm like yes yes six bombs six bombs you
can probably unlock like a secret um like a tinted rock and get like a soul heart from it yes and
like the lovers yes you can get two hearts if you can find a donation machine maybe you can get some
coins out of it I'm like oh goodness sake like all of them must be rolling their eyes that my only
experience like the friggin the hanged man uh oh yeah um that's fantastic I can uh I can fly in the
room like or the full card oh yeah it takes me back to the starting of the the map oh that's amazing
that's amazing uh hey I'm just gonna skip this part because I don't really need to see it um
can you speak a little bit about your plans for membership no bother you shoot before
but you're honestly worth it oh my god stop you're gonna make me blush um I will most likely do two
memberships uh streams a week um most likely ASMR membership is probably the most requested I also
like doing watch alongs um some stream snap games maybe for more closed things um
well oh if you can speak okay it looks like only bribery works on him um
two I mean yeah I want to make it worth your money like the way I try to think of it in my head
is how much do you pay for like a movie ticket for like one and a half hours entertainment
okay I'ma take that and then double it and then double it again so I'm like okay I'll try to stream
every single day I'll also try to offer membership streams at least twice a week that seems fair
that means in total for the membership not only do you directly support me and future projects
gentle and the projects the girls want to pursue soon but we can't talk about any of it yet um
and it means like also get like a more I suppose like a more intimate stream experience of people
like that um like 17 dollars for a movie ticket that's outrageous um
gen two confirmed live on the stream stocks I remember the first time I did this quest I was
so nervous about like all the guards coming at me but they don't even care hanged man
to we we can go well you do watch together streams for members I absolutely would love to do that
yes we can a hundred percent do that gen two spoiled live no clickbait oh you just wait until
there's don't a thumb for that if you want to see one of the concepts but not all
I don't really talk about it in the server with the girls out of respect because of a
a miscommunication on my part and honestly it's kind of easier it's much easier to go
you know oh shit my bad you're right then to like explain in mass detail like what the most
communication was you know like it is what it is gen two is just she be with a different voice
in a real color mm-hmm I'm actually getting her take this a charcoal skin at some point
I'm probably do it within the next one I brought in the coin and what not at all we're just skipping
through the dialogue that can I be our skin into this look now since our transaction I love
the gen two memes but gen one 3d though mm-hmm the girls are all very interested in 3d the problem is
I don't know I don't have a heart no sure what can I do for you no
you should think about staying the night oh wait I know one of those songs but she
doesn't sing it it's Roderick Roderick there's nothing like a good song to lift the spirit sure
what can I do for you no there once was a hero named ragnar the rest who came riding to white
run from old Roderick then all this ragged and ragged and brandish his blade as he told the
vault stories and gold that he made oh I can't remember the rest I need the rest of it it's in
another in I said another in she doesn't she doesn't go here right we're just gonna if you
want to skip this quest literally just time sink and he will teleport because it's just such a
whatever way you go about it you know the 3d will be lit yeah I don't have a clue like
they baby had like such a gorgeous 3d model but I'm like 9 in percent sure that shitting vr chat
um but I don't know what it is and I'm not sure any of the girls have 3d experience either to
help me out the best I can do is like 3d vr chat but I don't know if that's disappointing for them
um well maybe ask sin sin is vr chat I asked her and I was quite happy with her model like
um and I think that's like what the girls are if they're one 3d like that's all of God you know
um I'll be a learning experience for all vr chat streams being created with you know
could you imagine aces dg sessions in for your chat yeah it's it's not necessarily a lot of work
because I just oh you can't wait in this location damn game forces you east empire company warehouse
I wonder if that was by the British Empire British um
so this level you're supposed to like alert from this guy but
uh yeah I need to offer the girls um what are they called all the trackers but I myself don't
actually know what trackers they need and I don't know what the full price point is like I've
been really open and honest with the girls and been like obviously once everyone's monetized we
can see what kind of money you're earning and if it's good it's bad like because obviously if the
girls money's low they're not going to want to stick around are they um so I do have some kind of like
um mildly boosting efforts but it's not really
yeah you know it's kind of when you're on the managing side it's kind of like I can only
do so much with what the girls give me very thankfully the girls are giving me they're all
like literally everyone streamed every single day which was insane within reason of course
um and like they're taking it a bit more easy this week which I'm very glad to see we do
almost I'm a sneak increase yeah or do you think he notices me at all yeah no
uh there are some really nice uh things you can do in VR chat I have seen something I didn't
what detected me oh oh no he's discovering all the dead bodies along the way but he
doesn't find that suspicious like at all
I don't know if my my poor heart can take stronti in 3d it would be so fun because you can see how
like animated I um I thought about doing a dance 3d stream where like I play music
that you guys suggest and like we just dance and drink and stuff I don't know is that weird
um just a body nothing so so legit oh well it mustn't be anything um I thought that would
be cute like rating your songs and stuff but I don't know how good the tracking is like because I
want I want to see my butt jiggle I won't be twerking and stuff I know the year is transparent
and it's really endearing how come I draw to making sure everyone eats good both the talents and
fun it's right here in my favorite I just uh is he gonna just check to me I mean clearly he just
doesn't care if someone go oh um 3d stronti hypnotizes you that'll be interesting like I just don't
know how 3d works at all I think vain or like sony notes are the default for most tracking I've seen
VR avatars of pendulum and spiral tall everyone just the exception stronti
okay so he does a little uh jabate where he actually comes walking back which is why I'm
hanging back right now because he's a wee liar um but yeah 3d definitely on the cards we're just
obviously we're kind of in the recoup funds stage um and kind of seeing where everyone is of
everyone happy like I sent the girls all a message I was like is there anything I can do to make your
experience better like how do you feel after your first week and I got like a lot of good feedback so
um I'm just gonna be getting ready to get the girls shorts more consistently
because it's taking me a hot second to get shorts out I was hoping to at least get them
like two a week out right now it's like a one-wing oops and that's just because I suck
and I'm gonna fall in the water stronti but don't jiggle jiggle it falls
my money don't jiggle jiggle it falls I like to see you wiggle wiggle for sure
by the way when our membership expected to become available on tomorrow's stream um
I'm gonna get it all set up um and all of that so tomorrow's stream isn't gonna be Skyrim
we're not gonna do full achievements because I don't know why my achievements aren't working
there are enemies all over here but you can just go swinging
you picked a bad time to get lost I think if
this is no there is a health potion stacked over there somewhere I remember correctly
oh I thought there was a health potion here I guess no it's just Wayne close enough
we can sell these potion restraints so there's just spiders in there I don't know if there's
anything else you can just go willy nilly through this it's not really um no magic I hate magic
I don't want to go I can literally hear that spider in that cave it's membership gonna stream
yeah it's tomorrow so the the Skyrim part two is getting steam rolled over to make way for the
monetization stream and then I'm like 100% sure you guys know exactly what I'm doing tomorrow
it's not even gonna be a surprise at this point um but just yeah this is just gonna be a one
off Skyrim because if the achievements were working then yeah but I don't know why they're not so we
might actually do calming a bit earlier than expected she be as live again yes she be cotton boom
any any cotton boom um oh my god oh he's armored up who's next archer oh
I have no idea I'm just stupid to figure out are you wait do you know do you guys wait just
take a guess at what you think my monetization stream tomorrow is take a guess and I'll see if
you guys know I'll tell you if you got it right or not right where's the guy he should be here
oh there is
right yeah feet yeah okay feet stream it's feet ASMR I'm gonna have the camera
on my feet and because I have decks there in my toes I'm literally gonna hold the ASMR
tools with my toes and do like ASMR feet stream that's me yeah feet yeah I like to
it's ridiculous I know yeah I know it's ridiculous but I thought it was funny as anything and
because my model has like french tip toes I thought like yeah it's perfect I don't think my other
toes are gonna heal in time for it though unfortunately it's pretty mangled I don't
I don't think I have to go to the doctor I think I have to go to the doctor if it starts getting
inflamed you needed to know more now tell you what consider me your new friend in the north
I'm keeping the deed any objections consider it again Carlisle didn't even want it why did
card like a purchase golden thing now that I know who she maven if if I was maven okay
blah blah blah blah blah wait I must have spent a lot of time and resources would be
demonetized I mean can you get demonetized it's literally just fee like uh if you kind of take
away the ha ha funny from it it's literally just a body part and ASMR and like me is that dog
what um I heard that
okay gods could you get any more perfect that's the only concept I came up for like my monetization
celebration um people walk on their feet all the time yeah like I just think it's more like funny
ha ha than it is like anything else but like I this time so I don't keep repeating it but I
genuinely like feel so feminine now that I've got like my little manicure pedicure like I felt
so pampered like I was completely uncomfortable with the entire situation but I did feel really
pampered and I was like oh this is actually kind of nice hold on a minute hold on a minute these
gender norms have hands god damn it not again I've fallen for another one it's too difficult
it's too difficult I can't resist I thought I could can you really not jump this oh fine
you are very feminine literally like apparently my hands are super small as well like oh
these gender norms have hands
foot rubs though I will admit the foot rub that felt like heavenly oh my god like my like brain
was like a wire and funny I was like hold on this is like super relaxing I can't believe it all the
freaking stereotypes about whamming like in foot rubs are true it's awful I felt I felt so good
though I was like damn I need a need a reflin right now I need a need a sacrificial a sacrificial
reef one right now oh can I do that at the convention if we do a convention oh my god I'm
literally going through all the Skyrim right now just to get to the other side of the map
is strong he's a girl I can't believe it I'm more impressed with her dexterity how much dexterity
you have for your toes honestly my grippers on a rock you'll never guess what I'm sitting on right
now take a guess what did you need I volunteer literally should I just do that where you're
like massage my feet at the convention oh he said oh wait no I have sweaty feet oh I can't
let yous do that the reason why the women could do it is because I had to put my feet in like this
little water bath so she had no clue that she was dealing with the sweaty feet in the west
so we're now learning that Carlaya is this evil evil trying to take down the thieves guild so we're
gonna meet and mercer free or sorry mercer free and I if you want the correct english are going to
go and confront them um and it's called scoundrels foley oh no I've just completed that I'm actually
such a lawyer oh wait I need I'm freaking sick says exchange a piece of armor but we're about to
get more armor anyway so it's fine don't worry guys I'll take one for the team everyone here
volunteer and to be sacrificial refund my poor refunds what have I done he is honestly uh no
way this is like the closest landmark
it's gonna be a bit of a wonk I feel like I'm still level one why do I refuse to level up
level up
it doesn't matter what you're sitting on we cry because it's not us right there's someone on I
don't know if you guys like you swear too much but there's someone on twitter literally called like
mummy's chair and a freaking hee-haw every time I see them I'm like that name's hilarious like
your guys's names on runescape were hilarious as well um but it's actually so funny
just travel to white rune stable and buy a carry oh you are actually so correct however we might
meet Cicero on the road so there is a chance I have faith let's run that guy literally we
know actually down the screen whoa who are you oh you're a kaji are you mark at the liar
you don't wish me well oh what do you have on your prayer skimmer he's getting high if you
didn't know the kaji have a a really bad habit with skimmer
you found him I knew I recognized I was like is that the liar
of course he's a skimmer literally got nothing on his persons but three skimmer he is set for life
oh my god we flings we have reform
look at that chicken butt chicken butt chicken butt what oh Lydia no way she dances with me
what what chicken butt what what chicken butt
I like how she mimics me chicken chicken chicken chicken chicken oh look it's your egg
oh you have so many eggs oh my god this is exactly what I want is this what older like
chicken head covers just like that's amazing oh my god I would absolutely love to do a stream
about the domestication of animals as well think of how many endless animal species we have
and there's only I think 11 domesticated species isn't that amazing although there was one russian
guy who tried to domesticate foxes and he actually got really far but it does take years and years
you can hypnotize a chicken by drawing the line and dirt in front of them
oh oh oh I was a little moaned to head there please email them thank you
uh there's a little shack down here
domesticated foxes would be adorable they would oh there's a bear in this shack I recognize this
place from many I totally I've never heard a wolf how old like that before but
Lydia can you deal with them so I don't have to slow down I'm trying to make it to the
uh location there is probably bandits here actually that's one thing I do have to complain
about Skyrim there's like bandits in every freaking place ever literally I've not even approached
this landmark and it's like yeah bandits by the way it's like bro I didn't even get a freaking chance
to breathe there's always a bear foxes are difficult the worst part is they pee on everything
fox girl gen two confirmed made it into pee allure confirmed right there's a stable over here so
we're gonna head for it what's the difference between taming and domesticating taming is temp
horary friendship whereas domestication anyone can take over with it I think
because you can tame a wild hedgehog but you can't domesticate it yeah no that kind of sounds like
I'm on the right tracks but I did just I don't actually know the real can you please discover
that thank you just sweet time peeler my beloved peeler confirmed by stroney fox girl for peeler
lmao let the only reason they're in is because of the the content the girls like to put up
domestication is an extremely long process of taming yes I would agree with that statement
well they put fast travel on so they had to compensate for people who'd fast travel instead
of walk and they need more bandits oh bro every time you want to walk like two centimeters the
game's like enemy enemy enemy enemy taming is when you train a wild animal to be friendly around
humans domestications when you breed an animal over multiple generations to benefit a human yes
so a lot of people don't know that sheep um infinitely grow will that's because of human
selective breeding that they produce so much will and they've now required to be shaved
like you ever hear those stories that make the news that's like this sheep evaded the farmer for
five years and he has five years of like mats on him and the only reason that's actually even mildly
possible is because he was bred that way he was bred to produce like copious amounts of wool
and and it's like the same for horses you know how horses need little clippy cloppy horses
the reason for that is because of selective breeding and and the horse in the wild will
naturally wear down its rocks its hooves on rocks and stuff like that and what is going on here who's
our key um
like yeah silkworms we use for silk can't survive in the wild yeah i would really love to do a
domestication thing um i'd love to do a history one i just saw that on a perforx that wolf garden
huh i don't think i've ever seen a sheep on the news yeah when you come from scotland sometimes
the news is rather bland um you know not a lot going on in scotland if you watch the scottish news
oh no he didn't mate why why does the horse who's horse is that hello i'm sorry i'm late
good we're finally hydration check i've scouted the ruins and i'm certain carliah is still inside
you saw her no i found her horse
don't take care of it that horse didn't need to perish let's get moving i want to catch her
inside while she's distracted take the lead you want me to lead understood just make certain
you keep your eyes open carliah is selectively breeding wiflings to four you can't say that
that's hilarious you can't say that oh my god that's so true what the fuck that's so funny i'm
sorry i can't even laugh at that that's so funny um i'd rather the news be bland than hyperpolarizing
oh i don't even consume the news anymore where where are you bro i can hear your armor what are you
okay there you are jeez is everyone because she's growing so much will have actually become a
deficient sheep farmers don't make any money from willson synthetic fibers if a police will
we have to go back we need to go back please please no more plastic i'd like same i hate watching
yeah like it's just unwatchable it just you you'll finish a news broadcast um and you're just like
wow i hate life and it was like don't if if you consume things that like genuinely make you
more upset at the end of them it's it can be quite addictive and comforting to like watch it in the
moment but when you realize it's bad for you like you can just kind of posthump on it you know come
back another time uh there are droggers up ahead but it's not anything we can't
uh the droggers i'm actually gonna loot them the reason because a lot of droggers drop um
um soul gems which i'm needing a heck of a lot more of
i said they drop soul gems
soul gems se oh ah oh gems i can see that but i don't mean whoa okay sorry i'm sorry please
forgive me for pill in the lever i didn't mean i promise i won't do it again we all
okay they're just dropping gems i couldn't freaking
uh i didn't even get a chance to wiggle it
no no
oh
oh potions lovely i'll sell them for pennies honestly will is still warm even oh wait sorry
sorry i was looking at the corner of my eye oh ah
i can so ends the lesson uh doggers don't usually have soul gems wait who do i think
have soul gems on them oh the the centaurians have um the the good golden guys no
i'm like going left side i'm like okay there we go so many soul gems okay they just have gold
on them apparently we
get it your feeble attempts he's like so
nope don't ask me how long it took me to find the opening to this so my first playthrough
it's so painful this was my first ever um skyrim game actually my dad played morrow and um
but my my favorite thing about morrowind is that you can just jump on the spot um
and then like you level up your stamina it's quite interesting
oh i can do this you mean elder school's game yeah wait what did i say my first skyrim game
sad oh my dumb dumb
and he i was gonna say it's even oh no not me right now ryan hey stroney i wanted to ask you
something yeah i know you can speak scott but i was curious to know if you knew gaelic as well
cause if i remember correctly there's not that many people left in scotland that can speak it
no they don't teach us that uh if you come from the mainland you don't learn gaelic at all
um it's basically a dying language because they refuse to teach it to the next generation
i don't know if it's gonna change i hope it'll change in the future but sadly no i do not speak
gaelic which is just how it is they do not teach it and oh pretty shit
um but thank you for the tip narrow yes uh very sadly the they don't teach it uh if you're from
the mainland of scotland and i am from the mainland of scotland if you didn't know lovely little uh
scot wait no did i mean to do that i don't think i meant to do that did i um if i didn't come from
the mainland and i came from the shetland for example which is at the north some it's okay
if you don't really know scotland that well um where the heck is this red on the map that i get
am i going the right way
yel skeever okay i'm going the right way i don't know how to do that
that's so sad gaelic is one of the very few Celtic languages out left yeah like um
uh something's here scotland and ireland and all that were like pagan
fucking hell this is a lot of enemies got enemies got a lot of enemies i'm just swanging
i'm just swinging around my new ones business honestly me if i was a guy i'd be elephant and
that stuff up
i'm 42 i'm leveling up faster than my fishing and runescape
although you still need a trans a translator for glass region yes the scots is the
he just like went flying uh you really wanted that um
there's poison darts if i remember correctly yeah i'm just too good i just remember everything
honestly um yes i am very lucky that i do have scots at least which is recognized as its own
language which is really cool and i know it sounds like i'm like speaking that's because
i don't use slang at all like at all um oh we're almost there uh we're almost there
um
uh i'm completely forgotten what was happening about i hate these guys because they can yeah
they can disarm you which i don't like wait he he has special
eh i've never seen this before this is not freaking xbox certified flawed barla stone
what the heck is that why why did why did pc yell these cool things what the heck is a wireless stone
can you do a fool on scottish dream uh i mean if you mean slang i can only really do it for
like a couple of minutes because it's just like i get more mumbly and like oh good morning good
evening good afternoon and all that who's it going like it just doesn't really sound that good and
i don't think it's that relaxing either like and i kind of hate to put it on because my mom was like
no then he speaks slang in the house so i didn't and then obviously being an online creator
it's the complete opposite everyone wants to hear you with a slang in every hand and it's like oh
right then i guess it's a bit uh it's a bit forced because i was discouraged from speaking
words these doors have a weakness pc got updates xbox charges per update plus pc got lots of content
xbox charges per update i don't know
it's just a bit pointless learning gaelic when english is so common yeah like oh
i ain't looking good i ain't looking good i'm gonna take a nap right here
can you talk dirty scott's if you want
and a member stream sure yeah i remember liby saying some scott's can't pronounce for yeah
so if i say how i normally annunciate purple burglar alarm like i can't do it but if i put on
a harsh accent my tongue gets caught at the back of my mouth like a purple burglar alarm
like a lalalala and you can hear that yuki's temper is gone forever
it was the first lesson gallas taught us hey sweet ania
gallas had his wealth and he had you all he had to do was look the other way
garner did you expect him to simply ignore your methods and all the most recent versions of the
game my ps4 even got these updates you know it's time for you and gallas to become reunited
okay lol it's okay you're still very dumb but snap it will make me blue
i was going to make you say purple burglar after my first
super chat i said that before she was like how long until someone asked for purple burglar alarm
because it's quite common to be asked to say it and like i hope i don't sound moody like when
i do it because i'm like for people who watch long term they'll know like how often i get asked it
but for people who like pop in for the first time i don't want to be rude and be like uh like i've
already said it like five times today like i get the max it's different like i don't want to be rude
like that uh you know what fuck off since this day
hi sin honestly he's since his regard yeah we need i need screwed back on the tax
spitting on the beat oh right no let's not finish that one um you need to do a song cover with me
like a scottish one what's that i'm just like forcing you to collab with me jeez actually i need to
do an ASMR collab with you as well if i'm all out um easy how are you feeling uh uh hold on you shot
me carlaya no i saved your life my arrow was tipped with a unique if you're gonna be rude at
least over your best accent had i intended to kill we wouldn't be having this conversation why save me
my original intention was to use that arrow on mercer but i never had a clear shot i made a split
oh hi lydia two girls give you a
fucking street oh my god that's awful
then i'm in your d that's all no i meant i meant like a youtube like wholesome
but if you want to do one like that i ain't stopping you i am to to tourist attraction girls show you
how good scottland can really be
that's ridiculous you can't say that
perhaps it could be translated
thank you hard answers speak with right we need to go talk to
a winterhold
hi hen let me stick your laps to your dirty weekend
it's so cursed scottishry smart it's so cursed it's terrible i did a i did a plot recently
sin and it was like uh picks on you at a party and it was like oh what you doing on your own
oh no your girlfriend's gonna be mad oh you've no got a girlfriend right come with me come with
me come into this room oh i like that there's no locks on this door oh yeah oh we might get caught
oh and it's just awful you make it sound like we don't like it i think it just makes me grimace
call me a shake because it makes me grimace do the Harlem shake
whoop whoop whoop whoop whoop whoop whoop and folk wonder why folk go default america produce
what a folk actually what that show oh i'm getting absolutely right today hold on i completely
missed that swing but oh that i don't want the slow mo like come on that wolf's just hunting
i've not been funny we have successfully eradicated oh what's this oh what's going on here
no more stops we need to find our way to solid you what was this
i told you it's the wedding of vittoria vici an extremely well oh that's related to the dark
brotherhood so cicero could have been there but cicero wasn't i'm just gonna discover this
mating complex just because whistling man oh mercy can't whistle by the way
literally scot is the most important point you see awful ass is absolutely amazing yeah apparently
mercy can't whistle only discovered that yesterday i'm like uh what do you mean you can't whistle
i was like oh my god her mouth is so small that it will unironically though
she can't whistle and then she went we love your accent we found out recently too
she tried it with you i might just to just to ramp up the maximum embarrassment i might clip it
and make it short on her channel and be like a adorable vtuber tries to whistle or something like
and it's just her just going i can't whistle lung problems suck god damn you got cystic
fibrosis need pop you on the wee wiggle machine would i call it the the lung wiggle machine
i didn't learn to whistle until 16 it took me so long to get it like my grandad can do that thing
where you put like two fingers at the corner of your mouth and then go hewie i can't do that but
it's ear piercingly low like ear piercingly low that'd be great mercy's adorable for you
i'm sorry could you describe the smell can i help you with anything else
carlaya do you have gals with journal yes but there's a problem no this is do a video
they're trying to win one thing that each member can't do whistles for mercy no uh means like
maybe means like don't stream for the day that'll be my challenge don't don't accidentally do an
endurance guardian of his research right speak to who i'm just getting bounced around this map you know
what would you like me to serve to smell or will i get you a box
wait that's a lord of the rings reference wait a minute i recognize that lord of the rings
reference anywhere because no one says get me a box oh something all the way why why are you
putting me places i haven't discovered before
time to decor diho oh i didn't mean that for those who want to recover magical faster but
are more susceptible to damage well that's a absolute rubbish payoff
nash droney will say something that involves rolling arse oh what's wrong reefling do you
not like the way i say my arse after almost five hours of hearing you stream at two times i'm
finally caught up hi you can listen to me normally i promise i'm not a squeaker i'm sorry you thought
i was a squeaker why is there spitters come here no come here i just want to talk i want to shake
your hand i want to shake your hand what was that about
the apprentice don't suck no stream for one day we'll get separation i say
bro i've been waking up with the worst anxiety ever and i'm but it goes away the moment i stream
and i'm like shit i literally there's a hag in this hot i am like 99 percent sure that i remember
a hag being in this hot hold on am i going crazy is this not got a big beast in it oh no it's a
person oh oh he didn't make it hold on oh well there you go speak to cruise to it for i thought
this was the heart hi mommy i'm back from my jog yay you didn't get a bone bone more jogging
so congrats on your work remember to replenish your electrolytes by adding
salt extra salt into your diet the mutual separation anxiety is bad i mean it's like
good and bad like but when i wake up it's like like that kind of things i but like as soon as
like start like setting up my pc i make like a cup of honey
oh my god you're so adorable mud crab for gen two confirmed oh you're so cute i love you
i'm not even gonna hurt you he's just a little aggressive okay he's just a wee bit aggressive
the hack out you're thinking of is outside riverwood oh this looks like a dragon's grave
if i've ever seen one oh no maybe not i don't know he'll get crab girl sees a creature gen two
confirmed i'm just teasing you guys with that by the way oh no merchant's journal okay hold on
what happened here i begged my husband not to go but he just wouldn't listen he said if
he delayed the shipment even another week the legion would find someone else to take it south
let them keep their blasted money the road to white run is dangerous he says everyone knows
that so many caravans have been attacked so many travelers vanished into thin air some say it's
only bandits but they're rumors are worse goblins ghosts and witches 20 years we've been married
now and i can't bear the thought of losing them i'm not letting them go alone not this time we'll
never die together together mara preservas oh where's the man oh no
oh who to who to uh it's terrible picks up coins oh who did that that's terrible
uh coconut crab vtuber oh isn't that not that massive gigantic crab
v suckies gen two's name by the way yeah gen two already i already have the logos for gen two and
three made um because they were they it was like cheap and it was like i might as well lost them
out because i already know what i'm gonna call them i'm just gonna discover this location i don't
know if we're gonna start going against the force one shortly there are another type of bandits
essentially uh right how do i get around i guess i get around oh no robbs corpses look
they're not gonna need it let's be honest they're not gonna need that those nine coins
gen three spoiled no there's absolutely nothing planned of gen three i don't even know what concepts
i want and stroney did you see what you want yes what i want i submit what i want and then i
get back something and then i keep going to the drawing board that's how it works
so you're at my mercy shoulda picked mercy you can't purchase in the afterlife gen six
absolutely no i am done birthing any children after gen three i mean it's also like uh there's a
whole other thing to it there's actually a whole other trust factor as well like gen one i completely
trust wholeheartedly um like i did my thorough research on the girls and like when i when i
did the interview like i never got any bad vibes or whatever um which sounds terrible like oh you
did an interview like an informal interview and went off of was there bad vibes or not and the
answer is yeah i did actually um because and when you hear people talk you can get a sense of like
especially when they expect it like a super um like a super professional thing and you're just
like oh surprise it's actually just me me man uh here's here's the rules type thing um mercy's
patreon just went live oh she got an update i can't even remember what her update was
i i don't know i don't know what the tags are even though i was the one who put that up there for
her sounds like you got a trust you got yeah like i i get described as naive a lot which i
honestly don't mind i actually genuinely agree with that and kind of assessment sorry i'm just
trying to hit loads of markers along the way so we can just backtrack like this super easily
um oh is this like a little hunter's lodge thing going on oh it's like a little campsite oh
anyway we eating good tonight after three generations there's a real a real risk of bad
actors trying to get in that software yeah so because um i need to choose my words carefully
but i hope you can agree with um my my my thought process but it may not be reality because it's
just my thought process um it is very plausible that there were vtubers who were interested but
didn't apply because they wanted the guaranteed success of gen 2 like to see what gen 1 achieved
to see what gen 2 achieved because not that they didn't put their faith in the plan
it's not so obviously you want to you want to be a part something that's successful let's
wait am i on the right way or am i on the wrong way no i'm gonna write um i need to try and think
of my sense just like i'm really happy with gen 1 and everyone is good basically however the rate
as you said the rate of a bad actor coming into play does get higher um
but hopefully you know there's girls like with you know plenty of experience and i can just
see and assess them you don't want to risk the gamble yes it's like i don't know how to say that
i just knew all the girls i'm trying to have a really nice moment talking about my girls okay um
the risk does get higher when new people are introduced that may not have previous history
like um what the heck what am i trying to do where the heck am i trying to go
you can't see me um
i think you're doing the right thing you don't want to feel like you're even
messed up in the wrong thing yes that like um i did speak of someone who applied and then i went
on their twitch just to check them out in general and they spoke about how they only want to hang
around for one year and then send their audience to their old account and the quote was like because
the creator seems so chill or something and i got an in route um and it was just like kind of shocking
and it does like kind of slap me back to reality that like people who apply they might not actually
want to hang around and achieve like loads of goals they might just do it to go do their own thing
the lover stone this always feels the comforts of love all skills improve faster
if all skills improve faster then sure call me the lover stone
uh who would put that on social me out what wow you know that really happened um
they uh applied their application and i pretty much checked out everyone's stream
um uh after they applied just to see what they were putting out there because um there was a
very notable trend of people applying and then all of a sudden their stream uh consistency ramped up
because they were getting assessed and they were aware they were getting assessed uh i don't think
i didn't notice that if you were one of those girls um uh there was also stream variety came
out of nowhere some people were very glued to one type of game um and all of a sudden uh they
start doing a variety of games uh kind of showing that they can play a different um but yes um i did
get to experience someone who openly admitted that they basically applied but couldn't care less
about the actual longevity of violour and it is quite scary to think that there's a possibility
that even through my vetting process um there is a team who also assessed uh the girls that get in
as well um and maybe at a later date i can maybe speak a bit more about i think now is a bit too
sensitive of a time because obviously it's only been uh one week excuse me sorry just dealing with
this guy he is a very bad man do not trust him are you good that man nearly killed me
you saved my life oh thank you here well what do we get i think we get a gold band from or something
uh why were they after you know i don't have any idea does that affect your judgment what
does what affect my judgment i'm so sorry you're gonna have to go over that again
sorry i completely forget uh what my like previous sense was azure's voice was too
perfect for the character yes i i did admit that if azura did not accept uh i was essentially
up shit creek because everyone who applied i was not satisfied with their fit for the voice i did
say though i said it before anyone's like uh that's not fair they were born that way they just
got in uh what about rooting for the underdog okay you know fuck off um this agency isn't for
fucking like sorry i do get a bit passionate like you never fucking cheered for the underdog
in your life like shot it's you and zeal you idiot i i'm sorry i just choked on my bullet
i'm getting a bit too i'm in the middle of some very stupid work sorry that really hurt
oh how can i help you sorry oh persistent aren't you oh very well oh am i to stand in the way
by gen three strony strony's gonna need to recruit refland spies to be in the applications
inner circle honestly i love seeing you get passionate about it all oh it's it's honestly
fascinating stuff to be behind the scenes um i absolutely wait what
am i
okay well what i have been the artifact i've discovered in the shoe and zeal
sorry i'm just freaking mad to think i while being an admirer i'm sure you can i'm not certain
how many scholars you're accustomed to dealing very well
uh whatever um uh he did give us a key so i think we can just go for it come v-trippers
reincarnate into another model jimmy for those who apply we the dwidmer museum isn't open to anyone
because cal you have a problem with that go talk to him i have a problem with it
i don't have freaking out okay hold on a little to the left oh oh oh uh
uh
now everyone knows i suck at lot girl hold on
you stop shaking at me
yeah that's what i thought don't talk to me don't talk to me bro
all right uh
i don't think we can sneak through here i think they attack me
uh i'd rather die than go to prison
fucking hell this is a bit dramatic but i think we're doing it
oh i missed i missed i missed sorry i'm sorry sorry about that old chap oh i missed again right
see this freaking straight when you do the stamina effect
lidia go and stab him in the back like he's actually right there lidia yeah i know you're
on my side but you're in the faking way and i'm literally getting battered about the head
right that's it lidia lidia lidia we're having a level up that's a freaking annoying you are
it'll do some stamina but i just do health issues um right give me two handed
what's this champion stance power attacks to less attacks to a battleaxe great sword warhammer
yeah let's just do that and then what are these i've got three more perks
light armor sure why not shoving the pants that'll do it
can't add a bounty to the reach if they're all dead and no one knows what the bounty is about
oh
oh lidia's on the ground
my bounty's getting big oh parish only guilty if you get caught
what is that noise ew what is that noise
all right this is the way to victory let's go should put some points into restoration
don't not have access
easy easy
easy
upper wee bit easy easy
how about some rubbish i used to be so good on like this
upper bit
oh
uh right what's the deal we against oh we need soul gems oh we love soul gems
oh wait hold on hold on the analog stick analog stick please work with me here
uh control rod no i can't really divorce with him
uh we're gonna be looting it the ever living daylights of my what oh god i've forgotten this
no no one's here go home wizards guard oh shoot i one shot them
um
you have a healing spell by default that's right oh i got a key finally good tell me
why i have to grab the key does everyone have a key okay that's okay uh let's get
bored into the dwelmer rooms no not in here at all please forgive oh my god i'm one shot in
them now that i've actually upgraded my thing oh it's loud in these parts my headset is very loud
i need to turn down the master volume
let's get down to business to defeat the wizards guards when they shoot their arrows you are
what the heck i'm definitely not supposed to go in that this this green
i pick up everything and never know when to stop is this
wait am i going crazy that's gonna poison me yeah yeah i knew it
matt was i even supposed to go that way no i just took poison damage for the hell
a bit i was so fun i should do that again not wait did i not come from here
what am i who or have i gone the completely wrong way
i think i'm i might have
i think i went completely wrong way pardon me
it's barred from another site so i was going the right freaking way
ah right okay let's try again
i'm sure i can figure it out when i get there i feel like a some secret offer is it no these are
living quarters you're the stealthiest thief ever strong and no one will see you if they're dead
exactly i don't know why that's still going because i pulled a lever uh i think i did it on the other
side of the poison uh i guess if you wanted to be stealth you could just go through the poison
but we'll just go for it
we're going we're going we're going
i'm being a dome dome okay turn the off
right there so it's quiet and then up the stairs literally they were right there
and i walked away from them it's just feeling quirky okay just feeling misunderstood
mmm
just let it happen just let it happen just let it happen just let it happen it's okay
just let it happen
just let it happen it's okay it's okay just let it happen
Mm, big potatoes.
Just, oh, 20, 20, go, enchanting.
That's good, that'll be like enchanting up in here.
Just let it out.
Okay, we don't really need to, oh, the box, we need that.
Mm, is this the barred door?
It was!
Okay, we've now got the shortcut.
So what's this?
It's a chest.
And then what's that?
That's just the other side of the map.
Oh my god, we did it.
It's not war crime if it's a cute girl.
Me committing war crimes?
Stop, you're making me laugh.
Oh my gosh, I'm so turned around.
It's been so long since I've done this.
It's called barbarian stealth, honestly?
I actually really like that description for my thingy.
Like, I've always tried to do...
What the heck?
Jump shot.
Oh, right, wait, what?
There's a tic-tac to leave there.
I don't think there's any enemies until they come in.
We just need to pick up some charcoal and a piece of paper,
steal the paper, steal the charcoal.
It took me so long to figure out this area.
Heavy armor increased to 16.
Well, it wasn't really worth the level up.
But hey, we did it.
I'm gonna break some...
Break it down now.
Oh, look at that.
Look at that.
We do have a bow and arrow.
Fire damage?
Soul trap?
Maybe...
No, maybe not a soul trap on us.
I would say fire damage.
Take a little burn.
Now, what?
Petty or...
Bubbish.
You know, Seagrog.
Method of stealth, honestly.
Look, if it works, is there...
Is there truly a point?
Right, so the enemies do come in here.
Obviously, because we are playing on legendary mode
and I'm just so MLG pro.
Yeah, excuse me.
We're just gonna one-shot them, confidently.
We are just going to one-shot them, confidently.
We are just gonna one-shot them.
Nice and confidently.
No problems.
CUTELY commits crimes against humanity, honestly.
Have you played Ghost of Toshima?
I haven't.
One-shot, 100%.
Return to the guy.
Where's the guy?
Is he in here?
Oh, return to the guy, guy.
Return to the guy.
Walk on fire.
Why the heck does it make me go backwards?
I'm just...
The map in is a bit rough.
Can I loot this?
I can't.
They're so good.
Wait, are the guards gonna attack me?
Are the marker of guards gonna attack me?
I think they might.
I come back and see you're still in...
Eh, no.
I'm sorry, but these accusations are unfounded.
I'm not a novice.
I'm on legendary, clearly.
Look, I'm sorry to your untrained eye,
but when you get really good at the game,
it just makes things...
Why did it do that?
Why did you do that?
Why does the game do that?
Honestly, I could fart on it something.
Yeah, just because I'm such a high-skilled level,
it makes it appear to be a very easy level.
So please don't worry about it.
No, okay.
I've played this game for two...
How dare you?
Why is the child in the basement?
Alright, here's the translation, bro.
I'm rubbing.
When you're amazing, you make everything look easy.
Yeah, legendary.
See how that's not valued at 50?
It's not going to teach you nothing.
Don't open that book.
Maybe sometime you should judge a book by cover.
Mercer Frey is the baddie.
Dun-dun-dun!
He's trying to once you rub him.
That's actually my specialty.
The Nightingales!
It seems to describe the failure of the Nightingales,
although it doesn't go into great detail.
Gallus also repeatedly mentions
his strong belief that Mercer desecrated
something known as the Twilight Sepulcher.
She bawled under that hood.
Baw headed in.
The annoying hint is actually the bad guy.
I'm shocked, colouring me surprised.
Golden writing standards by the dev team.
Bald!
It always annoyed me when you put on a hood,
your hair gets removed
and annoys me so much.
It's just such a...
Excuse you, anyone talking to you?
Listen, all I want is the truth to be revealed to the guild.
They respected Carlaya and she deserves better.
Do whatever you can and I'd consider it a personal favour.
Sure, thank you.
If you ever manage to gain entry to the college
and you find trying to rid yourself of stolen goods...
He's a fan!
I've been known to handle items of questionable interest
from time to time.
Questionable interest, I like that.
We must hasten to rift in before Mercer can do any more...
We must hasten to rift in!
Bald gent who member confirmed...
No! No!
Say it ain't so.
I will not go.
Turn the lights off.
Carry me home.
Oh my god, members carry okay.
I can absolutely wreck my voice on that.
I can get beer.
I can get beer!
And we can do membership karaoke.
And I can do song requests.
You guys put it together.
I'll be pretty good.
I'll drink till you spew.
Carla currently and kindly explaining the Nightingale lore
and her relationship to Gallus
whilst I sing that one beer parody song
that had that Lego animation.
Why are you in the basement child?
I'm getting weirded out.
Leave me alone!
Get away!
Creepy wee thing, honestly.
And you sing Flare of Scotland?
No, I have to be hate music.
I'm not singing, I'm getting drunk and going
Oh, Flare of Scotland
When will we see our life again?
I don't know why national songs insist on going so high.
Can't you just give me one song
where the decibels, the notes in it
are just really common
and everyone can sing it.
Donald, where are your choosers?
What's that song?
I think I've ever heard of it.
I missed beer whilst I was grabbing a drink.
No, no, no, we're going to do drunk membership thingy.
Back to where I am.
I'll take my poops in.
I'm ready, let's go.
I was going to force us to sing Christmas carols on Christmas.
I like a wee and a manger.
A wee and a manger.
No crib for a pit.
Why does it go so high pitch?
Why can't they not just have a song
down here?
No crib for a bed.
The little Lord Jesus laid down his sweet head.
The cattle are lowing.
I was going to force you guys to do
freaking Christmas songs with me
and then we watch Lord of the Rings on Christmas.
Where the winds blow high,
where the winds blow to the streets
and my cattle go.
Although as you say hello Donald,
what the freak, I've never heard that.
Do you have titsangles?
Do they wobble to the floor?
I can't say that, I'm sorry.
I'm getting a bit delirious, hold on a minute.
You've never heard that song before.
Do they go to and fro?
She's not even drunk yet.
Just talking about alcohol is getting me steaming.
It's making me lose the plot.
No, it can't be.
What's that mean?
He quoted the main.
The floor?
Yeah, it's a bit dirty, we're currently in the sewers.
Do they wobble to the floor?
Can you tie them in the knot?
Can you tie them in a bow?
My kami oshi hates Mongolian throat singing.
It's because cats don't like the sound of the vibration
that Mongolian throat singing provides.
So thus I don't like it, I don't like vibrations.
That rrrrrrr.
No, bad.
Cats don't like it, it makes their ears go back.
So it makes my ears go back.
World's greatest thieves live in a sewer.
Down in the sewer.
Ever listen to the nasty shrank, please?
Let's go.
The memer is starting to break free.
I want to break free.
My cat likes it.
Your cat does not like Mongolian throat singing
and I will not be taking any further statements.
I assure you, your cat does not like Mongolian throat singing.
Beast cat, absolutely not.
Are you sure about that?
Rip project women OST fans and shambles due to the Mongolian throat singing.
I was so hard to sing that.
Any song is hard to sing, my voice is so frazzled.
Can I meet my life away?
Sorry, the thieves gold are now just revealing
that Mercer has betrayed them for many years
and there's not a penny left for them.
Meet my life away.
Why is Caravans a frog in the stream?
Caravans a frog here.
I would like to do some karaoke.
Sing your cover live.
He also like rock music.
We doubt you don't like vibrations.
I've got an even funner fact.
I only like it.
Before I help you track Mercer now,
I need to know what you learned from Carlya.
Mercer killed Gallus, not Carlya.
Gallus, Carlya and Mercer were nightingales.
Was there anything else she told you?
I was behind Golden Glow and Honeybrew.
Was there anything else?
Say it.
I need you to break into my...
The magic button cannot handle the vibration.
Be careful, just find a way in.
But the dark road home can.
You have permission to kill anyone that stands in your way.
Oh, I have permission.
Okay, infiltrate Mercer's home.
Oh, everyone's on alert.
Alert, alert, Mercer.
Alert, alert.
All are welcome at the Temple of Mora.
Ah, there we are, but you shouldn't be here.
I don't doubt for one second.
I won't remember that.
Please continue.
Information stored and saved.
Yee...
Literally...
There's no doubt about it.
The tales gilded back.
I didn't realize how...
Fake speedish that all the voice actors' accents try to mimic.
It's actually quite jarring.
Be careful.
What are you talking about?
Hello?
This is Mercer Frey's place and he don't like visitors.
Now go away.
I need to get inside Mercer's house, please.
No visitors, no way.
Now piss off before you make me mad.
I'll make it worth your while.
You ain't got enough coin to make my problems go away.
Unless you can talk to Maven Blackbriar and to let me out of my debt.
Okay.
You try and set one foot in this yard and I'll cut it off.
Fine.
I'll go talk to Maven about big...
Big...
Big stinky...
What's your name?
Bald?
More like...
Cold.
Because it's freezing outside and you're not wearing any outfit.
Oh!
Absolutely rolled and decked.
Hello?
America, hiya.
No, no, no.
American?
When's Azura's birthday?
I believe it's the 23rd of August if I'm not mistaken.
Is she not up?
Where is she?
He less of a shite.
Where's Maria?
Big Maria.
Okay, hold on.
If I put that on, it should show me where she is.
Oh, she is here.
You were there all along.
Sam, if you don't want any of it, I'll take a bell for you.
What did he do?
Do you think Mercer...
Is a cl-
What?
He's in debt because of a quill?
Is this his quill that's in the freaking lake?
I believe it.
Oh, no.
I think it might just be easier to perish this man.
I think it's in a boat.
Oh, goodness me, it's been many a year.
I'm gonna have to look at it on the HUD.
Hold on.
I want to say it's like somewhere here to the left.
Oh, I could be terribly wrong though, but there should be a boat.
It started.
It's at the bottom of the lake somewhere.
Thank you for your help.
I really appreciate that.
I am somewhere at the bottom of the lake.
I don't even have water breathing either.
I can't believe you.
You had the audacity to take that out.
You're just trying to upset me.
What's this?
What's that barnacles?
Wait, wait, wait.
Is this a hint?
Hold on, let me breathe.
Is this a hint that maybe you're around here somewhere?
Hold on.
Right, should we?
Oh, no.
Right, well, there was a box, but I guess not.
There's rocks here.
Is that telling me it's here somewhere?
But the barnacles, there's more barnacles.
Oh, can you say render distance, please?
Stronius, under the water.
You don't want reflins.
Ah, let me breathe.
I seem to think it's like the left side.
I saw that storage box.
I think that's the game being like hint.
It's over here.
Okay, hold on.
Let me just check again.
I think it's in a broken boat.
Um, it's on the map somewhere.
Right, I'm not reading chat for the next minute.
You're on time out.
You're done.
I seem to think it's close to the edge of the water.
Wait, this is a bit too close, clearly.
By the bridge?
I don't recall it being by a bridge, to be honest.
You know what, reflin?
What?
A strong name.
What do you think of the Indiana Jones game?
I didn't know there was a new one.
Oh, for goodness' sake.
I think I'm off the mark.
Where am I?
Maybe it's like down here a bit.
This is the entire area.
Okay, I'm just going to do one big loop around the island.
Why is there so many salmon?
Shoney, I love you.
Don't hate my friends.
Wait, why would I hate your friends?
I thought you weren't looking at us.
Look, I forgive really easily.
Oh, no, get up!
Shabee, what are you doing?
Underwater burning.
Okay, I don't...
think it's up this way.
But we're going to just do a big circle
for the sake of satisfying myself.
Come up for water often.
Reflins, remember that Shoney's much of an...
as much of an addict as we are.
Scuba, Shabee.
Shabee, making me nervous.
Oh, wait.
Maybe I'm on one of these islands.
I may be rocked up on a baby island.
Do you know that?
What the heck was that?
I'm rabbit.
Hold on.
Let's just check the hut again.
We're kind of at the furthest point
of this section of the lake.
I'm not really wanting to go too much further.
It's near the box you found before.
Oh, my God, I'm actually getting my hand held.
See, thank you, refling.
I actually get my hand held.
And you're just freaking back there.
I've gone way off course.
Oh, my God, forgive me.
Fucking nonchalant.
It's between the big island and Riften.
That's it.
I'm giving in.
Skyrimmer's been installed.
Are you happy now?
Oh, have I put you in the Skyrim mid?
Yippee!
I can't help the sarcasm.
I forget where the thing is every time.
In waste half an hour looking also.
It's underwater, not on an island.
Yeah, it's like crashed off of it.
My eyes are currently burning,
opening under the salt water.
Right.
That's not it.
These are just textures.
It's not like this.
I can't even swim in.
So there's no point.
I'm gonna go buy that box again.
If I could find the box again.
We'll float to the right this time,
not to be confused with the hit TV game.
A little to the left.
I don't know why I said TV game.
Steam game.
So those are the barnacles.
I'm getting swept up.
We're trying to find the quill.
That maven.
I did not realise how rubbish this game is.
Is this for real?
There's like two floating foxes under the cave.
What's going on here?
I can see loads of broken stuff.
Hold on, let me breathe again.
Right.
Definitely not searchable.
There's loads of boxes just hanging off the dock.
It just works.
I think you may have floated over it.
It's not by the docks.
I like the detail though,
the concept that it fell off the boat
and they can't retrieve it.
That's quite smart.
This is where I'm on the map.
I'm like messing around here.
Isn't this rock formation maybe?
What the barnacles?
Hold on, let me breathe.
I'm like right, I'm like freaking, I'm here.
I doubt it got dropped here.
It just seems so unlikely.
Go straight from the docks towards the island.
Okay.
Hmm.
I'm searching, I'm searching.
There's salmon, there's salmon,
there's bulks, there's bulks,
but it's more towards here.
Don't need to breathe, hold on.
Okay.
Okay, this is new.
I don't think I've investigated this.
Maybe we have.
They have a freaking potion of water breathing
that would make this a lot either.
Water breathing where?
Water breathing.
Oh, a whole 15 seconds.
Oh, you're too kind, you're too kind.
Oh!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, fucking.
Oh, oh, oh, I'm getting current.
I'm getting drafted away by the current.
Okay, fuck that.
Alright, I was doing the new one.
Stop, current, stop, I can't breathe.
Oh.
Ah!
I've only got 10 lock picks.
Going to be easy on me.
I'm going to need to bow some more.
No!
Less?
I'm like...
Is that less or is that more?
Oh.
Give me that.
Stupid bastard.
Bastard, you're a quill.
Right.
We did it.
Oh my god, that took well.
Just get Vol-song and forget about that.
What's Vol-song?
She's got it.
If she can open the box, literally.
What's inside the box?
That's a freaking quill.
You did it.
You're the first person in history to buy lock picks.
They're so common.
I know, I keep forgetting to feel like glue.
Hi, do you want a quill?
I presume you're bothering me for a good reason.
I've found the quill.
Really?
I wrote that off a long time ago.
Well, I suppose I need to fulfill my end of the bargain.
Yes.
Give this document to Vol.
It frees him from the debt.
But I never want to see him in Rifton again.
Oh, okay.
Oh, that's Exile.
That's not very nice.
He's made his pals here.
Do you want to reconsider Exile on someone?
That's not very nice.
Have you heard of that?
Have you heard how damaging that can be to someone's social life?
Makes him feel like they're not a part of the community.
You have to, you know, uproot and go elsewhere.
Not nice.
He's trying to suck it at Skyrim.
I know.
You, come here.
I can't talk to him yet or he'll be aggressive.
Like, you.
Here, over here.
What?
Or Big Vault.
Sorry, Big Vault.
Oh, oh, he's going to that gate.
Hold on.
If we're fast enough, if we're fast enough, we can go.
We can go talk to him on the other side of that gate.
Vault.
Vault, hold on.
Vault, it's me.
It's me.
No, no, no.
He's come back to the original position.
No, Vault, no.
Wait, Vault, wait.
Let me talk to you.
I just want to talk to you.
Vault.
Oh.
I have something for you.
Here, it's your debt with Maven.
You're free.
What are you doing?
How's he added?
Are you just coming out now?
Oh, he is.
Oh.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you very much.
Can I just come in this way?
Oh, it's barred.
Wait.
I need a bow and arrow.
Or can I just hit this?
Okay.
No, you need a bow and arrow.
I was being a bit...
Let me just...
Tada.
That's how you get the ramp down.
Super fuss.
He's skipping town, no reason.
Hmm.
I just subbed to all the girls account.
Heck, you did.
We love supporting genmates out here.
Oh, Delinia, you animal.
Literally finishing off the kill.
She said, nah, I want to be the reason
for death on the death certificate.
Jeez, Louise girl.
The bar is locked in place and cannot be opened.
Okay.
Uh, any money?
Garnet, I'll take you.
I can sell it for...
some money.
Statue of Debala, how about that?
Can I move that one?
Nope, can't move that one either.
Okay, um, I'll just stop touching things
in this house then, I guess.
I guess I'll go F myself.
Wait.
What?
This isn't the end.
Hold on.
Right here?
Ah, um, yeah.
Wait, I'm not touching anything else.
Suspicious clothes.
Honestly, I wouldn't have figured that out more.
Ah, if the game didn't help.
Little cheeky alien potion.
Oh.
Oh, what's this?
Oh, I have no idea what this is.
That looks like a trap.
Lydia, Lydia, Lydia, stop standing on stuff, Lydia.
Lydia, Lydia.
Oh, I'm getting sliced in days.
Hold on.
Oh.
I'm getting absolutely chopped up.
Oh, and there's poison darts.
Mine.
Goodness.
You need to relax.
Oh, my God.
Mine.
Okay, I've got that.
What's this?
Eh.
What even?
Why is this book?
I have curiosity.
What's the contents of this book?
I've never actually read it.
Lift her tail.
Certainly not, kind sir.
I am here to clean your chambers.
Is that all you have come...
Is that all you have come here for?
Little one, my chambers.
I have no idea what is you, implying master.
I am but a poor Argonian maid.
Bro, what?
So you are my dumpling.
And a good one at that.
Such strong legs and shapely tail.
You embarrass me, sir.
Fear not, you are safe with me.
I must finish my cleaning, sir.
The mistress will have my head if I do not.
Cleaning, eh?
I have something for you right here.
Polish my spear.
But it is huge.
It could take me all night.
Plenty of time.
My sweet plenty.
I've never fricking read that.
Oh, my God.
That's hilarious.
Many thanks.
Not certain how you managed to get your hands on this item we discussed,
but I'm more than pleased.
I thought you'd simply wait until transported to Castle Devorah
to its final destination,
but according to what I've heard,
it vanished right from their armory.
I wish I knew how you were able to slip by the guards,
bypass the porticolas,
unlock the armory door and break in at the door of a puzzle locked chest.
You need to teach me that little trick sometime.
I've left your cut in the usual drop spot
and might have another drop where you soon are.
There's three more books of it.
Oh, my God.
I knew the books existed.
Wait, what am I doing?
Egg spare.
Can we do it?
Okay.
But we have it.
Easy.
Okay, a bit more, I think.
Or maybe it was left, I don't know.
Okay, maybe it's left.
Do you know that?
Easy.
I'm getting nervous.
Alright, we got children.
I'll take children.
Not a bother at all.
The rat wave.
Let's go.
I don't remember what way to go.
Is it this one?
Oh, no, this is if you want Dragonborn.
Oops.
Can you stop attacking me?
Whoa, your bull.
It's an imperial bull.
I think an imperial bull is better than what I've got right now.
Although mine does have burn damage, so...
I wish YouTube had other emotes.
I know.
YouTube is like very slowly catching up to the appeal of...
I'm not doing any more lock picking on that now.
YouTube is very slowly catching up to what the appeal of Twitch is.
To the point where it is going to take over Twitch.
I'm sorry.
It just is.
Why did I jump down?
I've just added so much time to this travel.
I did not recall how long it takes to place Skyrim.
We're literally not even finished one questline yet.
Tear him up, Lydia.
Okay, there we go.
Emmy's Rats.
I'm so confused. Where did that come from?
I dropped down there.
Okay.
There you go.
Channel emotes soon.
Channel emotes literally less than 24 hours. Have fun.
Am I supposed to speak to Brineo?
Okay.
You know what?
If I had that selected, that probably would have gone a lot faster than what I just did there.
Underestimating the 1000 plus hours game.
Literally, I was like, right, we'll do the Thieves Guild.
We'll do Dark Brotherhood.
We're literally six hours into this stream.
I've less than six hours and I've not even finished Thieves.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
I got a bit excited there.
I apologize.
Okay.
Let's do that.
How much?
How many?
How much heavy am I?
Curry?
Wait, it's 2.18 out of 3.30.
That'll do.
I need like a hundred stuff.
Hi, Carlaya.
How long do we have?
Yeah, less than six hours because of this.
Oops.
I'm sorry.
No.
Why is two people inviting me to talk?
There's too many people.
Wait.
So do you do every sequel?
No.
I was just going to do Thieves Guild.
Black.
Assassins.
What?
That's not what they're called.
The Dark Brotherhood.
And then The Vampire.
And then The Mean Quest.
And I've done nothing yet.
So I don't think it's happening.
Dark Brotherhood.
Yes.
Hybrony of Smashes Into Wall.
The Trinity of Streams on YouTube.
YouTube Shorts of Recycles Clips with 10 Minutes Highlights on the same platform.
And also just a cheat for exposure.
Yeah, like Twitch is exposed.
It's very interesting to see breakdowns on either website.
Like, I've just...
Meet Karlai at the Sanding Zone.
Okay, we're about to become a Nightingale.
I know I've literally skipped through all the dialogue.
So for anyone who hasn't consumed Skyrim and is listening in at home,
I apologize greatly.
I can just give you the TLDR.
I'm more than happy to provide such a thing for you.
How the heck do I get out of this area?
I'll just go out of the docks.
How about that?
I don't think you can jump over.
If you haven't played Skyrim, go play Skyrim.
Mind yourself.
I'd be a Rifting Guard.
I'd be like, yeah.
You stink.
Don't be causing trouble.
Ooh.
Hi, Maul.
Any news involving the Dark Brotherhood?
Oh!
That's the other...
That's the Brotherhood Quest.
Well, that was lucky we talked to him to get that,
because we probably just have to kill Grelok the kind.
And she's actually not very keen.
What's this?
Oh, it's a clay deposit.
The Thieves Guild quest line is mostly yapping at this point.
Honestly, we're about to become Nightingales,
and it's about to be yap-yap-yap-yap-yap.
I thought I was a good yapper.
Mm-mm.
Yap-yap-yap-yap-yap-yap.
Hello.
Hiya!
I'm glad you're here.
What's the significance of this place?
This is the headquarters of the Nightingales.
Cut into the mountainside by the first of our kind.
See?
We've come to seek the edge we need to defeat Mercer Frey.
Okay, yeah.
What kind of an edge?
If you'll follow me, I'll try to explain on the way.
Yeah.
This way, please.
Yeah, let's edge this way, please.
Oh, look at them steps.
Mm, look at that bow, though.
Actually, one level.
Look at the satchel that the arrow's going.
I like how they're coded to look like what the arrow is.
Very nice.
Very, very nice.
I never believed that it existed.
I took enough and I'm back.
Are you surprised I'm still on?
Is Emi streaming today?
Emi?
Or is it?
No, Emi should already be on.
Azur should be coming online in two minutes.
If I have my times correct.
Emi's off today.
Just Sheevie and Mercy, so Mercy's on at one.
Right, we'll redirect into Mercy.
Deal?
I'll make you a deal.
We'll redirect into Mercy.
Yeah, but we're in the Nightingale like Robin Hood or something?
I, the first time I did this, like the Nightingale quest,
I was in love with Lady Luck.
I absolutely just...
Ow, I was very loud in my ear.
Hopefully that wasn't too loud in your ear.
I just absolutely and truly adored the little plot.
I like so cool.
I just look so amazing and awesome.
Everything, I am ready for the oath.
Now you go get changed.
Best looking armor in the game.
Honestly, this armor and Dark Brotherhood armor, yeah.
That's awesome.
I think we should trust the lass and take the deal.
I may have misheard you, but Mercy is in three hours.
No one.
Yeah, no, Mercy comes online at one o'clock for me.
One o'clock in the afternoon, yeah?
That's when Mercy comes online for me.
So, Mercy's actually perfect for us.
An arrangement must be struck.
So dramatic.
What time did I start streaming?
Oh, you started streaming, yeah?
At 4 a.m., yeah?
I started at 4 a.m.
You never wondered why everyone's schedule has a cheeky time zone
that no one uses,
because that's my time zone.
Straining on those night hours, yeah?
Yes, I will become Nightingale.
Yes, I'm ready.
Please stand on the western circle.
Holy crap, 4 a.m., yeah?
The reason why I stream so early
is in case I need to do stuff during the day.
Originally, it was either I stream at 4 a.m. or I stream at 10 a.m.
But the problem is, if I stream at 10 a.m.,
the day is over by the time I finish my endurance streams.
So, I wouldn't be able to do doctor's appointments if I need to make it.
Lydia, you're going to ruin this so much.
Please stand elsewhere.
Or just go...
Lydia, you're going to ruin this scene so much.
I'm not being funny.
Come here, Lydia. You're going to ruin the awesomeness of this scene.
Lydia.
Wait here.
Thank you. There's such a beautiful cinematic coming up
and they don't know what it is yet.
Just let it happen.
Oh, not Lydia standing in the corner, right?
Just don't look at her. Don't acknowledge her, okay?
She's like a dinosaur.
Alright, let's enjoy this because this is actually pretty cool.
I've come before you to throw myself upon your mercy
and to accept responsibility for my failure.
You're already mine, Carlisle.
Your terms were struck long ago.
What could you possibly offer me now?
I have two others that wish to transact the oath
to serve you both in life and in death.
You surprise me, Carlisle.
This offer is definitely weighted in my favor.
In my favor.
I ain't saying none of this.
What's the next?
Monka.
Wait, we don't get to see her?
I didn't see her.
Norm, I thought we got to see her.
I guess it's with the next cinematic.
What do you mean, we?
Yes, it's true, Crane.
He's done more.
The Scaly Key.
Big Scaly.
So the key doesn't lock any doors.
The three sounds like no one should possess it.
It's too much power for one human to have.
We see her when we return the key.
Yes, we will do that.
First time I've ever set out to return something?
Let's go then.
Alright, Big Brinny, what's up?
Oh my God, he's tapping his feet.
Oh, he's doing the Irish dance for us.
After we deal with him,
all that remains is restoring the guild to its full strength.
As a result, there won't be anything that you have attention to.
I've been at this game a long time, my friend.
A long time. I've stolen trinkets from nobles,
and turned priests for murder.
I'm good at what I do.
Maybe even one of the best,
but it's all I know.
It's on your words, but your foot is moving
and it's making me laugh.
It's about time. No, it's not right.
I don't know what to say.
So don't get sentimental on me now, I accept.
We'll handle the details.
Oh, we have quite the task ahead.
Then let's get to it.
What if we try to use the key on strongy?
And in playing, you don't have free reign of me?
Reef playing, you know me better than that.
Lydia, I'm sorry that I put you in exile.
Yes, follow me.
My thing.
I can't believe I made myself Lydia 2.0.
Strongy using the key on reefing?
It's funny, you think you have any resistance against me.
Roy is regaining his own foot in the way he tap him.
Here.
Oh yeah, becoming the guild master is bugged
if you don't do the radiant quest first.
Oh, I've always managed to do them after.
I don't even know how they...
Where the heck do you expect me to go?
Eh, let's do that then.
Strongy, considering you don't have many lockpicks,
it may be beneficial just to hold on to it for a while.
Honestly though.
Right, I need to go a little to the left.
Not to be confused with the hit steam game.
A little to the left.
Let's get to it.
If I can get up this hill, then the enemies in that building
won't be able to annoy me.
Why would I resist strongy?
Exactly, why would you?
Anyone who puts up with me?
Anyone who puts up a fight gets...
Twice as hard.
Hopefully you can figure out what the substitute was for that word.
That's terrible.
Wait, that's north.
I'm going the wrong way.
No, it's like along the waterfront.
And just what?
Sounds good.
Hi, strongy.
Dang, you're going hard into this game.
We haven't even finished one quest lane yet.
It's officially been six hours
and I haven't finished one quest lane.
I completely forgot how
just humongous what this game is.
It's extraordinary
that I haven't actually...
I'm about to get close to finishing the thieves.
But even then, I'm not even going to truly finish them
due to the reason
of...
of what?
Of...
Because we're not even going to do
those miscellaneous quests for the Thief's Guild
to restore it to its final glory.
Cause...
Do I take the lift here?
No, I still don't take the lift.
Keep the skeleton key for yourself.
No, I'll be a good girl
because I want to see a mummy nocturnal.
I really like her design.
I wouldn't mind
incorporating...
I wouldn't mind.
It's a very good design.
Now the heck did I get where I'm going?
Literally every time I have to go somewhere
I just start spamming E on a hill
and I'm like, is this where I'm supposed to go?
No, I don't really have to walk up the hill yet.
No, I don't have to walk up the hill.
It's fine. It's fine.
I saw that orbing.
I'm not sure if I should resist or not.
Either way, the outcome is clear.
The hard...
Oh, I thought it was the wind.
It was rules.
You don't need the key when you get a log pick into a hundred.
Oh, I didn't mean that.
Does everything just become easy piece of lemon squeezy?
Or do the log picks not break on a hundred or something?
We're getting there.
We can do it. I believe in us.
We're just a little exhausted.
I'm scarous.
I thought for some reason
you said I'm scouse
and I was like, right?
Now what?
Oh yeah, by the way, I'm scouse.
I like the way you talk, Scottish lass.
You know, right?
Can I buy a cheeky Maccas?
Wait, Maccas is Australian term.
I can't believe it.
We're boarding live here today.
Today, we are going to...
This place is actually covered in bandits.
I cannot for the life of me doing Australian accent.
Right, what's this?
A gate. Open the gate. Why not?
That might come and help me
with future...
Go on a Maccas run, yeah?
Get in void with me, yeah?
Oh, I thought I was going to one-shot you.
I'm going to be honest.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, you can beg for mercy
when you're dead.
P-pop-pop...
Oh, I bonked him. Right, give me that.
I will destroy that.
What is this? Can someone look this up?
What am I supposed to do with this?
Flawed Var-la Stone.
I don't know what it is.
I've never seen them before.
before PC seems to have them, Xbox doesn't seem to have them.
But Mercedes in three hours!
Say a shout out to Mercedes!
Sorry, I got a lot of gold itch on my head.
I like to see them.
Speak to Carlaya.
Ooh, they got a good look.
Expert is about much, I've done that for souls.
Right, the machines drop.
Where's Lydia?
Lydia, you do this all the time.
There should be an enemy that pops out of here, yeah.
Oh, that's right, I remember.
These guys used to treat me out.
I'm actually, I'll tell you what, that was like really loud.
I'm going to...
...settings, audio.
Is that a bit better on your ears?
I feel like whenever that happens, it's so loud.
A new hand has touched the beacon.
Now, these do drop, yeah.
That's exactly what I'm wanting, like tons of these soul gems.
Where's the enemy?
I love the enemy.
Just got an enemy.
Ooh, hold on.
My two hands is 46.
We're getting there, we're getting there.
Yes, oh my goodness.
This is what we want, like massive amounts of these soul gems.
And then we can put like really good stuff on.
There should be one that pops out of here.
Yeah.
Oh, I'm getting too good.
I'm genuinely too good at this game, I'm sorry.
The fact that I remember from childhood,
where the enemies like come out.
I'm not sure how scared I was with the enemies.
Come here.
Okay, there we go.
What was that, three to scavenge?
Oh, I'll take it, I'll take it.
I'll take it, I'll take anything.
I'm happy with anything, any offerings I'll take.
Oh, yeah.
Is the enemy from here?
Here.
Oh, I heard that.
I heard them like spidering up here.
I can hear enemy.
Oh, I heard two just one in there, but I need to go here.
They're so tiny.
Oh, we are getting so many soldiers.
This is exactly what I was needing, one of the runs in here.
That spawn sneak is actually impressive.
Ah.
There, them.
Okay, we can destroy that.
Yeah, let's go.
Alchemy, Arvin.
Yeah, yeah, I'll take the potions, let's go.
Oh my god, I just jumped in real life because of that noise of that latch.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, hello.
I hope you aren't too late.
Oh, those bandits back there.
Dot, dot, dot.
Mm-hmm.
I had the brap lever literally jump scare of me.
Oh, he really got me there, didn't he?
Oh, soul gems.
We love soul gems, soul gems, soul gems, soul gems.
Oh, wait, is this the thing?
I'm supposed to watch him.
Look, there he is.
Look through the bars.
I'm trying to, where is he?
I'm pretty sure he pops out somewhere here.
And this is a, this is an instance report.
I've returned to continue watching.
Where?
Oh, there he is, there he is.
That's Mercer.
Look, I'm crawling over.
Look at this little cinematic.
I like how they just expire right now.
Oh, they didn't even move a sword.
Eyelash, and we'll be ready for him.
Man, the FOV is so low.
Do you get motion sickness?
No.
I'm very lucky, Mercy says she gets motion sickness
playing video games.
Not to be dramatic, but I think I would end it.
Oh, God, I think there's a farmer around here.
What's this?
Potions.
Lutions and potions.
I do love a good, I do love a good collection.
Isn't there a farmer here?
No?
Empty?
Oh, found him.
Found him.
And I have course of poison.
What does he draw?
Skibertail, nah, you're good.
You, I want your soul gems.
Who am I perishing?
Why is Mercer such a poofy poofy?
Oh!
I just smacked myself into a wall at low health.
Okay, that'll do.
I think I'll be okay now.
That was a jump scare and a half.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Actually, it's probably really good that I have that on a panic
because it gets me away from the enemy really quickly.
The heck is this?
Let's just stop.
Oh, I need to go up.
Excuse me.
The freaking blades on the ground took all my eggspear.
Are we having a troll?
That's, eh?
And where's the other lever?
Excuse me, Brynjolf, you're just smacked me in the...
That's the other lever there?
Behind an eggspear?
That can't be right.
Surely not.
But it is.
That can't be right.
Don't you have the skeleton key?
No, we've not done that part.
But that is it.
Well, good thing I don't have a smurf it, but what?
Wait.
Oh, that's not the lever at all.
Where the heck's the first lever?
Is it here?
Where's the second lever?
Reveal yourself.
What?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's adjacent to the other lever.
Oh my god.
Then you can go all the way back again.
Out my way, out my way, out my way, out my way.
I'm not that fast.
Hold on, hold on, I need to cheat.
I was gonna say, putting something behind an eggspear level thing is wild.
That wasn't it?
Okay, I was gonna say that has to be it.
I refuse.
A little cheeky chess.
I'm being trolled by this game.
I'm being trolled.
I'll destroy that, and then I can get more thingy.
Are we there yet, bruv?
I feel the same.
We've literally not even finished one quest line.
I'm ready to make another cup of tea.
All right, you can stealth this area, but I'd rather just go for it.
I'd rather just go for it.
Earthquake, cheeky bit of an earthquake.
By the Pope, who's there?
Identify yourself.
There is a chess down below, but I'm not really fast right now.
I want to finish one quest line.
One quest line is all I ask.
Stop it.
You're so stinky.
Okay, hold on.
You got something.
Shaman's key.
What was this?
The shaman's key, dude.
Oh, is it for that?
You know what?
I might be the chest.
No, it's not.
Well, I'm not looting it then.
Go away.
I don't know what the heck the shaman's key is for.
Clapham stinky lining, honestly.
I mean, how do you come back from that?
Someone calls you stinky.
You have no way of coming back, truly.
It's over for you.
Just admit it.
There's traps everywhere.
Isn't there a massive Centaurian coming up?
My brains just reminded me that there's like a big enemy coming soon.
What does that say?
Bruv, the game thinks I can read that?
Mercer, it's backwards.
Mercer is on the bottom.
One, two.
Why is that backwards?
I can read Mercer as backwards.
I don't mind the stinky.
I don't mind the wise.
What, an air?
Why is it backwards?
I'll take these scrolls because I can sell them for money.
This is very real.
Oh, dear.
Right, can you jump the Centaurian and not me, maybe?
Oh, goodness, gravy.
Some of these enemies.
Am I right, fellas?
Oh, my fellas.
Oh.
Oh, hold on.
Hold on, right, there you go.
All right, I should probably go to sleep.
See you next time.
Rest well, those who sleep.
Please don't worry if you do need to go to sleep again.
Bit of a cheeky endurance stream.
Mercer is going live in T-minus less than three hours.
We are going to raid Dinter because my Skyrim escapades got cut short
due to the fact that, oh, I am moving so fast.
I am successfully avoiding all the traps laid out.
Yes, I don't know why achievements aren't popping up.
I'm literally using Xbox Game Pass right now, so it's kind of the...
I'm not sure what the dealio is, but I'm quite happy just to play through the...
Thingamabobber and tomorrow's monetization celebration.
So I guess I can enjoy like a more relaxed for my boys.
Oh, come on.
Get a rest.
Oh, I'm low health.
I'm about to get altered by a spider.
Hold on.
Okay, there we go.
Go around to read it.
Go around it to read it.
Oh, is there like another room that makes a lot more sense
if there was like something behind it?
Me here just ignored it and chose to be confused.
Oh, give me that.
Oh, orcishbowl and ice.
Oh, and alchemy.
Resurrect and restore my energy.
Mmm.
Alchemyxing like a DJ.
Give me them juicy soul gems.
That's all I want.
That's all I crave.
I just want soul gems.
Oh, I might get one of you.
No.
Okay, okay.
You guys don't need to perfectly follow me.
You do realize that, right?
But we can do this.
And we completely missed them because we alerted the enemies to our location.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, my God, he's beat.
He jumped in me.
I'm actually beating that.
I wasn't beating him.
God, they have so much venom.
So much venom.
Don't mind if I do it.
What on earth were they doing?
Sheebie, what have you been doing in your dungeon?
These last words?
Oh, my God, that's brutal.
Hold on.
These last words.
Nobody thought they were real,
but I've seen them in the eyes of the snow elves.
The dwarves thought they took them from the Thawmer,
but they themselves were fooled.
A statue built in secrecy by the slaves.
The eyes burn into you,
and I see them even now.
Sarafa escaped through the collapsing tunnel,
but he'll never escape what we've seen.
Men will never believe him,
and he'll be driven mad by the knowledge that he'll never see them again.
But I may yet see them again before I die.
Wow, that was strange.
Johnny's a soul gem addict.
Literally, they're like the most OP leveling up system.
I'm just going to blast through this area
because there's a massive flamethrower, I think, or something.
How am I detected if I'm around the corner?
Why are you going for me?
He's right there.
Literally, right.
Actually, I just remembered Mercer drops are really good.
Two-handed sword, and we already got children.
Yeah, that's right. Spank that rat on the fire.
Oh.
Oh, let's go.
Oh, my fellows.
Oh, I'm getting...
Yeah, okay. I was the same kind of blasted by this.
We may yet to see Johnny's eyes before we die.
I might need to heal.
Or I might get a wave of thought.
Ooh, we've been...
Oh, I got detected.
I keep going, like, all right.
I'll finally go sneak, and then I get detected
because I'm not paying attention.
Touch this.
Eat this.
Fun fact, the Dwemer and Elden Scrolls are not doors,
but actually, a type of elf.
Two-handed.
He isn't a drill wielder.
Exactly.
Imagine not being a drill wielder.
I can't relate.
I've tried so many times to be an archer,
but I just can't do it.
Like, especially when the enemy come up in your face
and you've got a bow and arrow,
it's like, bro, wouldn't actually be so furofuro.
I think that actually does more damage to the mother.
Wait, can I get them to deal with the enemies?
Oh, my God, that's so cool.
I can, like, go through here.
Is there, like, a treasure chest or something?
Or is this just, like, a hurry up?
Oh, wait, that symbol.
That means there's loot here?
I don't see no loot.
Or does it just mean that the thieves' guild was here?
Huh?
I'm so confused.
I feel like there may have been something I missed,
but hey-ho.
All right, let's get to it.
Everybody get to it.
To it.
Let's get this part.
It started.
Let's get the foam.
Departed.
Mercer was here.
Shield one-handed is perfectly viable.
Thank you very much.
Probably.
What do they hold?
So they just kind of hold a lot of, like, mix and stuff.
That's interesting.
I guess a few were more into, like, the alchemy side of things.
Oh, master a lot.
Right, I'm not bothering.
Saw his bot on your bike.
Mm-hmm.
Hydration check.
Oh.
Wow!
Such a ship.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, give me the key, Mercer.
The water's rising.
Uh...
I don't believe you, no.
Turtle gates me.
My new friend leaking.
Both of us lie, cheat, and steal.
Oh!
Dun, dun, dun.
The difference is, I still have honor.
If anyone falls, it'll be you, Mercer.
Nightingale.
Uh, I can't remember if this is hard or not.
Oh, no, he got wallets.
Oh, he's got blood drain.
Oh, my God.
Oh, where is he?
I can just see the red doll.
I'm chasing the red doll.
I'm not even...
There he is!
I found him!
Hello!
I got him.
He's got...
Whoa, he's got like...
Yeah, I'll take all that.
Shit, give me everything.
Oh, I'm carrying too much to be able to run.
Uh...
Oh, sorry, hold on.
Sorry, excuse me.
Just need to drop a few things that I don't need.
I don't need an embalming tool.
I can show you that much.
Uh, don't need random chunks of ore.
That's fine.
A wall?
It looks like a ship.
Is that a tap?
Yeah, don't need all these random miscellaneous things.
That's fine.
Ingredients that could probably eat all the little ones
and clear up some side space stuff, I guess?
Unknown, unknown.
Sorry, guys.
I know the cave is collapsing.
It's very important I have a little taste test
of all these ingredients.
I assure you.
Food?
Yeah, sure.
I'm just freaking loaded up.
Am I light yet?
No, I'm not light yet.
Holy crap.
Okay, uh, right.
What do we not need?
That does say 26, not gonna lie.
Oh, I forgot to...
That one's better.
I don't want to, like, drop it, though.
I feel like I can sell it for, like, decent money, honestly.
Um...
I guess we'll just drop that shit.
Orcishbowl, 11, playing...
These don't really give me much money.
Okay.
So don't panic.
I know the cave is literally...
Why is it...
Oh, I know the cave is, like, perishing
and it's falling with war.
But don't panic, guys.
Everything is okay, alright?
You just have to let it fill.
Oh.
Oh, he...
Oh, he hit the quad.
The quad.
Oh, are you guys okay?
Do you guys need to breathe?
No?
No, you don't need to breathe?
Okay.
You don't have to.
If you look above the head of the elf,
you'll notice those rocks look very suspiciously movable.
That's because they are.
You have a keen eye.
Refling, you have a keen eye.
Strongly to taste test all the new alchemy ingredients.
Literally, like, trying to, like, release.
Some of the weight in my inventory.
And I'm like, hmm, yes, hmm.
This moth wing is the whole...
What a delicacy.
You just have to wait.
Unfortunately, you can't, like, swim upwards.
It doesn't do it the way you want it to.
So it's a bit awkward.
But yeah.
I remember the first place where I was trying to, like,
swim through these pipes.
I was like, yes, the pipes, the pipes will save me.
But it should do one big collapse.
There you go.
Take it long enough, honestly.
And then you just gotta wait until it gets high enough to get up there.
To shift the weight in my body eats 50 cheese wheels.
We are aquatic.
Let me eat some too.
Stopping to release, yes, there.
Hmm.
But it's faster you get out of that cave
the easier the game.
Briff.
I have completely forgotten how much the NPCs
love to talk to you.
Five, eight, nine.
No!
Carlisle!
It's not simple.
Sepucar.
I've never said sepucar.
Are you ready to take a pilgrimage together?
Then we'd best get started.
You need to protect the king.
I'm afraid you'll have to face the end of your journey alone.
Take this with you.
I'm not certain if it will help within the walls of the sepucar.
I've had this for the most time.
And I haven't let me down.
I hope it brings you the same path.
I'll literally yank the HP off him.
Can we serve Strony in other ways?
Absolutely.
It depends what your offering is to me.
Aw, I've not even been a folk wreath yet!
Actually, you know what?
I need to destroy and enchant a few things to sell on.
So I'm gonna go do that now and it will free up a lot of inventory.
Is Carlaya the same VA as Shadowheart?
I cannot tell you that.
I don't know.
Baldur's Gate is such a good review, though,
that I'm really tempted to play it for the first time on stream.
I'm worried in case I'm so dumb I can't figure it out,
but hopefully it's a full-proof game.
Anyone can just jump in on the fun.
This is what I want.
Devouring, archery, and potions.
Everything else can be sold.
You heard it here first.
Did I even have a big gem?
I do!
Yes!
Did I make it craft?
That was bloody good shoo.
That bloody good shoo.
Right, where's that?
Okay.
So what? Just enchant random stuff now for the XP, I guess?
Turn Undead.
Frost Damage, here, why not?
Petty Soul Gem.
Yeah, I'm just going to put Petty Soul Gem stuff on it.
And then I know I can sell everything in my inventory.
God, look at the level up is so fast.
This game is so forgiving.
Just the noise.
It's just constantly like...
We'll put all of this stuff on.
And then we can get a pretty penny.
Oh, we might be able to buy the home.
We might be able to buy our home in Riften.
And then we can have our little flower garden out in front.
We can't get chickens though.
Not yet.
Baldur's Gate 3 is good and you can do whatever you want.
It's not really wrong way of playing it.
Baldur's Gate is really open and rewarding.
I'm glad.
Um...
I can't figure it out.
Also, it tells us, please backseat me.
You'll be fine.
Yeah, some folk really are so strongly like a little bit backseat gaming.
I'm actually going to travel to Riften just to sell some stuff
because my inventory is getting a bit too full.
Now, as much as I like being full and, you know, a bandaid slapped on top.
Not like this.
What is this?
You!
I would like to sell some weapons that are very heavy.
I will keep children.
I'll put it elsewhere.
I don't want to sell that stuff.
I'd rather keep it in the prowl.
I can sell, like, all of it right here at Money's.
I will remember that.
You can marry the butcher.
He's not butcher.
He's a blacksmith making all that.
Those wires are really crossed on me.
Please take...
Please take some of my stuff that I don't need.
Thanks. Appreciate it.
Created potions are 1% more per...
Wait, no, actually, I'm going to keep the diamonds and stuff on me.
The reason for that is because you can get, like,
Miscellaneous Quest to ask for that basic stuff.
How about you?
Everything I've got on display, really.
We're going to get rid of all this.
This should really lighten the load.
I don't want to sell that thing.
Oh, I completely forgot I had, like, all those...
That must...
Oh, he's not going to go left.
Oops.
Oops, I'm giving away things for free.
Oopsies.
Teehee.
Little teehee moment.
Right, we'll go Falkreath and then we'll hit up Twilight's...
La-la-la-la-la.
Strangely, I will remember everything you said.
Bear, no.
I even don't want to say half the time.
I'm just here for a good time.
Do you remember when we almost got our head chopped off?
Yeah, and I was taken over by bandits and burnt to a crisp.
Teehee, not my problem.
Teehee.
Strangely, Ever dropped a bunch of jewelry in the shopping centre in Riften.
Everyone starts fighting over stuff you drop,
and, like, it literally terminates NPCs,
and it's, like, the proof.
I've need them for quests.
That's the one thing I could absolutely obliterate Skyrim for,
is if a quest requires an NPC,
do not let them be perishable.
Do not let them expire.
I am so sad.
What the heck is...
Oh, no!
The wolves jump these poor people,
and the one wolf perished them both.
That's what you get for trying to execute an innocent dragonborn.
Some of them are marchers.
Yeah, like, some NPCs can't be perishable,
but if they have a quest,
I feel like they shouldn't be able to expire at all,
because it's so annoying when you're, like, trying to do it,
and then it's, like, all surprised, by the way.
Oh, who are you?
Hello.
Mummy, Goo Goo Gaga Azura.
Mummy.
Any mummies.
We'll make it a little tea break.
A little tea break?
Is that allowed?
Is that permitted?
And then I'm going to get a wee snack as well.
A bit of a little cup of tea, a little bit of water.
Yeah, I'm starting to think we're getting, like, absolutely nothing done.
We're pretty much looking at T-minus two hours.
I've been live for almost seven hours.
I've yet to finish the quest.
Right, fault creases here.
What the heck is that?
Bro, you cannot drop rocks on people's heads.
I cannot tell you how inappropriate that is.
I am home with my mummy.
We drink milk and tea up in this place, of course.
Literally, how have I been at this for seven hours?
I'm not completed one quest.
Something's not adding up.
I don't know.
Like, I'm pretty sure the Skyrim World record is, like, two hours.
Like, one hour and 52 minutes or something.
Ridiculous like that.
And you're telling me in seven hours, near seven hours, I couldn't finish one quest line.
Well, I need sleep.
Good night.
Thank you for hanging.
No promises.
I won't see you in my dreams.
That's right.
Get Scottish.
Your only dream of a Scottish.
The Highland Cows call you.
Ooh, I don't want to walk over a grave.
That's bad luck.
There's a lot of graves.
What's going on in fault grief?
I feel like that's probably a quest, because that's a lot.
Scotland, forever.
A little tricky thing.
Get Scottish.
I think I need to do that.
Someone did that where it was like, get pregnant, get pregnant, get pregnant.
And it's like, do you didn't see it?
Like, really intense music.
I want to do that, but like, get Scottish.
Get Scottish.
We're almost there.
We're just going to run a little bit longer.
Oh, there's castles and ruins.
Did you know you can just straight up buy castles in Scotland?
Fun fact, you can literally look up them online.
Just type in Castle for sale in Scotland.
I'm not even kidding.
It's pretty intense and cool.
And you can buy churches.
It's a lot cheaper to live in a church, an ex-church, by the way.
You can literally, it's like churches for sale in Scotland.
Yeah.
Just have a look.
It's like way cheaper.
Shawnee, have you heard of the Scott Wikipedia vandalism story?
Yes.
Oh, we should talk about it.
Like, if you didn't know, so Scots is basically slang.
And we say things very phonetically.
And someone, whoa, I didn't realize you were a bandit.
Sorry.
Time to go, buddy.
Okay.
And someone basically went, oh, I'll just rewrite this in Scots.
But he, like, wasn't Scottish.
So he just wrote what he thought, like, Scottish folks said.
And it was just complete gibberish.
And he'd been doing it for ages and no one, like, caught him.
Wasn't that it?
He said in Zillow, Scotland to find an affordable hoose, honestly.
It's Gallus.
Hello.
Hello, Gallus.
I visited Edinburgh.
Let's go.
I'd ask the same question with you.
It's really funny.
Shawnee's going to buy a castle, move the wheel or team into it,
reference to serve them there.
But could you imagine, though?
Like, oh, you know what, you get out of this exchange?
I servited.
How are you to blame?
Where can I say not?
Wait a minute, you're Gallus.
I've heard that name in a long, long time.
How do you know of me?
I'm best pals with your girlfriend.
The key.
You have the skeleton key.
I never thought I'd see it again.
How do you say I love you in Scottish?
It's just I love you.
Like, I love you, and then I love you.
It's kind of, like, shoved together in fast.
He's that adoring fan.
Is he?
Biazura, Biazura, Biazura.
I did this for Nektoro.
I did this for the owner of the guild.
Carlaya helped me.
Yes, your girlfriend's alive.
Well, then she would have appeared here.
Then take the key and right all the wrongs.
When we put the strongens or cult leader,
we could cut taxes and save money.
Yay!
We can be tax exempt together.
Yippee!
How can I, how can a spirit die?
The sepulchre isn't nearly a temple
or a vault to house the key.
Within these walls is the ebony.
The ebony?
A bit of an ebony.
When Mercer stole the key,
that conduit closed,
severely limiting our...
Maintaining a historical site
for tax breaks and profit?
Yeah!
And then we run, like, a massive B&B over.
Oh, my God.
Oh!
I'm afraid so.
I'm weakening.
And I can feel myself slipping away.
The years without restoration of my power
I had taken their toll.
You really want to mess with the IRS?
That should be a song.
I fought the law in the law one.
Ray.
I will go.
Good luck, Gallus.
Even if you don't have to do anything,
that's okay, I'll do it all.
I don't mind doing the hard work, right?
Who needs a bastion?
Who's begging for the pagan?
Because it's all happening at once.
Let's go!
I bet he do.
Beat him up, beat him up, beat him up!
Beat him up!
Ay! Ay! Ay!
Oh, wow.
They're actually kind of beef.
They're actually a bit stronger
than your average enemy.
Hold on a minute.
I don't like that.
Where's...
You, come here.
No.
I'm stuck on the stairs.
Hold on.
I'm stuck on...
Ow! Ow!
Stop!
Swap to weapon, Ray!
Stop to melee!
Yes, there you go.
Okay, there we go.
Jeez, I lose.
What is in you?
Arrows?
So, Gem!
Alchemy!
Totally not secret,
backtracking.
I do love Skyrim for that.
It's quite...
It's quite rather entertaining.
Okay, they've got elven arrows
on their persons,
which is pretty...
Ugh.
Whoa, why are you so scary?
I'm not gonna lie.
Like, they're kind of messing me up now.
Open our own velar colony?
What?
In the Scottish countryside with crops
and feudal lordship for the growth?
Bruh.
Look, sometimes a sense of community
is all you need.
Wait, I'm to stay in the dark.
Right, if you stay in the dark,
your health doesn't get...
Well, wasn't paying attention to that.
Was I?
Clearly, no?
Uh, yeah, you just need to stay in the dark
so you don't get hurt in this section.
It's not really too bad at all.
I just can't see nothing in it at all.
Oh!
It's just a wee bit of poison.
Just a few darts in my eyeballs.
It's fine, it's fine.
I can still see for the most part.
Hee hee.
I wish I wore my glasses.
Ah, we did it!
Hey!
Woo!
Let's go.
What's this?
Ah!
My lady!
Hello!
Oh!
A bandit got all the way here.
Hello, my lady.
Please ignore the fact that I'm taking your offering.
So fragmented, I don't need that.
Uh, uh, behind here is two chains to pull.
Gammy!
Atlas!
Where's Blossom?
Where's Gammy?
That's Gammy, the girl.
And that's her dad, Atlas.
And Blossom's her mummy.
Hmm.
Is it true if you buy Landon Scott, you become a lord?
No, that is completely false.
Um, if you take that in, by the way,
you'll actually...
What on earth?
Um...
Hello!
Ow!
Oh my god, I just got reeled by a log.
That wasn't really that fun, I'm gonna be honest.
Right, we did it.
We did it.
We're here, we're here.
Snowberry's waiting on Aces every need.
Penpal's being picked for a set of me.
Oh, it's all spooky, it's all spooky and purple.
Oh, I love the color scheme.
Oh, I remember this.
Oh no, I'm stuck.
I should read his note.
Anderson's, Andrew's message.
I can't believe it, I came all this way,
solved all of those ridiculous riddles,
just to end up here.
After I memorized Nystrom's clues,
he'd collected from Letheus,
isolate his throat.
Now I guess the joke's on me,
because I'm stuck here and I don't see a way out.
Hope someone comes by soon, I'm getting hungry.
I don't think he made it, chief.
I don't think he made it.
Yeah.
If only we had some sort of...
key?
Some sort of skeleton...
Yep.
Oh.
Oh, I'm stuck.
What have we got?
Oh, yes.
Gammys!
Look at all Gammys babies!
Oh, I'm the wrong way, sorry Hen.
Tell me that ain't good design.
Excuse me, will Stylical around?
Oh, yeah.
Nothing more than the fulfillment of your agreement.
We must stay focused, Reeflings.
We must stay focused.
I wish you to drink deeply from the Evermere mortal.
Or this is where the agent of Nocturnal is born.
Drink?
The oath has been strong.
The die has been cast.
And your fate awaits you in the Everglow.
Bye-bye, Mommy!
What? Where did you come from?
Hello?
Sorry.
Oh, sorry.
Can I talk to you now?
Yes.
Uh, please, she sounded indifferent.
I assure you that she'd been displeased with you.
We wouldn't be having this conversation.
What's this about becoming an agent and a Nocturnal?
The crescent moon represents the agent of shadow.
The crescent moon, I think, is what we want.
In the full moon, for the agent of strife.
This is Nocturnal's role in maintaining balance.
How is this goddess of stealth when it's clear?
With the clap of her cheeks,
we'd alarm the guards on a 500 meter radius.
It's unfamiliar.
Her hotness is so powerful.
And you?
Aww.
The beginning of what?
Wow.
We're down good at what we do.
Uh, I think stealth.
Tell me where the crescent moon.
Is the most on moonlit nights.
Yeah, okay.
Well, you do the agent of...
Are you a crescent moon?
You're a full moon.
And you're a half moon.
Okay, crescent moon.
Okay, now what?
Oh no, Gallus is about to come.
Ooh, look, it's Gallus and Carnaia.
They're gonna kiss.
I was afraid she'd become like the others.
If it were not for the actions of this Nightingale,
she and his would have come true.
She would have lost all hope.
Nocturnal calls me to the Everglow.
My contract has been fulfilled.
Will I ever see you again?
When your debt to Nocturnal has been paid,
we'll embrace what's ahead.
How well, Gallus.
Eyes open.
Walk with the shadows.
I've been 25 years since you've seen each other,
and this is it.
This is what they muster.
Are you alright, Carla?
Maybe it's just not...
She doesn't understand.
Oh, he's going to disappear into the bowl of soup.
Oh, he's in the bowl of soup, lads.
Sorry, I'm sure it's really emotional.
What is it?
He appeared at Gallus' school in our bowl of soup.
The spirit becomes one with the Everglow.
Ah.
So he's gone.
Okay.
You drank the ghost soup, honestly.
They're a part of the darkness around us.
When we say, walk with the shadows,
we are asking those nightingales who have passed on to protect us,
to believe that they are literally what guides our uncanny luck,
by placing their hands in ours.
That's why the Evermere needed to be reopened.
Without it, there's no way Nocturnal was able to...
I'm getting it now.
How will I know if I'm needed here?
If this place is in danger ever again,
the shadows will call.
Okay.
Where should the need arise?
A portal connects the Sepulchre and Nightingale Hall.
Use it whenever you wish.
Okay.
Where will you be?
I've decided to make my home at Nightingale Hall.
Since it's your home as well.
I hope to see you and bring you out there.
Of course, I may visit some of Skyrim's cities too.
Quiet things from time to time.
Can't afford to get rusty now, can we?
Well, I'm...
I'm satisfied.
Yeah, yeah, bye-bye.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you, hubby-bee.
Is this your home now?
It is!
Okay, so she just hangs out here now.
Girl, that's a bit depressive.
But anyway, that's all for now.
As long as you're having a good time and all that.
Thanks for the experience of being in Nightingale.
Alright, have a good night and good luck.
Thank you!
For those of you who need to go rest, please do rest.
I am literally farting about...
Cause...
Mercy is going live in two hours.
I'm gonna redirect into her and then it means I can...
Do a little bit of...
A little bit of preparation for my monetization stream tomorrow.
I'll need to actually make the thumbnail.
And you get a picture of my frickin' feet for the thumbnail.
Omega at low.
And...
Oh no, what did I do now?
Well, we do...
Night...
Night mother, night mother, send your child unto me for...
Oh no, sweet mother.
I keep saying night mother.
Apparently...
It's sweet mother.
I could've sworn I turned that on.
Man, there we go.
Yeah.
Group brushing, T minus 90 minutes.
Yes.
Right.
I am going to make a cup of tea.
If we would all like to get something to hydrate.
Gotta go to Winterhold for that one.
Yes.
I'm gonna make a cup of tea.
And then...
We will...
See how far we can get on the dark, brotherhood.
There's absolutely no way in heck we are getting anywhere close to it.
But...
It doesn't mean we can't start it, okay?
Man, I'll arrive late for tomorrow's stream cause I'll be at work.
It's a very short stream tomorrow.
It's not Skyrim part two, just...
For those of you who may be lurking, there is not a Skyrim part two tomorrow
cause I've completely messed up the achievements
and the whole point was to do the achievements.
And for some reason they're not working even though I am on Xbox Game Pass.
But we do have plenty of time in the future.
I will definitely come back to Skyrim once I've fixed whatever's going on.
Cause honestly, I'm like, should've just played cameo.
Sorry, we need to break in here so we can go talk to this kid.
Sweet mother, sweet mother, send your child unto me for this soon.
Very tired.
Oh no.
Sweet mother, send your child unto me.
So you come in.
Munkah.
S.
Are you alright?
The body?
She came.
An assassin from a dark brotherhood.
Ah yes, the black sacrum.
A Wang of course.
So long.
So very long.
But now that you're here, you can accept my contract.
Your contract?
My mother, she...
She died.
I'm all alone now.
So they sent me to the terrible orphanage in Riften on her hall.
The headmistress is an evil cruel woman.
They call her Grelad the kind.
But she's not kind.
She's terrible to all of us.
So I ran away and came home.
And performed the black sacrament.
Now we're here.
And you can kill Grelad the kind.
Sure, buddy.
A kiss by the sweet mother.
What does the book say?
Hand that book over.
So you wish to summon the dark brotherhood.
You wish to see someone dead.
Pray, child, pray, and let the night mother hear your plea.
You must perform that most profane of rituals, the black sacrament.
Create an effigy of the intended victim assembled from actual body parts,
including a heart, skull, bones, and flesh.
And circle that effigy with candles.
The ritual itself must then commence.
Proceed to stab the effigy repeatedly with a dagger,
rubbed with the petals of a nightshade plant while whispering this plea.
Sweet mother, sweet mother, send your child unto me
for the sins of the unworthy must be baptized in blood and fear.
Then wait, child, for the dread father sitheth rewards the patient.
You will be visited by a representative of the dark brotherhood.
So begins a contract bound in blood.
That's actually really cool.
Oh, I'm quite happy with that.
I quite like that kind of back behind the scenes,
not behind the scenes because it's like hidden in a book,
so it's not behind the scenes.
But I like seeing how the game like tried to explain it.
It's quite thingy.
Where did he find the body part?
Oh, he tried his best, okay.
Probably went into the crypt or something like that.
So this is probably the only instance
when you can perish someone in front of a whole group of people.
Sorry, Hen.
Yeah, you do not get in trouble for doing that.
And all the kids...
And they're all like laughing at our own stuff.
Wait, oh, I've gone the wrong way.
Sorry, I've gone the wrong way.
We're saved.
Yeah, literally one of the only instances
you can walk in and perish someone
and then come straight back out again.
They don't care.
No one cares.
The Rift and Guards don't even care.
They must have known as well.
Now, the actual nice lady takes over.
Yay!
So really, we just did everyone a big ol' favour.
I was like finding different fun ways.
Apparently you can cast Friendsly in the Children Parish Gray look.
I'm not sure if that's true or not.
Is she...
You know?
Like, kinda sounds like Midoriya.
What did you give me?
You're a child.
Completed Innocence Loss.
Family heirloom?
Oh, sorry, sorry.
My bad.
I got a little...
I just needed to check what your family heirloom was.
Is there any?
Oh, there is.
A plate?
A plate.
I mean, you are a child, so I guess that makes sense.
Now, if I remember correctly,
we need to go sleep in a bed.
The first sleep the poor dragonborn has had
since I started my adventures,
so we'll just rent a little bed in here.
You ever just accidentally dash across the house, honestly?
Oh, you.
Hello!
Can you come a bit closer?
Okay, I guess not.
Yeah, I'd like to rent a room.
Thanks, darling.
Oh, okay.
Oh, 10...
10 stars!
Whoa!
Hello?
My lady?
You want to join me?
Okay.
Right, please stop talking to me.
I'm trying to be sure in my room,
but I'm having to help the NPC.
Okay, there we go.
Thank you for showing me my room.
If you want the tip,
just stay in the room, right?
Get in that bed.
Don't be ill.
It's all right.
Absolutely shocking behavior.
Please stop.
12 hours.
We won't make a cup of tea very shortly.
I'm sorry.
I'm getting delirious.
Miss Johnny,
can I be excused from the history of the Nordic class
to use the bathroom?
Yes, you're allowed to use the toilet.
Right, I am going to go make a cup of tea.
What?
Was that not supposed to be kidnapped?
After you perish?
Does it have to be about the island?
Huh.
Give her to her, kid.
It's after you receive a courier's lair.
Ah!
How are you streaming now?
How are you so powerful?
I'm not sure.
I don't know.
What are you streaming now?
How are you so powerful?
That is called autism.
And I love my games.
Right, I'm waiting on the courier.
Courier, courier.
Give me a letter.
Courier, my boss.
Right, ah, sorry.
I'm going to go get a cup of tea to recalibrate
because I have been playing for a hot second.
I'm going to have to pause the game sadly
because there can be NPC events
such as cultists entering the town
which can kill NPCs.
So I will have it paused
whilst I go quickly make a cup of tea.
Please do stretch your legs
and get yourself a wee water
and have a pee.
You've got to sleep.
No.
All right, sorry, man.
Yeah, I thought you had to sleep right away
but I need to receive the letter
with a hand that says we know
and then go to sleep, okay?
So go for a tinkle.
Go get some water.
I'm going to get a cup of tea
and we're going to recalibrate
and come back and meet in the middle.
It will be a couple of minutes, okay?
I think I can get a wee snack.
Right, I'll be right back.
Good night.
Welcome to Europe.
Oh, wait, I said that wrong.
Welcome to Europe, young man.
Remember that 10-year-old vision?
Oh.
Sorry, that was the worst Dutch I think I've ever done so far.
I do apologize to any...
...Nederland-Mensen who are listening in.
But everyone else is just like,
what on earth are you even on about?
Hi.
Welcome back.
What, you thought I was gone forever?
I've got me a cup of tea,
and I've actually got strupewafel.
I'm not even kidding.
I have actual strupewafel.
I was supposed to eat it on the rating stream,
but I couldn't find any more European snacks.
So I'm just literally going to eat a little strupewafel.
Welcome back.
I love...
Strupewafel is like crack cocaine.
Sorry, but it's not.
Sorry, but it's so good.
Um...
Yes, mercy for the snippets who are lurking.
I appreciate you, even if I'm not your flavor.
Um...
Tea minus one hour and 40 minutes until your...
Kohai is ready to say hi-hi.
And prove that she can't whistle.
Which is adorable.
I can't believe I hired her on the basis she can't whistle.
Stop leaving a...
What? I'm not allowed to go get a cup of tea?
For my boys?
What do you mean?
You like hearing my words?
Like all cranky?
Yeah.
Are you ending when mercy comes on?
Yes, I'm going to redirect into her on purpose
because I didn't know I was getting monetization today.
So tomorrow we're doing the monetization celebration.
So I need to set up like all the emotes
and I need to set up on the price.
And I think very sadly I have to freaking charge more than 4.99
and I really don't want to charge more than 4.99 US dollars.
But I think I might have to because of this YouTube gifting stuff.
Can any of yous confirm that YouTube gifting thing is a nightmare or a hassle?
I'm going to take a bite of my waffle.
I know it's only like 2 cents difference.
I just don't like that.
Hold on.
I'm going to check out marshmallows.
If you'd like to send me any marshmallows,
I'm just going to take a quick pause champ on top of everything.
Jesus Christ.
Why do I have so many DMs?
Okay.
I don't know.
Oh good.
For the most part.
Oh, and now I can't see my mouse again.
Okay, marshmallow refresh.
Let's go.
A lot of follow girls have 1.99 tier and then 4.99 and the gift goes to the 4.99.
Would exactly 5 dollars work?
I possibly.
Hello mummy.
You're asking what software baby uses for 3D.
It's called Warudo for full body tracking.
There's a lot of videos about it.
But I think most YouTubers use Sony MoCopy,
SlimeVR or Vine trackers.
Okay, okay.
It's okay mummy.
I know you can't open my last Mario link on stream.
Don't forget to check later.
Is it bad that I check?
Like as soon as I go offline,
I just spend like another 30 minutes and I'm like, yeah.
What's the problem with gifting?
So the issue is if someone is very kind to gift,
but they can't dictate what type of tier to give,
it means outsiders isn't a nice term to use.
That's not the correct term.
But someone who maybe...
What's the word?
I'm trying to think.
Someone who gets access to membership streams
that should name.
You know, like someone who's just going to be rude about it
or whatever.
I don't know.
Yeah, use whatever.
It's better to have people watching the membership streams
that are actually interested
because someone might get a message
and it's like, oh right, okay.
You might be able to turn on gifting entirely.
Well, the problem is gifting is a massive money source
for the girls.
If someone's going to be a shitter in members' content,
they better be paying out their own pocket.
Ah, that's so funny.
I'm sorry, but that's actually such a funny statement.
Okay, Strani and fellow reeflings.
I'm going to have a fun rest of the stream.
Oh, now I need to go.
Sorry, fucking words are blending together.
I'll see you tomorrow.
Yes, I think it'll be roughly two hours.
It's a short stream tomorrow, do apologize,
but I'm needing overall vocal rest.
I've got quite a few VTuber ASMR collabs coming up,
so I'm needing to be a good girl and rest and try my best.
I am a Spanish reefling and I've been very...
No, you've not.
Hold on.
You've helped me pass some hard times,
so I just want to know that if you're really proud of you
your streams go...
Also, I like how you act on stream about gapping
and ranking burps is fun.
Se te quiera.
What is se te quiera in espaol in English for me,
because I don't know what se te quiera means.
I think it means.
I don't even know.
You are truly an anomaly.
I've never seen someone who is so intensely thoughtful
in caring about both your daughters and reefillings.
Yeah, also shameless.
Hold on.
What am I getting?
What am I getting spanked by?
It's a level of authenticity.
I would never...
I would never even see in a person,
let alone a VTuber.
I wish you all the success in the world.
Wow.
You did an absolutely fantastic job
on the tryharding in the ASMR stream.
I can only assume you have a really good coach
since it took me over a year to study to get to that level.
A coach?
Like a hypno coach?
No.
That's just called autism.
In general interest.
I just apply what I like to whatever
and I do it my way.
Also, it's something I would never do otherwise,
but my...
But my girlfriend has convinced me
I should do...
Bibbius?
So I've printed out 21 pages
so I can build some additional cognitive habits.
I made a collage by the end of the month.
What?
What is this?
Well...
What are these additional cognitive habits?
What is this?
21 Bibbius?
For me?
You have that in you?
Right now?
It's almost 5 am.
Yes, please rest well.
For those of you who are hanging on by a thread,
we're just going to start off the Dark Brotherhood
at this point.
I'm going to see if I can fix achievements
and possibly we can come back to Skyrim,
but tomorrow is being steamrolled
by monetization celebration stream.
Gotta get those micro plastics out of you somehow, honestly.
Hey Lassie, would you kindly raise the model up
so you can see more of the girlies?
You could zoom out a bit too
if you don't want to block too much of the game.
Someone said they don't like it.
Where is it?
I would have to go like this.
Does this work?
Hold on.
Does that work?
It does work.
That's terrible.
I can't really get away with it too much.
Let's behave.
A tomato a day keeps the other boys okay.
Yes, that is our new slogan, ladies and gentlemen.
Tomato a day keeps the other boy else okay.
I'm still trying to eat the same strip waffle.
I'm getting so distracted.
So when's the audio of you rambling about assassin's greed
or something while getting your...
Oh my god, you guys are getting our while.
I'm actually doing a review.
On Assassin's Creed Brotherhood
which should come out around November.
Like I'm doing an actual game review footage.
Like I'm being so serious on it.
So if you like hearing my accent putting you to sleep
well I can tell you about Assassin's Creed
and how amazing it is.
Sometimes I wish we could see the film.
They're pretty outrageous.
I'm trying my best to like dart around them.
But good night rest well those who need to rest.
I love Strauner's The Cuttlefish in this hoose.
Strauny, if you like V&N games, kind of reckon Valhalla is such a good game
and I think you'll like it.
I most certainly will check that out.
I may have in another life thought I was about to play it
and then play the complete wrong game
which was called Helltaker I believe.
And it was also a puzzle game
and I was so confused on why the game looked so different
to what I was playing
and it turns out I was playing the completely wrong game.
But yes, I would love to give Valhalla a try.
Hi cuttles, are Mondays and Tuesdays always going to be endurance?
No, they are not.
It's just a Quinky Dink really that I put on Monday and Tuesday.
But no, they're not always going to be the endurance on those days.
Yes.
Having you laugh about to...
Are you squiddin' me right now?
By the Pope!
I'm going to be so honest.
Brian did not help with my confusion
on the pronunciation of your name, tiny spainy.
What?
And you had it right.
As spainy is pronounced like a spainy anteater.
A spainy anteater or a spiny anteater.
Brian just made that ten times worse
and I do apologize if I'm now officially butchering it
but thank you for the tip.
Do it phonetically in chat.
Right, so it's either spainy
or did I even spainy?
So, you know.
Spainy.
Okay.
We got there in the end.
Literally, I'm renaming everyone who just doesn't have an easy to rename for me.
Spiny.
There are Wednesday, Thursday, Friday, Saturday and Sunday endurance streams.
Yes.
Mostly the stream stipend.
I'll try and do for like a big amount of time
because I know not everyone's available
at the one time zone, if you will.
Having you up about developmental psychology
and socially inculcated reactions to stress
made me realize I really wish that physical touch and affection
was more normalised in society.
Especially for men, male socialised people.
People need more hugs these days.
Also, I'm curious how you deal with the stress
and she mentioned you don't know how we do it.
I always have a goal or something to work towards
which helps distract me from what I'm feeling in the moment
and essentially makes me numb and work through it
so right now my goal is to help the girls achieve what they want.
So I'm like, even though I'm stressed
and I'm worried and I'm this and I'm that
because they are a much more important focus on my life
it's kind of one of those things where I can just put it to the side for now
and right, okay, what's next?
Once I get offline, I have some lovely VTubers
who are waiting on an ASMR collab from me.
I have to send away shorts for the girls.
I need to record that for them.
I need to do...
Every word is hard to pronounce.
If you're bad enough, for example, I pronounce spatula, spatula.
Honestly, I think having a purpose is really useful in general.
Yes, I agree with that, I also do it that way.
It's so tough to tackle men's socialisation
because where does it start?
It starts in the home, but then where does it get affected?
Secondary socialisation at school.
I don't know if you guys had this, but in Scotland
it became so quickly, oh that's gay, to show any affection
in any sense, in a basic hug, a basic handshake
rubbing shoulders against each other.
If you're both gay, you get, you get, and it starts from there
and then that isolation progresses further and further
to the point where the most natural thing,
which is a reassuring hug or embrace when you meet someone you know
becomes this almost taboo, unfamiliar territory.
And it is such a shame that you even have to experience that
because of the secondary socialisation, because your primary socialisation
which is your family, you know about your dad came home
and you gave him a big hug, like oh dad, and when you went and visited
your grandparents, oh granddad, grand, and gave him a wee kiss
and a wee hug and all that, and it all goes out the window
because of secondary socialisation.
Yet behind closed doors, behind closed doors, behind families
perfectly normal, absolutely normal behaviour
and it's very frustrating because to even think of how to tackle it
where do you even start?
Because the way it's set up is it's your fault
on an individual level that you can't do these things
that you can't hug your bro that you meet up with once a month
and you can, it's your fault because
you didn't keep up with that societal norm, you didn't break the moat
you, like see how it's so hard to break from society's grasp at that point?
Someone says how's the game going? I'm so sorry, I'm currently in a rant about
the social education that you get after, I'm freaking going on a rant again
I can't stop, I can't stop myself, it's fascinating stuff
when you start to really break it down, it becomes almost
frustrating when you realise how bare bones and simplistic humans
are in nature and yet we are, pardon me, sorry, I'm burping away
we are our own biggest enemies
we live in a society, literally, I'm typing that too
we live in a society
that's it, I'm typing that in chat, that's me getting it out there
we live in a society, get that out, get that off your chest
you're welcome to type we live in a society as well in chat to get it off your chest
because we do live in a society
we live in a society, therapy stream when?
oh I'm not sure I can do that, Mercy's actually doing
a terrible therapy advice stream
we live in a society
wait, yes
wait, yes, that, sorry, I just read that
refling that was like your toes did everything for me, you're welcome
after this stream
tonight, with all the conspiracy talk, I need you to do
conspiracy theory talking stream with Pippa, it would be incredible, love your yapping
I just can't wait to get enough of the adorable cut of it, oh I don't know if I would go too far
I've not had a chance to watch Pippa's content in a very long time
but I don't know if I would go too far and I'm like
I, my ideas are quite
alienating, like as much as we were meming on needy streamer overload
my
I know you're not really supposed to talk about any of that, you're supposed to be a tee hee
but yeah, I'm thinking you never know
I plan on writing a fairly long fantasy of mine
I've had of you, it's still cringe, I want to write it though as it was extremely
pent up after you did it, is pace been fine for this
yes, I recommend it
oh no, strong is a moon truth, oh god what's that, I don't even know what that is
I don't know if I'd go too far, she says when talking about the yabba
it would be a race to see who will go too far, you're a Pippa
I'm like, I'm probably
1984 dystopian type
allegations, I don't know what
Pippa's field is in particular
but I am dystopian based, whatever horrors of man made comprehension you
can think of, have occurred, you know, I'm like that
kind of side of things, can you please say in the thickest
Thailand accent
I cast tongue positional
awareness, sorry that was a really rough accent but there you go
what's your favourite, Pringles favour
paprika, I love Pappangles, Pippa is there
and lizards are in government, literally 1984, Shawnee Calls
Pippa is just
psycho, she'll go way too far quicker
well we shouldn't egg her on, how about we just leave this as
moon truth or believes the moon is a hologram
is a conspiracy theory made up to clown on
that people actually started, well
I have terrible news, I'm afraid I don't meet much of the requirements of a conspiracy
theory, I'm afraid that yes, our planet is in fact
very controversial, I know
it's okay, it's okay, you can unsubscribe
at least it's not Fahrenheit 451 yet
right?
yeah, Fahrenheit 451
yeah
I guess if the reason why
a lot of media before
a certain year was kind of scrubbed on a mass level, so people realise
people don't know that in every 100 years
I try to get a sense of that
true, Iron Reaver true
right, imagine burning books
you're a round airther unsubbed, I can't believe it
the moon round, the sun round
the earth on a turtle's back and world of warcraft
that's all I'm saying
the earth is round, oh wait isn't it not like a, there's like a certain name
because it's like a wonky round and not a perfect round
something like that
have I shared any bibboots?
I actually don't share them with the girls
just because
I don't know I just, it's never really occurred to me to do such a thing
an oval lumpy ball, yeah a lumpy ball
remember to check your balls regularly
find a lump, get it checked out ladies and gentlemen
and before you go, it's embarrassing
I assure you the person who is doing the ultrasound on your boss act
has already looked at about 10 sacks that day already
and within that week has probably seen over 100
I assure you your wristicles raggy are not that unique
get yourself checked out if you are worried
an ultrasound, yeah that's what they do against your
if you have a bump you get an ultrasound on your
wristicle, raggy
that's not the thing, isn't that an ultrasound? I checked I'm clear
I mean we could check live if you want
wow I zoomed through the backlog at 2x speed after hearing
back where you read my marrow
I found a lump and they have no idea what it is
some things can be completely benign
like you know we all come out a bit wonky
can you come out 100% a perfect specimen now
it's definitely thing had me balls all just sounded clear
if you really want to, yeah right okay everyone follow my
do your hands have calluses, rougher smooth feet question mark
I have what's called hyper hydrosis
especially in my feet and I do have it in my hands
which means my hands are always very
smooth I have no dryness because I am constantly
wet really
there's nothing else to go off by but yes I always have like
kind of moist hands so they're always soft
my feet are incredibly soft so yeah
there you go now you know I was actually going to do a donathon reward
where I give the like for a second and third place
like thigh highs that I've worn but obviously with my sweaty feet
constantly they're not like dripping not dripping I don't need
Botox if you didn't know Botox will paralyze the
sweat cells but they are constantly
having like a
they're not dry put it that way most guys hands are like
dry so when you go like when you rub your hands together it's like
but when I rub my hands well when I put my hands together I can fart
with my hands because they're always clammy and wet and
yeah that's very true I can always do that
do it on command I can never find this
most called flushed that most called flushed
I can do that breathe it in lads and lasses well you are a cuttlefish
I'd be concerned if you were tonight you're so talented sweaty hands aren't fun
yes but it's a little bit annoying especially gaming with a
controller because of the heat transfer it reflects straight
back and my hands get very sweaty when I'm using a controller
fart hands game when your hands are dry just hold Chinese
I have enough sweat to make your hands nice and soft as well
okay there's enough to go around I assure you
don't read this out loud
oh my god I'm getting intel I'm getting intel
I know you said you wouldn't ever approach other
v-tubers but considering the similarity of line of work would you ever consider a collab
with project melody both of you seem very knowledgeable and passionate about
positive A in education mental health I feel like you would be great for us
I would never say no
but at this point in time you know
I'm just gonna focus on getting the girls like their achievement stuff
I would never say no but like to reach out is quite
you know daunting I'm sure anyone can kind of relate to that kind of
thing
yeah I would never say no a lot of people said that
me and project melody seem to be like
opposites and yet the same type thing with their kind of care and all that jazz
reefing intelligent agency since you have hyper hydrolysis
do you keep yourself well hydrated the way that I can tell
I'm actually severely dehydrated as my hands go dry
that's when I know I'm like up
creek basically as if my hands stop my feet will never
stop I have never been aware of my feet stopping
sweating look at me I was always so
embarrassing as well I don't know if you guys have school dance
but I used to like rub my hands on my trousers like really quickly before
like and I'm sure I bet you my dance partner like whoever you got on the
day felt like I was doing it on purpose like oh boy
and it's like no I have a really bad sweat problem I don't want anyone to know about
it he he
she's just like me for real for real
your nerdy and yappy and intensively
he he he
I've never been to a school dance oh I guess maybe
not every country does it but we had to learn like
Scottish traditional dance like the gay garden did you say the gay garden
yes gay isn't happy ha ha ha we get it we're
called gay garden which means happy dance
never been to a school dance can't relate
I have hyperdologists too so I'm constantly dehydrated
had school dance here in New Zealand it was similar
hmm because I hate having to wipe my hands
hi
hey strongy question what sort of maros would you hate to receive
I don't know
I
what would I hate to receive
I don't know nothing really
gets me like I can't even think of an example
I don't know maybe like ask me to finish a game I didn't finish or something
or be like you suck at this game oh oh my heart you've got
me I can't believe it I can't believe I didn't finish every single game I've ever started oh you
call me like I don't I don't know I can't think of an example
me I think the force this is
some sad dances at some point in primary middle I went to a school
dance but there was not a specific dance I had to learn ah never went
to a dance but always to the after party ooh ballin
everyone quick tried to get under her skin why would you want under my skin
you'd rather be
I would say in it but hold on a minute that doesn't sound right
well hold on a minute there
you suck at Skyrim
when you're gonna finish it oh oh you've got me
oh tell me how bad I am at the RDA side oh
oh you've got me I can't believe it right I should probably drink my tea and then we'll jump back
into Skyrim that's right the tunes are on tunes are on
mm okay I'm hydrating I'm hydrating
mm-hmm
she doesn't even know how to chase the RDA oh you've got me I didn't know to put the
grenade launcher on oh who would have thought
a grenade launcher
I can't believe it I'm being I'm being dunked on
ah
I would probably say the thing that would genuinely upset me the most
is if someone sent me something nasty about the daughters
and obviously if that starts appearing in the inbox
I know it's like not to pay heed but it's probably the worst thing I can
imagine but I would then again it was like well you're subjecting me to
not them so yeah
that's what it is
I like how she goes idle she hitting my eyes
well it's actually for hunting
but I think it can be used for a distraction
as well before I ink on you I just ink on you and run away like what you're gonna do
about it literally before you can even react I'm already gone
eh
do you ever play a follow game do you go for stats or stay list oh stats
I absolutely cannot for the life of me
by the pope
no way miss Morgan
that's hilarious that's hilarious
congrats on getting back hopefully work went
well and it wasn't too painful or perishing that's absolutely
hilarious thank you for the tip
inks on you leaves refuses to elaborate like an absolute
chattel fish that's right chattel fish I'll take that title she
blasted on me and ran away what if I ink faster than you
one minute 56 I think beat that good luck like you
can't you literally can't beat that record I'm sorry
okay I finished
okay right let's see about actually getting oh wait no I was
in Skyrim but I need to turn my controller on
strongy go to sleep
strongy no I'm gonna sneeze I'm gonna sneeze
okay there we go
right where are we heading I need to get a letter
so I'm going to do some sight first thing
my ears oh sorry I forgot I'm allowed to sneeze
my apologies hopefully that wasn't too bad
do you like being a black sniff no I want to
sell what have you got for sale
if I could give you a tissue oh no no I just wiped my snot on your hoodie
I don't need a tissue just give me your hoodie don't be shy
give me your hoodie give me your hoodie bring it over
right I'm not gonna sell that that's silly
alright just use my sleeve she certainly started my thing
I lost my twin sister a while back
how did you manage to finish that early
mmm you know
guys aren't the only one that might have a bit of the
preem
I'm a bit of a fiend for it
so
it is what it is I can't get this quest started
don't want to do that one retrieve the
sure we can do that we'll go retrieve the glove whilst we get the courier to
do his thing the glove the horn
how much would you guys pay for that hoodie
the convention I'll snot on it for free just bring grass pollen
or flowers and I'll be sneezing away I'm like really allergic
to that stuff can't go outside
which is funny because I have like a seed collection
which I really enjoy but of course seeds don't have pollen issues on them
although collecting them sometimes can have traces of pollen but it's not really a big deal
like if you know what you're doing
okay okay okay our first dragon
come land okay it's just a basic dragon
please land please land
oh
of course it resisted soul trap it's a dragon
I'm the freaking soul gem for the dragon
I don't know why we're pretending otherwise
hold on
I had just emptied like all of my inventory only to pick
all of that up again
that was quite a reaction wait what did I do
did I make a funny seed collection yeah you didn't see my
stream yesterday I showed off my seed collection I like when I
were in mud crab down
I obliterated that dragon's one ankle I know
I smashed it into dust and he was like okay I'm done I'm done here
hmm
wow that was really easy what a bad dragon
thank you
no no you don't have to tell me twice I'll
keep cracking these jokes all day long
are you nerd about your seeds I can do like an actual informal
informational stream I think there's four ways of seed dispersal
air, hook, berry
is there one more is it
chubbers like strawberries and potato
I think I need to beat the absolute yeah I need to beat everything
oh one shot I love
when they're one shot oh my gosh
right stop yeah don't do that again do you understand me
do you understand me good boy
because don't do that again
the fourth is cranking hit the front
yeah yeah yeah tomato tomato wait what
oh that drogger just absolutely
oh my god this is getting very
loud I don't know how loud it is for you guys this is like
in my ears it's all the sound effects going off right now
okay this way this way is my guess
hello
goodbye hello
goodbye hello goodbye
oh no that's not it
this is the opposite of ASMR thank you
turn down the volume after this turn down the volume
uh audio
turn it down a bit more
ooh
more damage and a soldier
I need to enchant that one are we good boys because we are
reeflings or are we reeflings because we're good boys
uh ow the skeleton's always do that
huh oh no you turned
into like oopsies well I've committed now
hit that one there should be a
soldier on the outskirts
I knew it
so captured that is a
okay I never made it in time but that's okay
you can just go this way if you really don't want to do the fight
Lydia should actually clean up any enemies
oh I'm getting so many soul gems
we're gonna make so much money selling all the enchanted jewellery
what's going on in here
I can never remember I think there's something back there
I hit
oh my god I'm getting so many fricking soul
might as well call this game Jart please
what's that one do
I don't even remember the odds literally the very thing that I'm here for
well not here for because I'm actually doing a quest but
sure take the darker
200 feels so good literally
right so I can enchant this possibly
with soul trap and then give it a
greater soul gem greater
and then the other stuff will just shove anything on it
doesn't really matter as long as we just get some
XP yeah we're at 44 already
which is fantastic
just shoving anything on it
and these are worth a lot so as our
speech goes up we get even more money as time goes on
okay
no I don't actually believe this is from
software action RPG Dark Souls actually
can you say enchantment like sandal from da
I'm so sorry you're gonna have to
jog my memory sorry Lydia you were right in my way yet again
dragon age
I haven't played dragon age I'm so sorry
I do apologize
yoink my soul no
okay this is good
I like this
there's another one yoink my soul no
and last but not least
yoink unless Lydia wants to do the honors
you okay yeah you okay
do me do me right there's a word of power
down here you do have to go the long way around
I'm new here and you're so gorgeous oh thank you
people say I have watermelon here
uh but yeah thanks for
hanging out I'm strongy I'm gonna match that I can't believe I haven't
introduced myself I'm strongy I'm Scottish
so I'm not the easiest to understand we're currently just meming around
on Skyrim because I was originally gonna do an achievement run
but my achievements aren't even working for some reason even though I'm on
class so we are gonna redirect in one hour into
a gen mate of mine who's a yandere so if you got a thing for yandere
you'll be screaming for mercy either way
oh wait sorry you'll be screaming for mercy either way
oh thank you thank you
alright right how do I do this
oh I hit the wall hit the wall literally
oh okay I'm okay I don't know how I got away with that but I was lucky
alright these are fire plates but honestly because I'm
on because I'm such a super skilled gamer at legendary mode they don't hurt me
the way they would hurt you if you were on legendary it's okay
it should be a spider yeah right on cue
right on cue
oh look all these souls
I've seen a butter and jay the long way
I find it very easy to understand thank goodness because I make effort to
annunciate should be here all evening folks
or at least for the next hour Brian
I'm a tintin fish
yeah thank you for the tip iron report
turning me German at this rate what's going on here
okay no what is that
I really do not recall that ever
occurring but sure whoever
right mysterious no
dragonborn I need to speak to you urgently
Randy attic room at the sleeping giant and in river mid and I'll meet you a friend
a friend you yoinked my horn
give me that you don't deserve it give me them riches
give me them
major grip that's what I need
I'll be wearing gloves of major grip at the convent right enough enough
too many jokes too many jokes
I'm getting out outrageous I'm getting out of
what is sad your German is better than some people
thank you for over 10 years
the only German tick tock I know is like these people in the supermarket
and it's like they are doing
skits and the guy goes babe when it scans the item
and then they always say something I never have any idea what's going on
but they always go bitter bitter diner bitter bitter bitter
like bitter has so where am I going
almost bitter has like so many different things
it's all they say
in your case wouldn't bits of major grip be better
what am I planning to do with my feet I need to be firmly planted to the
ground at the convention what's going on here
oh the German
tongue twister
the rhubarb custard thingy
I know exactly what you mean
there are enemies nearby
where go and then who wants some
I don't know bandit
give me that
are you
oh you think my feet can't keep me to the floor
by myself oh I completely
forgot that happens when you loot someone's like
clothes that was I do apologize for that one
I caught me by surprise even though I've done it
a few times now
good thing you don't have a mod yeah this might play vanilla
I would have probably forgotten
finally
okay we do the brotherhood
from who
okay we're going to go back to the brotherhood
roll probe we'll stay the night in white run so we can listen to ragnar the red
hey chat have you been leveling up
I've been getting distracted if that's what you're talking about
cultist orders no many things
no mysterious no
no okay the other mysterious no we know
oh no
do they know
they know oh no
okay let's see if we can listen to ragnar the red
I want ragnar the red
are you the bard
ready
wait can I sit on the bench
yeah shush shush everyone I want to hear
one once was a hero named ragnar the red
who came riding to white run from horde warwick said
oh for goodness sakes shush
there is no possible goal that he made
but when he went quiet did ragnar the red
shield maiden Matilda who said
oh you talk and you lie and you drink or meet
now I think it's high time that you lie down and bleed
slashing of steel is the brave last Matilda
changing full of zeal
both will no more win
with ugly red head roll the red on the floor
can I give you money
because you took my tip because you took my request
oh okay well that's a shame
we did it right I would like one room please
he just walks away literally I'm like do you know one
money like I just made a specific request and you did it like
oh I'm stuck why am I stuck okay that was odd
right time to go to sleep and totally not be kidnapped
I mean smile
shut up and take my money
my friend used that song for one of our classes and got an A
he yanked it and then submitted it as his own
that's actually really smart
well where am I and who are you
does it matter you're warm dry and still very much alive
that's more than can be said for old grailard
oh half of skyrim knows
old hag gets butchered in her own orphanage things like that
tend to get around oh but don't misunderstand
I'm not criticizing it was a good kill old crone had it coming
and you saved a group of urchins to boot
but there is a slight
did we make a oopsie whoopsie a problem
you know boy was looking for the dark brotherhood
and my associates
grilard the kind was by all rights a dark brotherhood contract
a kill that you stole
you must repay
well now funny you should ask
if you turn around you'll notice my guests
um well that's not really important
here and now that's what matters
you see there's a contract out on one of them and that person can't leave
this room alive but
there's a contract to see if you can figure it out
hmm make your choice make your kill
I just want to observe and
we will use our interrogations all right I'll do it I'll kill
one of them see I knew we could resolve this
civilly a debt owed must be repaid
you understand well we want to kill the spree now we'll become serial killer over now
pick your guest and send the poor fool to the void
I'll give you the key to this shack and you'll be on your way curious
okay the with friends
like the kill one of the captives let's have a little talk
I can hear you talking out there please let
me go with someone paid to have you killed
what oh god I don't want to die
uh don't be afraid
you can tell me okay well I guess it's
possible I've been selling my sword arm for years now
it kills a lot of people
could be someone wanted revenge but
shibi and the harem they're coming
we're totally not about to perish someone but it's okay so who are you
my name is fulltime I'm a soldier
he's a sell sword
hi harem hi shibi how was her yapping stream
nobody really so can't you just let me go
well no but thank you we now have sell sword
what do they do
who are you
hmm high quality yapping stream from shibi
that's why I like to see baby
we are interrogating three people
we're to perish one of them to fulfill a contract
with someone paid to have you killed alia
excuse me what kind of question is that
it's alright just tell me what I need to know
I'm a woman living in Skyrim with six children and no husband
I don't have the time of the patience to be nine
six children it's me wait no five children
okay
and you
hi yo how's shibi
we're currently doing the dark brotherhood quest
maybe you are your own child
obtainer of goods
why would you admit that
and would someone pay to
have you killed vasha
come on you can tell me
we're all friends here
the real question is would someone pay to have me killed
again
8 day goes by without someone trying
this reminds me of my dungeon
this place reminds me of the dungeon the blood everywhere and all the cages and things
right if you don't know who to
perish I'm gonna show you a trick
wait am I being dumb
doesn't that normally cast a path
am I going crazy
does that not
wait I could have sworn if you
did that it leads to the guy
turn around
oh it's just telling me wait is that
because hold on hold on hold on hold the
phone hold it right now in your hand hold it in your hand right now
hold pause
there that's how you know who you're supposed to kill
now it doesn't actually matter who you kill as long as someone
perishes but there you go
that's how you know who you're
supposed to perish
that was sure to have enemies
remain silent we know we did right
when most would speak you listen
you understand that the only thing that matters is you following my orders
to kill
you could perish Astrid oh no so I'm free to go
and you've repaid your debt in full
but why stop here
I say we take our relationship to the next level
I would like to officially extend to you
an invitation to join my family
in the southwest reaches of Skyrim
in the pine forest you'll find the entrance to our sanctuary
it's just beneath the road hidden from view
silence my brother
I'll see you at home
Curious Astrid Curie oh Lydia you're not supposed to be in here
more like Lydia I'm sorry
I know I said I was going to read in a mercy
and I really want to I really do but I'm really into the dark brotherhood quest
oh there's enemies nearby hold on
identify yourself scanning area
say that again please
just more slowly wait what did I say
Lydia was waiting outside so you didn't have to enter
can I travel now
then you go to Falkreath
don't forget to rest your voice
right speed run right school are you squidding me right now
could I get an ever elusive strongy good girl please
oh no I feel embarrassed though
my voice isn't good enough for that
good girl oh it's weird hearing in my Scottish voice
you're a good girl oh I'm so embarrassed
thank you for the tip Miss Morgan
oh my god wait
who's a good girl
oh my voice cracked nah this is cringe hold on hold on
it's you isn't it
so it's time for your reward
silence my brother
thank you
I'm like oh god
I'm like really appealed to a girl before now you're getting me all embarrassed
what the heck
this is my first time
Emmy greeting pen pals
I feel girly oh yeah you feel girly
mmm
should we go ahead with the EOE that sentence
you took her first
oh I like that
I'm honored to be a part of the family Astrid
oh we're about to meet
the girlies are winning this one the night
I'm arranging a job
but need a bit more time for now
I forgot about this part of the brotherhood quest line
soon the night mother will arrive
and things around here are sure to get even more interesting
we have to basically
the armor of the dark brotherhood
may it serve you well in all your endeavours
do filter requests
I think
me and the boys hello
do the part where he tries to buy you some candy
okay okay wait here we go
hello girl
oh yes have us in shock
my mom and papa left me all alone
and I'm so very hungry
I know a shortcut to the candy shop through the valley
oh yeah very good very good
mine is dark down here
no
I'm not that tall I'm not that short
you think I'm that small compared to everyone
oh yes please old man
let me see the dark brotherhood can help me
always mocking the experience
my contract went very well
wait I was either the wrong way around
this close to turning that priest inside out
damn messy
what of your latest armbion
something about a khajiit merchant
oh a big dog you say something I'm not kidding
how adorable
he's even in the workplace
he wasn't a merchant he was a khajiit monk
a master of the whispering fang style
I think it may not be on scale
workplace bullying
can't wait to have to go to HR and report all of that
we learned
per kill mark of death
swindling dysfunction
a little family
toxic work environment love
you will hear even more I assure you
I wish I had one I'm sorry
I like to unize you
but who knows I've been proven wrong before
Astra said you've got some work for me
nah?
loin cloth sniff
dribbling in from time to time
wait what you don't have one wait you have one
since simple enough
these aren't particularly glamorous assassinations I'll be honest
don't pay much either but they'll keep you busy
just do them as you're able there's no real time limit
the targets aren't going anywhere
okay
wait so what now
did you get me them
I'm ready for the first set of contracts
okay thank you thank you thank you stop
no more talking thank you
probably gonna miss the end of the stream goodnight
I am just doing
be the brotherhood yeah
and then
where are you just gonna go to freaking dawn star
yeah we're not really doing anything
so please don't worry about going to sleep
what
okay
wait what does it say
oh consider adoption wanted a good home
in these days of born strife the orphans of skyrim are the true victims many have no one left
to turn to and face the life of hard labour poverty and misery
if you could provide a stable home from one of these innocent children please consider adoption
so adopt from us or take in someone closer to home
you can make a difference in a child's life for more information inquire within
Constance Michelle Honorary Hall Riften
okay that is a very nice note she definitely is taking
care of those children a bit more
yes we are just going for a cheeky stab
there should be someone in a tent over here
um
I don't know if we could
I could have sworn you can speak to this person and they recognize you as someone from the dark brotherhood
but they don't do anything about it I'm like 99% sure
why are you here get away from me
you are right to be paranoid
oh
oh shit I missed
wait hold on
okay maybe I thought he didn't run away
but I guess he did right how do I get to
I'll just take I'll just go westward from here
time to adopt six children for gender oops
let's not talk about gender
oh no
I love that actively
I love that actively when you talk like when you do stuff in Skyrim
like the NPCs kind of discuss it I think that's such
a cool little detail I have to admit for a game for a game
that came out in 2011 and was produced like before that
that's pretty that's pretty decent you know
are you gonna give it to them sometimes can't can't give them all the credit
but you gotta give it to them sometimes unfortunately I believe we
do we have to go south no we don't I'm just taking
super long obnoxious way so I'm going to teleport back
and then I'm basically just gonna go along the war's edge to get to this dawn star
death is highly over here
infamous last words
so warhammer stuff literally oh you didn't see it coming
just imagine how cool Skyrim 2 will be
um did they even
announce it yet or am I going crazy and they have jeez how do I
get down oh I've not just done that have I
that'll be fine that'll be fine on the old ankles right
maybe this will do yeah easy easy just edge it a little bit
nice and slow slowly
slower good boy
that's terrible I shouldn't do that
you shouldn't ache me on either
Elder Scrolls 6 is in development
okay okay I could have sworn
they hardly freaking talk about the damn thing I can't
oh my god literally it's too easy the problem is you give me too
much power and then I get high on it and I just do it all the time
I'm not being funny that girl gave me far too much power
with me seeing them freezes excuse you
give me your soul
not oh I'm out of soul gems wait where the heck am I going
where the heck am I supposed to go straight ahead
into the water
why not get a horse it takes too long doesn't it
and the horse aren't even that fast don't you beat me up
I'll beat you up I'll smack you on your
ball head it is um I don't mind giving you the power
you're still going strong yes
sorry I am I am going to redirect into
mercy because unfortunately my achievements bugged out so
it kind of may or may not have defeated the whole purpose of this achievement
uh run uh man we keep running into Talos
literally he was like that snake was like uh and then he was like
yeah I don't care I can't I'm boss
bossing on me what if we weiflings get the power
anarchy very classic
bro you're actually making me blush
oh my god a girl me you like me
can't comprehend it can't comprehend it doesn't make sense
what do you mean the Scottish accent is not making you cringe at your boots
what do you mean truly truly too much power
Talos no see I'm literally I'm walking into Talos
with north west so I can't even
talk I'm getting flustered thinking there's a girl watching me with a
fuck okay right I'm just going to converse this straight off the bat
so I used to play Call of Duty and whenever there was like a girl on my team I used to get really
flustered and I couldn't even talk properly I don't know why I just like completely
clam up and I'm just like uh uh uh and I just get really like freaking terrible
about it so it's really I don't know why I still haven't come over
yet because I played a few rounds of valorant and it happened there was a girl on my team and I
couldn't speak at all and voice chat and I don't know what it is
and it's not even like I'm trying to like impress her or anything I just like get all weird
and like I don't want to bother her you know I'm being weirdo
I'm like it's not like I'm trying to like
pick someone up or anything and I'm like freaking Call of Duty I don't know why I get all clammed up
and it's happening it's literally happening right now in live stream and I'm like oh my god now everyone knows I'm a weirdo
and I'm like uh I'm freaking talking to wham this hard
better not better not speaking and starting
to say bad jokes she's just like the majority of guys
clamming up like basically every other
cod player of honestly
girls are steering
wait until she really so the reason
why it feels like it's different for valorant girls is because
like I'm not trying to
I'm not like trying to
you know get anything out of them no that sounds really odd that makes it sound like
I'm freaking honing in that sounds really odd hold on
hold on let me think anything
I can't imagine anything bad happening if we give one person all the power
thank you for the don't know iron reaper
again or the tip one of the other it's either the tip or the don't know
either you give me the tip or the D it's up to you your choice
call that a clam jam
scrawny clamming up
if speaking to women is hard then you sure are very talented at it
well I'm like freaking my hands are sweating now and I'm getting my
faces all red it's burning off I can feel it and I'm like oh my god I need to like
right hold on can I even
can I hurt you on your own balcony
no question mark
oh my god look at the way
that was my business oh I got detected oh yeah
I got detected get me up get me up
get me up not detected there is a sanctum here by the way for the don star
based off of yesterday's stream most of us can probably give you the tip
honestly didn't you say that your hands are always sweating
yes but I am I do have physical reactions
to like stressors and it can make them sweat even more my left hand is currently
soaked and my right hand I'm like touching my face
hi
hi sleigh saber
you know girl too are you I can't take anymore
I can't take anymore I'm losing it
yes right what was I saying
right cause the violour girls are like
it doesn't I don't have any it's not like I'm trying to do anything
I don't want to sound like I'm prederen
I can't freaking say a sentence anyway this is Skyrim it's a really good game it came out in 20
actually came out on November the 11th 2011
which is release date was 11 11 11 11
which was really cool little tidbit if you didn't know
I'm getting absolutely trolled right now
anyway
hi what do you want nothing I don't want anything
wait oh I got bounty added to me that's not good
that means the guards are always going to come up to me unless I clear the bounty
could you imagine you could start short
well that's why the plastic on like the controller in that is really good
for that issue I got seen
I fear for the girl refuelling
oh I see I didn't know you were there
oh my gosh I see that was terrifying
weee
this is the riskiest thing I've ever done do not go down a waterfall
whatever you do by the way that's a terrible choice right
can I teleport back to Mazeem
I can are you still playing on legendary yes I am
I never was not playing legendary at any point
I can show you again if you want
look a little to the left okay it's really cute that you're getting flustered
over this when every time you speak makes me flustered
what was I saying
thank you for the tip Miss Morgan I appreciate it
what was I showing oh yeah I'm on legendary
look a little to the left see look see legendary
I've been on it the entire time
I don't know why anyone thinks I'm not on legendary for some reason the proof is right on screen right now
so it's rather odd
yeah see fair enough yeah
oh wait hold on oh look a little to the right again
where am I
oh I'm still running away from the guards the guards aren't chasing me
they can be I'm in the middle of a waterfall
the guards are chasing me
oh there's an in route let's go get the in route
thank you for the tip again Miss Morgan
I never doubt scrawny what you mean me
they have made legendary for scrawny specifically because the game was too easy
true true Andrea am I being
can I just teleport to my location
so I can progress with my campaign what is shooting bone
arrows at me is that Lydia is Lydia turned against me too
get me down the stream I'm a fish I'm actually a fish
get me this is literally what it looks like from the outside POV
you're just zooming down the rocks
can we teleport now
yes we can
she's just so good guys honestly
well I was going nope not at all
definitely a MLG gamer
and she tells you her problems because I'm so good literally I don't know why people seem to struggle
playing on legendary oh Cicero
are you squidding me right now
listen scrawny our Scots accent if one of few benefits of being Scottish
so use it to your advantage as much as you can
thank you for the tip Kitsune
use my Scottish accent to my advantage
even the night mother are of course welcome here Cicero
and you will be afforded the respect deserving of your position as keeper
understood
I think I may or may not be
rather submissive at the moment so I can't take a much to say
oh pardon me
putting out my weapon in the middle of a cutscene
I'll be clear on that point
oh yes mistress perfectly you're the boss
oh there you are
I was done speaking with that muttering fool anyway
we've got business to discuss do you have a contract for me
is this over for mash
and speak with the apothecaries assistant
you'll probably find her in the hags cure when the shoppers
why does Cicero sound like junk oh why would you say something like that
my name is Moeery
rip tie is ready to roll
I'll let you keep whatever Moeery pays
ah there you are
I was done speaking with that muttering fool
hello hello
it's good to meet you Cicero
just keep your distance Jester and we'll get along just fine it's good to meet you
so polite so nice Cicero likes you
the night mother is sure to like you too
oh we're going to be fast friends
why did you come to the sanctuary Cicero
the night mother's crypt in Bravil was
desecrated
my stripe nowhere there is safe at present
so Cicero brought our lady to her home
this is the only sanctuary left in all of Skye River
you see such was my
honour as keeper as keeper
how much did they spend on this freaking voice actor who's he nailed it
what are your duties of a keeper
look at yourself Cicero not about the night mother
or feeling submissive
you're such a good girl
thank you
oh Cicero was just the keeper
I look at love me
are you squidding me right now
would you like me more if I transitioned to a woman
have you got a pole
I want the pole if you've got a hole I want the hole
don't swap
you don't need a swap
the words
the listener what's a listener Cicero
the listener is the only person the night mother speaks to
Stroney's an equal opportunist are you squidding me right now
you dislike Cicero
oh you don't like his character
but inside the listener's head
I hear da but there has not been a listener in years and years
a lady has not chosen
I like to dislike Cicero
but Cicero's like trying to
stroney's such a good right you're done
collectively you're done
I was supposed to hand in the contract so I wasn't paying attention
thank you for the tip anonymous but no you got a pole keep the pole
don't be swapping stuff around
there's a whole other conversation that can come out of that
but we can't even get into that
we're going to very slowly hand over
all the freaking things
I love watching your long gaming sessions
that was lovely to be backdrop thank you for the tip I appreciate that
I'm glad I was worthy
to wait for after all this time
it had been a while
I have to make up for lost time
why do you want to eat me
I don't even thought about that
oh yeah I want to eat calamari
no you're not supposed to want to eat it
thank you for the tip pick one
I like how Lydia just respectfully hangs out
she's like yeah I'm not going to come in and solve my problem
thank you I appreciate it
there was a lot of
I don't know what the word is
I suppose emotional turmoil is a bit of a dramatic
lower
yeah I'm fine
he was shouting about the foreign swore
I think you dropped this
do you know anything
hello
the dark brother has come
we're here
I'd prefer it raw like sushi
we're not supposed to want to eat it
I'm glad because there was like
the emotional turmoil and a lot of bad memories came back to the surface
but they got completely manually overrated
just because of the love
and everything that we did
the girls and I couldn't have predicted anything at all
it was impossible to predict and we were dealing with
a major calling at the time which was really messing
with like how to predict anything at all
okay but what were we supposed to do with the fish
I can give explicit detail
would you like explicit detail
we love you love you little replay
please do someone says lick it
take the dirt
nice and easy
wait is there someone here I need to perish
wait did I read the map wrong
I think I might have read the map wrong
you hear about the story of a dude who put a fish in his pants
no I did not is this bad
am I supposed to perish her
she's so messed up are you okay
wait so why does
why does she have to be
cherished if it's optional I'm not actually going to do it because that's really mean
I have a perfect mean for the situation
cherish the fish worship the fish for all mortal positions
no that is nothing
why are you shooting
you've just attacked those bandits no wonder they're shooting
a little to the right
but I can forfeit the fish best I can forfeit to fish
no keep it
no give money to fish unless
is there even an unless
I don't even think there's really an unless in that scenario
it's not that one no it's up here
I'm not really sure if I'm going to be able to make it to this checkpoint
because I'm definitely not supposed to be coming up the sheer cliff face
of a mountain only give money if you can afford it
but even then I feel like there's so many attachments to it
and it's like only give it if you're financially stable only give it if you
are genuinely enjoying the content only give it if
you know you've treated yourself and
you've got savings and all that and you're looking after yourself like if you're
in debt or anything like that no it's a big no no
like you don't need to be donating to myself and I'm sure the VLRR
girls all agree with me like make sure you're
sorted out first make sure you're secure first like having a good time
I swear to god if I read any of the comments that go I'm living in a cardboard
box watching you on neighbor's wi-fi
stolen laptop because I don't have any more more
possessions of this world yeah yeah reflins I know your memes
I know your memes you're too
considerate give views to fish yes you are more than welcome
if you have the spare time and you don't have like other responsibilities
then fish you are welcome to watch fish
by the pope who goes there
okay Zaryn thank you for the tip
please do look after yourself guys because it is
important I don't I think I can just skip him to be honest I'm gonna just
skip him we don't need to fight you're so sweet so based if you do
that through through I actually live in the under dark
sorry what is the under dark
sorry sorry I know it's not a fair fight because you're relying down
okay that's really smart though are you squidding me right now who goes there
donating cause why not love you strongy keep doing what
you are doing cute fish anonymous oh my god my coffee
thank you anonymous for the tip or the D your choice
should we settle on the D or the tip
or is it funnier when I just mention both but thank you very much for
the tip I appreciate it way fish
give life lesson I will always give life lessons I
think it's very important to consider
life experience as an XP bar and when you talk to people and when
you get to hear other perspectives you are very slowly filling up that bar
and one a very big life lesson
can be hold on
hold on I'm wrecking and decking right now
even I have to admit that's pretty impressive
oh right okay well
you weren't really I thought okay that was really bizarre
is this book yes
do you also get XP but you also get XP for hurting people
what just wait until you find the one
butthole who's just enough XP to level up
oh no seriously I don't mean talking about
I can teach you guys about debt and how it works and how credit cards work
I genuinely believe credit cards are the absolute spawn of
Satan for lack of better words I absolutely
they're terrible and once you get sucked into them and you're uneducated in them
it's like obviously not part of your curriculum surprise surprise
I wonder why oh that's right we're going down the conspiracy theory holding
man like gee willikers I wonder why you're not told about
how to do your taxes properly I wonder how you're not told to financially
gee it's almost like the world runs if people are on debt because of the way
society is set up because we love capitalism
which is why I absolutely do not
want any like tips
or support you do not have to give me any monetary
for that kind of thing
oh literally I could go on a massive essay
about that kind of thing
shut the fuck up
and on shut the fuck up
you stream sleight of my cardboard box and on
and on bend over
bend over you're done
you're done you're absolutely done bend over
no I don't want to hear it I don't want to hear no
that's terrible don't say that there's a safety word what is it
thanks no we use that
I'm a cephalopod
I cephalopods on you
thank you anonymous for the tip
how went your first real contract
I only live to serve
oh very good very good indeed
you my dear are going to fit in here quite nicely
now I need your assistance with a matter of a more
personal nature
it's Cicero but it's worse than that
who is he speaking with what are they planning
astrid you're being paranoid I'll just remain silent
did she call us a good girl I think she said very well done
very I'm gonna burp
very well done really very well done
I'm in prayer
it'll be no use like
but that seems so disrespectful she's gonna put me in a coffin
put him in a coffin
I need to go I need to go hug skeleton mummy
mummy
strony would you kindly detail in the alt twitter what we are supposed to do
with the fish
actually yeah I really need to get on that
oh I have to lock pick the coffin
you can have just given me a key I have to lock pick into a coffin
oh thank you for the tips
and a warrior oh I'm sorry
mother do forgive me for this little shuffle
10 minute mercy reminder okay they got me flustered
are we alone
yes
alone
sweet solitude
no one will hear us disturb us
everything is going to plan
where should we do with the oyster
let me DJ okay
the unchilled
that's an interesting term for the vampire child
an unchilled
a non child
docking the seeing the seeing
nothing
not that I'm angry
oh never
this VA can't talk this
sister with voice actor
huh
okay
okay and
that was creative I'll give you that we're members of the thieves guild
it's night mother's voice thank you for the tip again
no no mama
the listener
oh but how can I defend you
I exert your will if you will not speak to anyone
but I will speak
my Xbox
always crashed at the night mother this scene
and the Embracer second scene always breaks on
Xbox 360 it doesn't matter what you do
shadow thief money gang we love stealing items
this task
where's the night mother's patreon
where's the difference between an American wall and a German wall
you punch a hole through the American wall
the German wall wants you to punch it again then it can break your other hand too
I don't get it
thank you for the tip I am repo
drywall versus a brick wall
are we making fun of American houses wait until we get started
about tornado alley wait a minute
that's not how geographical locations work
ah that's the roof
defiler
it's so good
speak worm
I feel like that doesn't speak worm
in my accent could you imagine I like catch you doing something
I'm like explain yourself speak worm
oh no that does not work at all the night mother spoke to me
she said I am the one I am the one the only one don't need a gun
to get respect up off the streets
lie
sister's video really didn't have to go that hard he's so good
it kinda works instant wait it works
what should my worm speak
my worm simply inks why is he jelly
wait she said to tell you darkness rises when silence falls
darkness rises when silence dies
she said those words
but those are the words
German walls are
25 to 30 centimeters thick
thank you for the tip again I am repo
appreciate it god damn you give me a lot of money
she's back
she has chosen her listener
she has chosen you
why did that humming mumbling sound remain me of sea bat
I'm so sorry I hum it
tornado alley is a conspiracy theory it's just UFOs stealing houses
and the night for insurance
whatever you've been planning is over
are you alright I heard the commotion who is Cicero talking to
reveal yourself traitor
I spoke only to the night mother
I spoke to the night mother but she didn't speak to me
she's in a little jake he's adorable
what the listener
it's true
the night mother has spoken
the listener has been chosen
Cicero's infectious with how happy he is
Reflings it's chosen it's chosen
I feel the worst are you alright
yes I'm fine I don't know what happened so fast yet the band
Cicero spoke to the night mother but she spoke to you
is this just more of the fools rambling
it's true the night Miller spoke to me she said I was the one the only one don't need
a gun to get respect up off the streets my enemies your enemies
we wet them off like a canteen
sorry Cicero wasn't talking to anyone else just the night mother's body
no to night mother
I like the scottish version
I'm the one the only one don't need a gun to get respect up off the streets
my enemies your enemies we wet them off like a canteen
yeah you like that
I hope nothing bad happens to Cicero
I must speak to someone named Armand
Motieri
I have no idea who that is
that I have heard of and I know where it is
should I go should I talk to the man
no no listen
I don't know what's going on here but you take your orders from me
I'll be clear on that
I am still the leader of this family
you're so easily dismissed
I need time to think about all this
go see Nazir do some work for him
I'll find you when I'm ready to discuss the matter
oh you are the one who served mother well
I have
oh well
aww her's gone
are we a street gang
Astrid feels the power slipping away
yeah
madame
but that was then this is now you're the listener and the night mother
chose you for a reason I'm sure Cicero will remain
aww
will the night mother speak to me again
I don't know
wait the listener is serious
sorry Cicero
well of course the night mother will speak to you again
she might speak now or later or I don't know
the night mother is part of you now
I'm not taking my man
real golden retriever energy
okay
oh wait do you have a new line for tell me
oh Cicero is just the keeper
I keep
aww he's like so happy
sorry to walk away mid conversation
you do be talking a lot those sisters
I think you're a bigger yapper than me and that's a hard title to
join off of me hi Nazir
sorry
Astrid wanted me to see you about some more work
what time is it
oh mercy's on
positive tunes
right I'm gonna see if I can get these
out with it woman
I'm going to see if I can fix these achievements
because there's really not a reason why they shouldn't be working
whatever tomorrow's stream is going to be
oh I can hear myself twice go away
is she live
what's she doing advice giving give me your troubles and I'll make them worse
that's honestly a hilarious concept
I might be doing that later down the line
I'm going to see if I can fix my achievements
that's not really the biggest thing issue ever
I will be
tomorrow I will be doing my monetization celebration stream
do I really have to make it $5
on the nose I really like the idea
it was $9.99 to support your wishy-dice but
why
oh my god no
true Seaf Guild master
thank you for the stream you're more than welcome thank you for hanging and I will redirect
into mercy
oh can you do a collab with the girls where you do a
round of terrible advice that would actually be quite funny I wouldn't mind
doing that
my collab is actually power washer sim where you get to see us all together
because someone not naming names, refling
guessed the entire reason why we're playing power washer first
out of all the games of course you had to figure out what the freaking plot was
but yes
I will see you giffy givers tomorrow brushing your teeth
oh I don't have my toothbrush here
I might like to do it tomorrow
I'll still work Matty's but we'll do it on stream tomorrow like after the
the foot part
but thank you so much for having me thank you for letting me do another
well it wasn't a fool endurance but it was almost a fool endurance it wasn't too bad
tomorrow is getting bulldozed
for monetization celebration so be there or be a square
I won't be up for too long definitely not an endurance stream
but please don't worry if you can't make it the void will remain up I will be
a good girl
just like you you'll be a good boy won't you
or a good girl
yeah only nine over a stream yeah just a little bit
but yes we will be good together and we don't need to worry
it should remain up
and I think that's everything I have to say
it's possible do we have to stagger our monetization
celebration days
or can I if I did two if I did two hours and then perfectly read into
she be yeah that's fine if she decides to do hers
as well because I'm not going to tell her not to do it you know
I'm not going to say no six hours shaking my head I'm such a fake
gamer I'm such a rubbish streamer nine hours
she said again okay I have to learn that being called a good boys
okay I've learned that being called a good boys move well it's supposed to make you weak in the
knees
for me it's simple okay you
behave you get rewarded
fair and simple exchange
oh you do have to go to 599 to avoid gifting
you're joking please tell me you're trolling me
and it's not 599
is it actually 599
I don't think I can charge that much that's not fair
mmm
why did gifting change does gifting not go to the lowest here
are we sure gifting doesn't do the lowest here
what's gifting so when someone is monetized
you can gift membership to other people and
um
I specifically am having you know what
we could test it on me
we could test it on me tomorrow
I know how to um dance the line
okay we'll test it on me tomorrow we'll see
what happens strongy street spot oh English strongy
speaks and my heart becomes weak 100% sure it doesn't
seen tons of channels with 199 split
let me let me cook
and I'll put the price that I want and I think it's fair and we'll see what happens
and if it's just an absolute cluster minuster then
we'll deal with a fallout on me at least and then the girls are unaffected
by any fallout
the fear of a thingy but I've never seen it happen
nah and it's like
I have to turn on being able to be gifted yes I would put it on because it's a big
income source and I have terrible news
I spent a lot of money
yeah failure wasn't cheap let's put it that way
yes not even fallout in new vegas
what about fallout in new vegas
I've seen 399 and 799 that's rubbish
if they use it they have to turn on being able to receive gifts
ok ok well that's a team effort
just a wee bit of money just a wee bit of pocket money
if so well
I will let you be carried away
to mercy gently well she gives you terrible advice
and we'll take it from tomorrow
and see if we
are able to make everything run smoothly
and if not thank you for the stream
bye amy
I modded like all of yumiya on my channel
oh yumiya your mod problem now
oh ho ho ho
yes I will see you all tomorrow for monetization stream I will update the picture
thing tomorrow I'll see if I can fix the skyrim achievements I don't know why they weren't
popping up because I am on game pass but we'll deal with it
thank you all so so much please enjoy mercy moddies to the fullest of your
ability and we'll see what a crazy fun
we get up to tomorrow and yeah yeah yeah as if everyone doesn't know exactly
what I'm up to right I'll see you tomorrow bye bye
bye bye see you tomorrow
and thank you for all the tips that was actually pretty intense today that was like a lot of tips
I'm not gonna lie I'll see you tomorrow bye bye